[Music]
big data is that technology that
revolutionized the IT industry this
Millennium and you can't think of big
data without thinking about Hadoop you
could say that without Hadoop much of
the big data we produce in our lives
would stay unmanaged and unprocessed hi
guys welcome to this complete Hardo
tutorial for beginners by simply learn
today we'll take you through everything
important that you need to know about
Hadoop AJ and Richard are industry
experts each with over 10 years of
experience in big data and its various
components will guide you on this
Learning Journey we will first start off
by giving you an understanding of Big
Data followed by how you can install
Hadoop on Windows and Ubuntu then we'll
go through the various components of the
Hadoop ecosystem in detail like the htfs
map ruce and Yan then we'll teach you
how scoop Hive Pig and HP work and how
you can practically implement each of
them you will learn about big data
analytics and some of the most popular
applications of Big Data following this
we'll tell you how you can become a big
data engineer and finally we've
handpicked 80 of the most important
questions that you might face in a big
data interview before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and click on
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn with that out of the
way over to you AJ now when we talk
about evolution of big data we have
known that data has evolved in Last 5
Years like never before now in fact
before going to Big Data or before
understanding these Solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards Big
Data technology and solution I would
like to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in Big Data why is there
Sudden Rush in Industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on Technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in Big Data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use Legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past 5 years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore any
data as being uneconomical now we can
talk about different platforms through
which data is generated take an example
of social media like Twitter Facebook
Instagram WhatsApp YouTube you have
e-commerce and various portals say eBay
Amazon Flipkart alibaba.com and then you
have various Tech Giants such as Google
Oracle sap Amazon Microsoft and so on so
lots of data is getting generated every
day in every business sector the point
here is that organizations have slowly
started realizing
that they would be interested in working
on all the data now the question which I
asked was why are organizations
interested in big data and some of you
might have already answered or thought
about that organizations are interested
in doing precise analysis or they want
to work on different formats of data
such as structured unstructured
semi-structured data organizations are
interested in gaining insights or
finding the hidden treasure in the so
called Big Data and this is the main
reason where organizations are
interested in Big Data now there are
various use cases there are various use
cases we can compare that organizations
from past 50 or more than 50 years have
been handling huge amount of data they
have been working on huge volume of data
but the question here is have they
worked on all the data or have they
worked on some portion of it what have
they used to store this data and if they
have used something to store this data
what is happening what is what is
changing now when we talk about the
businesses we cannot avoid talking about
the dynamism involved now any
organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
Solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on WhatsApp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on YouTube did
you guys know that YouTube is the second
largest search engine after Google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
Facebook Walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
Google 40,000 search queries are
performed on Google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that lot of times people
when they are loading up the Google page
is basically just to check their
internet connection however that is also
generating data IDC reports that by 2025
real time data will be more than a
quarter of all the data and by 2025 the
volume of Digital Data will increase to
163 zabt that is we are not even talking
about gigabytes or terabytes anymore we
are talking about betab bytes exabytes
and Zab bytes and Zab bytes means 10 to
^ 21 bytes so this is how data has
evolved now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about Facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
Facebook you could always check in
Google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also so search for
solution that is hadoo which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using Hado and that should
take you to the Wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using this
so-called solution called a doop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in Big Data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find hidden information
which probably they ignored earlier now
take an example of rdbms what is biggest
drawback in using an rdbms now you might
think that rdbms is known for stability
and consistency and organizations would
be interested in storing their data in
Oracle or db2 or MySQL or Microsoft SQL
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
first question which I would ask is do
we have access to 100% of data being
online in rdbms the answer is no we
would only have 10 or 20 or 30% of data
online and rest of the data would be
archived which means that if an
organization is interested in working on
all the data they would have to move the
data from the archived storage to the
processing layer and that would involve
bandwidth consumption now this is what
one of the biggest drawbacks of rdbms
you do not have access to 100% of data
online in many of the cases
organizations started realizing that the
data which they were ignoring as being
uneconomical had hidden value which they
had never exploited I had read a
presentation somewhere which said
torture the data and it will confess to
anything now that's the value of data
which organizations have realized in
recent past take an examp example of
Facebook now this shows what Facebook
does with its big data and we'll come to
what is Big Data but let's understand a
use case now Facebook collects huge
volumes of user data whether that is SMS
whether that is likes whether that is uh
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles Now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect Facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way Beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize The
Experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user Behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what Facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
to Facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how Facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something as I voted that was used for
2016 elections with reminders and
directions to tell users their time and
place of polling also something called
as safety checks in incidents such as
earthquake Hurrican or mass shooting
Facebook gives you safety checks now
these are some examples where Facebook
is using big data and that brings us to
the question what is Big Data this was
just an example where we discussed about
one company which is making use of that
data which has been accumulated and it's
not only for companies which are social
media oriented like Facebook where data
is important take an example of IBM take
an example of JP Morgan Chase take an
example of G or any other organization
which is collecting huge amount of data
they would all want to gather insights
they would want to analyze the data they
would want to be more precise in
building their services or Solutions can
take care of their customers so what is
Big Data big data is basically a term it
is used to describe the data that is too
large and complex to store in
traditional databases and as I gave an
example it's not just about storing the
data it is also about what you can do
with the data it also means that if
there is a lot of dynamism involved can
you change the underlying storage and
handle any kind of data that comes in
now before we get into that let's just
understand what is Big Data so big data
is basically a term which has been given
to categorize the data if it has
different characteristics organizations
would want to have the big data stored
processed and then analyzed to get
whatever useful information they can get
from this data now there are five vs of
Big Data volume velocity variety value
veracity although these are five vs but
then there are other vs which also
categorize the data as Big Data such as
volatility validity viscosity virality
of data okay so these are five vs of big
data and if the data has one or all of
these charactertistics then it can be
considered as Big Data including the
other ways which I just mentioned so
volume basically means incredible amount
of data huge volumes of data data
generated every second now that could be
be used for batch processing that could
be used for realtime stream processing
okay you might have data being generated
from different kind of devices like your
cell phones your social media websites
online transactions variable devices
servers and these days with iot we are
also talking about data getting
generated via internet of things that is
you could have different devices which
could be communicating to each other you
could be getting data from radar DS or
leads or even camera sensors so there is
a huge volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is big data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
lot of speed where it becomes difficult
to capture collect process cure mine or
analyze the data then we are certainly
talking about Big Data the next aspect
of big data is variety now this is where
we talk about structured data semi
structured data or unstructured data and
here I would like to ask a question what
what is the difference when do you call
the data is structured semi structured
or unstructured now let's look at an
example before we theoretically discuss
about this I always would like to use
some examples let's look at a log file
and let's see what is it so if I look at
this log file and if I would say what
kind of data is this which is the
highlighted one the answer would be it
is structured data it has specific D
limiters such as space it has data which
is separated by space and if I had a 100
or thousand or million rows which had
similar kind of data I could certainly
store that in a table I could have a
predefined schema to store this data so
I would call the one which is
highlighted as structured but if I look
at this portion where I would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a p turn and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if I would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if I look at all
the data then I would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can Define this data
now this is what I mean by variety of
data that is structure data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be EAS easily understood you
have semi structured which could be like
in XML or Json or even your Excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
a lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening and then finally you would
want to draw value from that data but
from all the data collected what
percentage of data gives us value and if
all my data can give me value then why
wouldn't I use it this is an aspect of
big data right veracity now this means
the quality of data billions of dollars
are lost every year by organizations
because the data which was collected was
not of good quality or probably they
collected lot of data and then it was
err anous take an example of autonomous
driving projects which are uh happening
in Europe or us where uh there are car
fleets which are on the road collecting
data via radar sensors and Camera
sensors and when this data has to be
processed to train algorithms it is
realized that sometimes s the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had lot
of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so extracting loads of data is
not useful if the data is messy or poor
in quality and that basically means that
veracity is a very important V of big
data now apart from veracity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different vs categorize the data
as big data we would like to talk on a
big data case study and we have taken an
example of Google which obviously is one
of the companies which is churning and
working on huge amount of data now it's
actually said that if you compare one
grain of sand with one bite of data then
Google is processing or Google is
handling Whole World's sand every week
that is the kind of data which Google is
processing now in early 2000 and since
then when the number of Internet users
started growing Google ALS also faced
lot of problems in storing increasing
user data and uh using the traditional
servers to manage that now that was a
challenge which Google started facing
could they use traditional data server
to store the data well yes they could
Right storage devices have been getting
cheaper day by day but then how much
time does it take to retrieve that data
what is the seek time what is the time
taken to read and process that data, of
search queries were raised per second no
doubt now we could say millions and
billions of queries are raised per
second every query read 100 MBS of data
and consumed tens of billions of CPU
Cycles based on these queries so the
requirement was that they wanted to have
a large distributed highly fault
tolerant file system large to store to
capture process huge amount of data test
distributed because they could not rely
just on one server even if that had
multiple discs stacked up that was not
an efficient Choice what would happen if
this particular machine failed what
would happen if the whole server was
down so they needed a distributed
storage and a distributed computing
environment they needed something which
can be highly fa tolerant right so this
was the requirement which Google had and
the solution which came out as a result
was GFS Google file system now let's
look at how GFS works so normally in any
particular Linux system or Linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
of files and directories which could
store the data GFS was different so to
facilitate GFS which could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master and
multiple Chun servers or you can say
slave servers
or slave machines Master machine was to
contain metadata was to contain data
about data when we say metadata we are
talking about information about data and
then you have the Chun servers or the
slave machines which could be storing
data in a distributed fashion now any
client or an API or an application which
would want to read the data would first
Contact the master server it would
contact the machine where the the master
process was running and client would
place a request of reading the data or
showing an interest of reading the data
internally what it is doing is it is
requesting for metadata your API or an
application would want to know from
where it can read the data Master server
which has metadata whether that is in
Ram or disk we can discuss that later
but then Master server would have the
metadata and it would know which are the
Chun servers or the slave machines where
the data was stored in a distributed
fashion Master would respond back with
the metadata information to the client
and then client could use that
information to read or write to these
slave machines where actually the data
was stored now this is what the process
or set of processes work together to
make GFS So when you say a Chun server
we would basically have the files
getting divided into fixed size junks
now how would they get divided so there
would be some kind of Chunk size or a
block size which you would determine
that if the file is bigger than the pred
decided chunk size then it would be
split into smaller chunks and be
distributed across the chunk servers or
the slave machines if the file was
smaller then it would still use one
chunk or a block to get stored on the
underlying slave machines so these chunk
servers or slave machines are the ones
which actually store the data on local
diss as your Linux files client which is
interacting with Master for metadata and
then interacting with chunk servers for
read write operations would be the one
which would be externally connecting to
the cluster so this is how it would look
so you have a master which would
obviously be receiving some kind of
heartbeats from the chunk servers to
know their status and receive
information in the form of packets which
would let the master know which machines
were available for storage which
machines already had dat and master
would build up the metadata within
itself the files would be broken down
into chunks for example we can look at
file one it is broken down into chunk
one and chunk two and file two has one
chunk which is one portion of it and
then you have file to resding on some
other chunk server which also lets us
know that there is some kind of Auto
replication for this file system right
and the data which is getting stored in
the chunk could have a data of 64 MB now
that chunk size could be changed based
on the data size but Google file system
had the basic size of the chunk as 64 MB
each chunk would be replicated on
multiple servers the default replication
was three and that could again be
increased or decreased as per
requirement this would also mean that if
a particular slave machine or a Chun
server would die or would get killed or
would crash there would never be any
data loss because it replica of data
residing on the failed machine would
still be available on some other slave
server chunk server or slave machine now
this helped Google to store and process
huge volumes of data in a distributed
Manner and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store huge amount of data
now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call all as had doop now when we talk
about Big Data here I would like to ask
you some questions that if we were
talking about the rdbms case take an
example of uh something like NASA which
was working on a a project called setti
search of extraterrestrial intelligence
now this was a project where they were
looking for a solution to take care of
their problem the problem was that they
would roughly send some waves in space
capture those waves back and then
analyze this data to find if there was
any extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer Computing now volunteer
Computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their RAM and Storage from
their machines when they're not using it
how would that happen basically download
some kind of patch on their machine
which would run as a screen saver and if
the user is not using his machine some
portion of data could be transferred to
these machines for intermittent storage
and processing using Ram now this sounds
very interesting and this sounds very
easy however it would have its own
challenges right think about security
think about integrity but those those
problems are not bigger as much as is
the requirement of bandwidth and this is
the same thing which happens in rdbms if
you would have to move data from
archived solution to the processing
layer that would consume huge amount of
bandwidth Big Data brings its own
challenges huge amount of data is
getting generated every day now the
biggest challenge is storing this huge
volume of data and especially when this
data is getting generated with lot of
variety where it can have different kind
of formats where it could be viral it
could be having lot of value and nobody
has looked into the veracity of data but
the primary problem would be handling
this huge volume of data variety of the
data would bring in challenges of
storing it in Legacy systems if
processing of the data was required now
here again I would suggest you need to
think what is the difference between
reading a data and processing a data so
reading might just mean bringing in the
data from disk and doing some IO
operations and processing would mean
reading the data probably doing some
Transformations on it extracting some
useful information from it and then
storing it in the same format or
probably in a different format so
processing this massive volume of data
is the Second Challenge organizations
don't just store their big data they
would eventually want to use it to
process it to gather some insights now
processing and extracting insights from
Big Data would take huge amount of time
unless and until there was an efficient
solution to handle and process this big
data securing the data that's again a
concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the CPU Cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to a doop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges Big Data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is Hadoop now what is Hadoop it's
a open source framework for storing data
and running applications on clusters of
commodity Hardware Hadoop is a open
source framework and before we discuss
on two main components of a dup it would
be good to look into the link link which
I was suggesting earlier that is
companies using Hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning Big
Data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having Hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so-called Hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which I would suggest is
looking at different
distributions of a doop any person who
is interested in learning in Big Data
should know about different
distributions of a doop now in Linux we
have different distributions like wiu
Centos Red Hat Suzie dbn in the same way
you have different distributions of
Hadoop which we can look on the Wiki
page and this is the link which talks
about products that include Apache
Hadoop or derivative works and
Commercial support which basically means
that Apache Hadoop the sole products
that can be called a release of Apache
Hadoop come from apache.org that's an
open source community and then you have
various vendor specific distributions
like Amazon web services you have Cloud
era you have hoton works you have IBM's
big Insight you have mapar all these are
different distributions of a doop so
basically all of these vendor specific
distributions are depending or using on
code Apache Hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the Apache Hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use Apache Hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor specific
distribution with its cluster
installation Solutions cluster
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage a cluster so
look into this link which talks about
different distributions of Hadoop coming
back what is Hadoop Hadoop is a open-
source framework for storing huge amount
of data and processing it it also
depends on commodity machines and it
does not need Carrier class Hardware now
when we say commodity machines we are
still talking about machines which are
higher than a basic laptop or a basic
server but then they are not at the
level of a carrier class hardware and
costing huge to the organization Hadoop
as a framework has two main components
or I would say two processing layers it
has a storage layer which is called hdfs
Hadoop distributed file system and it
has a processing layer which is called
Yan which can handle different
processing Frameworks in which Hadoop
map reduce is the oldest most mature and
most evolved processing framework sdfs
derives its existence from from GFS it
solves the issue of storing huge amount
of data in a distributed fashion and map
reduce is a programming model which
allows to process data which is
distributed across a cluster we will
learn on sdfs and map produce in further
slides sdfs is a storage layer now
compare your laptop compare your desktop
that also has a processing layer and a
storage layer your diss are your storage
layer your RAM and CPU core is your
processing layer similarly Hadoop as a
solution has a storage layer that is a
distributed file system which can store
huge amount of data in multiple machines
instead of a single machine or a single
server which basically makes it highly
reliable highly fault tolerant and
distributed for parallel processing
consider a data file of size 1 GB now if
that was getting stored in one single
machine we would still have the data
getting stored in one or multiple Diss
and if you would try to read the data
the seek time time taken to read the
data would be very high in comparison to
reading it from multiple machines now
sdfs like your GFS divides the file into
smaller chunks and stores the data
across theop cluster in previous
versions of Hadoop the default block
size was 64 MB however from Hadoop
version 2 onwards the block size is 128
MB now that's customizable depending on
the average size of the data which is
coming into the cluster the block size
can be changed the minimum block size is
128 MB which basically means that every
file which is less than or equal to 128
MB would use one block and any file file
which goes beyond the size of block will
use multiple blocks and these blocks
would be residing on the underlying
slave machines files are automatically
split by Hadoop framework into blocks of
default block size and stored across the
cluster each node in your Hado cluster
would have a bunch of diss that would be
storing these blocks now once we have
the data stored in a distributed fashion
that also gives us the flexibility of
going for distributed computing and when
we say distributed computing we are
talking about performing distributed
parallel processing on large volumes of
data take an example where we are
talking about one single machine or one
huge server which has four IO channels
and each input output channel can take
care of 100 megabytes of per second 100
megabytes of data per second so if we
have a data file of 1 tbte it would take
approximately 43 minutes for one machine
to process 1 tbte of data if you compare
that with distributed computing where we
are talking about hundreds of machines
each machine having similar number of
input output channels and each Channel
having the same capacity to handle 100
megabyte of data per second if a data
file of 1 tbte had to be processed in a
parallel processing fashion using
distributed computing it would take just
26 seconds for 100 machines to process 1
tbyte of data in this environment now
all of you might be thinking that yeah
this is right but then what about the
processing logic that might be
complicated and yes that would be but
then we have a map reduce programming
model and a processing framework to help
us doing that now when we look at one of
the distributions of dup that is hoton
works it also has different resources
that provide security to to your big
data now before we start talking on
these different services like Apache nox
Apache Ranger which basically allow you
to monitor authorize and audit your
Hadoop clusters let's also look at the
history of Hadoop which started in 1999
with Apache software foundation in 2002
where nut created by Duck cutting and
Mike Cella then duck cutting join dupe
and took nutch product with him 2008 nut
was divided and Hado was born and 2008
Yahoo released Hado as a open source
project to ASF in 2008 also Hadoop based
startup Cloud era Incorporated cutting
left Yahoo for cloud era Yahoo was then
coming out with hotton works as a
commercial Hadoop distribution mapa
technology also released Hadoop
distribution green plum released Hadoop
distribution and pivotal HD so this is a
brief on history of Hado you can always
read about history of evolution of Ado
how it started and today there are more
than 10 distributions which are existing
in Market however Cloud era is the
dominant one and as per recent news
items cloud and hoton works have merged
as one entity which will bring up better
solutions to the market here is a quick
demo on setting up Cloudera quick start
VM in in case you are interested in
working on a standalone cluster you can
download the cloud era quickart VM so
you can just type in download cloud era
quick start VM and you can search for
package now this can be used to set up a
quick start VM which would be a single
node cloud data based cluster so you can
click on this link and then basically
based on the platform which you would be
choosing to install such as you using a
VM box or which version of cloud era you
would install so here I can select a
platform so I can choose virtual box and
then you can click on get it now so give
your details and basically then it
should allow you to download the quick
start VM which would look something like
this and once you have the zip file
which is downloaded you can unzip it
which can then be used to set up a
single node Cloud era cluster so once
you have download loaded the zip file
that would look something like this so
you would have a quick start virtual box
and then a virtual boss disk now this
can be used to set up a cluster ignore
these files which are related to Amazon
machines and you don't need to have that
so you would just have this and this can
be used to set up a cloud data cluster
so for this to be set up you can click
on file import Appliance and here you
can choose your quick quick start VM by
looking into downloads quick start VM
select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of CPU Ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image. vmdk file into your BM box once
this is done we will have to change the
specifications or machines to use two
CPU CES minimum and get a little more
RAM because Cloud quickart VM is very
CPU intensive and it needs good amount
of ram so to survive I will give two CPU
cores and 5gb RAM and that should be
enough for us to bring up a quick start
VM which gives us a cloud era
distribution of Hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in Cloud era cluster
working with sdfs and other Hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
VM for our practice here the importing
of Appliance is done and we see Cloud a
quick start machine is added to my list
of machines I can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned I would
like to give it more RAM and more CPU
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least five and
click on processor and let's give it two
CPU cores which would at least be better
than using one CPU core Network it goes
for natat and that's fine click on okay
and we would want to start this machine
so that it uses 2 CPU course 5gb RAM and
it should bring up my Cloud Quick Start
VM now let's go ahead and start this
machine which has our quick start VM it
might take initially some time to start
up because internally there will be
various Cloud era Services which will be
starting up and those Services need to
be up for our Cloud era quick start VM
to be accessible so unlike your Apache
Hadoop cluster where we start our
cluster and we will be starting all our
processes in case of cloud era it is
your Cloud era SCM server and agents
which take care of starting up of your
services and starting up of your
different roles for those services I
explained in my previous session that
for a cloud era cluster it would be
these Services let me just show you that
so in case of Apache cluster we start
our services that is we start our
cluster by running script and then
basically those scripts will
individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud era we would always have a cloud
data SCM server which would be running
on one machine and then including that
machine we would have cloudm agents
which would be running on multiple
machines similarly if we had a hoton
Works cluster we would have ambari
server starting up on the first machine
and then ambari agents running on other
machines so your server component knows
what are the services which are set up
what are their configurations and agents
running on every node are responsible to
send hardbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping up of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start VM we would just have one SC
server and one SC agent which will start
on the machine which will then take care
of all the roles which need to be
started for your different services so
we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have cloudm server
and agent running and once we have that
we need to follow few steps so that we
can have the cloud admin console
accessible which allows you to browse
the cluster look at different Services
look at the roles for different services
and also work with your cluster either
using command line or using the web
interface that is H now that my machine
has come up and it already is connected
to the internet which we can see here we
need to do certain things so that we can
have our admin console accessible at
this point of time you can click on
Terminal and check if you have access to
the cluster so here type in host name
and that shows you your host name which
is quick start. Cloud error we can also
type in hdfs command to see if we have
access and if my cluster is working
these commands are same as you would
give them in a Apache Hadoop cluster or
in any other distribution of a doop
sometimes when your cluster is up and
you have access to the terminal it might
take few seconds or few minutes before
there is a connection established
between cloudm server and cloudm agent
running in the background which takes
care of your cluster I have given sdfs
DFS list command which basically should
show me what by default exists on my
hdfs let's just give it a couple of
seconds before it shows us the output we
can also check by giving a service cloud
ER SCM server status and here it tells
me that if you would want to use cloud
era Express free run this command it
needs 8 GB of RAM and at least two
virtual CPU cores and it also mentions
it may take several minutes before Cloud
era manager has started I can login as
rout here and then give the command
service Cloud era SC server status
remember the password for root is cloud
era so it basically says that if you
would want to check these settings it is
good to have Express Edition running so
we can close this my sdfs access is
working fine let's close the terminal
and here we have launch Cloud era
Express click on this and that will give
you that you need to give a command
which is force let's copy this command
let's open a different terminal and
let's give this command like this
which will then go ahead and shut down
your cloud data Based Services and then
it will restart it only after which you
will be able to access your admin
console so let's just give it couple of
minutes before it does this and then we
will have access to our admin console
here if you see it is starting the cloud
era manager server again it is waiting
for cloud manager API then starting the
cloud manager agents and then
configuring the deployment as per the
new settings which we have given as to
use the express edition of cloud era
once all this is done it will say the
cluster has been restarted and the admin
console can be accessed by ID and
password as cloudup we'll give it a
couple of more minutes and once this is
done we are ready to use our admin
console now that deployment has been
configured client configurations have
also been deployed and it has restarted
the cloud man Management Service it
gives you an access to Quick Start admin
console using username and password as
Cloud era let's try accessing it so we
can open up the browser here and let's
change this to
7180 that's the default port and that
shows the admin console which is coming
up now here we can log in as Cloud era
Cloud era and then let's click on login
now as I said Cloud era is very CPU
intensive and memory intensive so it
would slow down since we have not given
enough GB Ram to our Cloud era cluster
and thus it will be advisable to stop or
even remove the services which we don't
need now as of now if we look at the
services all of them look in a stop
status and that's good in one way
because we can then go ahead and remove
the services which we will not use in
the beginning and later we can anytime
add services to the cluster so for
example
I can click on key value store here and
then I can scroll down where it says
delete to remove this service from the
admin console now anytime you're
removing a particular service it will
only remove the service from the
management by Cloud manager all the role
groups under this service will be
removed from host templates so we can
click on delete now if this service was
depending on some other service it would
have prompted me with a message that
remove the relevant services on which
this particular service depends if the
service was already running then it
would have given me a message that the
service has to be stopped before it can
be deleted from the cloud era admin
console now this is my admin console
which allows you to click on Services
look at the different roles and
processes which are running for this
service we anyways have access to our
Cloud era cluster from the terminal
using our regular sdfs or Yan or map red
commands now I remove a service I will
also remove solar which we will not be
using for the beginning but then it
depends on your choice so we can here
scroll down to delete it and that says
that before deleting the solar service
you must remove the dependencies on the
service from the configuration of
following services that is Hue now Hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our Hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so I'll
click on none and I will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my Management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete it
remember I'm only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and I can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these Services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service I can click on the drop down
down and click on delete again this says
that scoop 2 also has relevance to Hue
so hu as a web interface also depends on
scoop 2 as of now we'll make it none at
any point of time later you can add the
services by clicking the add service
option now this is a cluster to which
you have admin access and this is a
quick start VM which gives you a single
node Cloud error cluster which you can
use for Learning and practicing so here
we'll click on scoop two and then we
will say delete as we have configured
the dependency now and we will remove
scoop two also from the list of services
which your admin console is managing
right so once this is done we have
removed three services which we did not
need we can even remove scoop as a
client and if we need we can add that
later now there are various other alerts
which your Cloud era admin console shows
and we can always fix them by clicking
on the health issue isues or
configuration issues we can click here
and see what is the health issue it is
pointing to if that is a critical one or
if that can be ignored so it says there
is an issue with a clock offset which
basically relates to an ntp service
network time protocol which makes sure
that one or multiple machines are in the
same time zone and are in sync so for
now we can click on suppress and we can
just say suppress for all host and we
can say look into it later and confirm
so now we will not have that health
issue reported that probably the ntp
service and the machines might not be in
sync now that does not have a impact for
our use case as of now but if we have a
caros kind of setup which is for
security then basically this offset and
time zone becomes important so we can
ignore this message and we are still
good to use the cluster we also have
have other configuration issues and you
can click on this which might talk about
the Heap size or the ram which is
available for machines it talks about
zookeeper should be in odd numbers Hue
does not have a load balancer sdfs only
has one data node but all of these
issues are not to be worried upon
because this is a single node cluster
setup so if you want to avoid all of
these warnings you can always click on
supress and you can avoid and let your
cluster be in all green status but
that's nothing to worry so we can click
on cluster and basically we can look at
the services so we have removed some
Services which we don't intend to use
now I have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically I'm good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as I said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
which you can use to add service so we
will just say restart my cluster which
will restart all the services one by one
starting from zookeeper as the first
service to come up we can always click
on this Arrow Mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using Hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on host and you
can have a look at all the host we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
roles it tells you what is the dis usage
it tells you what is the physical memory
being used and using this host tab we
can add new host to the cluster we can
check the configuration we can check all
the hosts in Diagnostics you can look at
the logs which will give you access to
all the logs you can even select the
sources from which you would want to
have the logs or you can give the host
name you can click on search you can
build your own charts you can also do
the admin stuff by adding different
users or enabling security using the
administration tab so since we have
clicked on restart of a cluster we will
slow slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in aache Hado cluster even here we can
click on hdfs and we can access the web
UI once our hdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web UI link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly Yan as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the Yan UI
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to H which will give
you the web interface which allows you
to work with your sdfs which allows you
to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud era SC
agent on every machine will be able to
restart the roles which are responsible
for your cluster to come up we can
always click here it tells that there
are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember hdfs
user user is the admin user and it does
not have a password unless you have set
one so you can just login as sdfs which
might ask you for password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloud error and then you
can log in as hdfs so that then onwards
you can give your hdfs commands to work
with your file system now since my
services are coming up right now when I
try to give a sdfs DFS command it might
not work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our hdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working using the command
line options from the terminal like what
you would do in appachi Hadoop cluster
you could use the web interfaces which
allow you to work with your cluster now
now this usually takes more time so you
will have to give it some time before
your services are up and running and for
any reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
VM and you can be using this to work
with your Cloud era cluster we will
learn today on setting up a Apache
Hadoop cluster although there are
various distributions of Hadoop as we
have already discussed and you could set
up a Apache Hadoop cluster which is the
core distribution you could be setting
up a cloud era distribution of a doop or
even a hoton Works however for cloud era
you would need machines which are really
powerful at least machines which have 16
GB of RAM and in which you can set up
multiple virtual machines each virtual
machine of at least four to 5 GB same
thing applies for hotton works or you
could always download and set up a cloud
era quick VM or a hotton Works sandbox
in this session we will learn how to set
up a Apache Hadoop cluster which is the
code distrib ution and if one has
learned how to set up Apache Hadoop
cluster then they would understand the
internals of setting up a cluster
different configuration properties which
are needed for your cluster setup now
for this we need to set up multiple
machines as you see on my screen and for
this you will have to download the Linux
dis image so we are using ubben 2 for
our cluster setup you can always go to
Google and type in ubben 2 disk image
ISO file and you could search for this
and that should show you a link like
this which says UB 2
16.04 you can click on this link and
depending on your machine so my machine
is 64bit machine and so I would download
this dis image which is already
downloaded on my machine and if your
machine is a 32-bit machine then you can
download this one which is 32bit PC i386
now to set up Apache cluster you could
even do it with a machine which has 4GB
RAM and you could easily set up at least
two virtual machines which can then be
used to set up your cluster now this
also needs you to download a
virtualization software so you can type
in download Oracle VM box it is pretty
lighter on the machine you can search
for the link you can easily say vikii
and that should show you the download
Oracle VM box now I would suggest going
for a older version rather than going
for the latest version probably because
that might have some more patches to be
installed and you can click on an older
version of virtual box and then based on
the machine which you have download the
relevant virtual box version once you
have downloaded Oracle VM box and once
you have downloaded the Linux dis image
you are ready to set up machines Within
your virtualization software which can
then be used to set up a cluster to set
up a machine click on new and here we
can give a name so let me give M1 I will
choose Linux and I will choose Windows
64bit now in certain cases people might
have problem in not being able to list
down Windows 64bit and that basically
means that you have to enable
virtualization in your bios settings so
restart your machine get into BIOS and
enable your virtualization and then you
should be able to see 64-bit option here
in any case and later if you face issues
with the Oracle VM box you can also go
for vmw workstation click on next and
this tells you that you would want to
allocate Ram so we can go for now with
1.5 GB depending on your machine you can
even give more RAM to your every
individual machine within your
virtualization software so I'll choose
1.5 GB click on next now here it says
create a virtual hard disk or do you
want to add a virtual hard disk so we'll
say create a virtual hard disk now click
on Create and then you can choose vmdk
that is virtual machine disk which will
also allow you to use the same dis image
in case you would want to use a
different virtualization software click
on next and then it says how do you want
your hard disk to be allocated so let's
go for dynamically allocated hard disk
that is as you store data on your disk
it will we'll be using your parent disk
storage click on next and here we can
give the size of our disk so I'll keep
it 20 GB that's more than enough for
machines which will be hosting my Apache
Hadoop cluster click on Create and we
have given the basic settings for my
machine however this does not have any
disk assigned to it so now while this is
highlighted click on settings and then
click on system here we can increase or
decrease the RAM we can even give more
CPU to our machine that is CPU course
you can click on storage and here where
it says empty click on this and from the
drop- down select your disk image which
you would have already downloaded now
let's click on network and to have my
Hadoop cluster set up I would need every
machine to have a different IP now I
could go for natat which is Network
address translator but then every
machine would have the same IP address
so it's good to go for bridge adapter
and if you are using your own personal
Network every machine setup will receive
a different IP address click on okay and
you have given all the settings for this
machine now you can click on start and
this will start your machine it will
recognize the disk image which you have
added and basically this should allow
you to give settings to set up your
first window machine let's just wait for
couple of seconds and that should give
me an option which says either try ubu
or install ubu and we will go ahead with
installation of ubben 2 distribution of
Linux for our machine now while this
comes up I can always set up one more
machine quickly by clicking on new
giving a different name choosing Linux
click on next let's give some Ram click
on next create a virtual hard disk now
click on create choose vmdk click on
next dynamic Al allocated hard disk
click on next give the size of your hard
disk and then click on create once this
is done repeat the steps click on
settings system processor let's give it
two CPU course storage click on empty
and then let's choose the disk image and
in network I will choose bridge adapter
once this is done click on okay and just
to a start of your second machine also
so we can parallely set up two machines
which which might approximately Take 5
to 10 minutes and once your machines are
up we can then go ahead installing some
relevant packages and Hadoop to set up
our Hadoop cluster now let's look at our
M1 machine and that's slowly coming up
using my dis image and once it comes up
I should be able to install UB 2 in M1
so here is my machine which is slowly
coming up and let's look at the second
machine if that is also coming up so
click on machine one here and it says
the connection is established so it is
using the bridge adapter which we have
chosen and then it should throw me the
options which allow me to go ahead with
installation
options here we can click on install
wtu it says download updates while
installing it's good to select this
click on continue it says erase dis and
install 2 and we are good to do that
because it's not erasing anything from
my parent disk it is doing this for this
particular machine so click on install
now it says if you continue the changes
listed below will be written to the disk
we are fine with that click on
continue and now let's choose the time
zone so in my case it shows Berlin in
your case it might show the city or the
country where you are in so click on
continue and don't worry if it says it's
disconnected from internet we don't need
internet as of now because we have
already added the dis image so the
language selected is English US unless
you would want to have it in a different
language click on
continue and it needs name so let me
give my name here I'll say what would be
my computer name so I'll say M1 I'll
give a username so we need to have a
common username across all the machines
which would be used for Hadoop cluster
so pick a username and type in a name
I'm giving SD see I'll give a simple
password for my machines and then click
on
continue so all the relevant things are
done for this machine and then we will
have to give it around 5 to 7 minutes
while it sets up everything and then
finally I will get a pop-up message
which says restart or reboot your
machine and my machine would be ready
the same things we'll do on my second
machine so I'll click on install luin 2
then we can select down download updates
while installing if it shows up and if
it says that there is no internet
connection nothing to worry we can
always come back to this click on
continue erase dis and install open 2 so
click on install now click on continue
let's give a time zone here and click on
continue we can always change the time
zone later also once this is done you
will have to give your machine a name
and then also a user which you have
already set up in machine one now we
would have a Hadoop cluster and we would
also have sdfs which would use the file
system from M1 and M2 does we need to
have a common user which is set up in
all the machines which you would use for
your Hadoop cluster setup so wait till
it gives you different options and
carefully select your machine name your
username and give it a simple password
click on continue
and here I'll give my name I'll say this
will be my machine 2 I'll say HDC as the
user I'll give a simple password and
let's click on continue now we will have
to wait for 5 to 7 minutes my first
machine is already being set up and my
second machine will start now once both
the machines are set up and once I get a
message please reboot your machine we
will have to wait both of my machines
are almost about to be set up and they
will give me an option to reboot now
meanwhile what you can also do is you
can download the cloud era quick start
VM so you can just type in download
cloud era quick start VM and you can
search for the package now this can be
used to set up a quick start VM which
would be a single node Cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically B based on the
platform which you would be choosing to
install such as using a VM box or which
version of cloud era you would install
so here I can select a platform so I can
choose virtual box and then you can
click on get it now so give your details
and basically then it should allow you
to download the quick start VM which
would look something like this and once
you have the zip file which is
downloaded you can unzip it which can
then be used to set up a single node
Cloud era cluster so once you have
downloaded the zip file that would look
and something like this so you would
have a quick start virtual box and then
a virtual boss dis now this can be used
to set up a cluster ignore these files
which are related to Amazon machines and
you don't need to have that so you would
just have this and this can be used to
set up a cloud data cluster which we can
learn in further sessions there is
another option that you could just be
setting up one machine and then your VM
box has an option of cloning the machine
where you can set up one machine with
all the details like Java hadu packages
and other relevant packages and then you
can clone it but then you will have to
take care that both the machines should
have different IP which means once the
machines are up and if you have cloned
the machine then you would have to
manually change the IP address in the
machines so either you could go for this
option or do it as I'm doing here that
is set up two machines individually now
it would give you this message which
says installation is complete you need
to restart the computer in order to use
the new installation click on restart
now and that should restart my M1 and
similarly I get a message for M2 so I'll
click on restart now and both my Mach
machines should restart so click on M1
again and here it might say you have to
remove the installation media so we can
click on enter and this should basically
start my machine same thing applies to
Machine 2 so this will also say remove
the installation media and we were just
using a dis image so we have to just hit
on enter and that should basically bring
up my machine it will also be advisable
that if your machine is low on RAM you
can set up one machine and then you can
use SSH related utilities to copy the
data from one machine to other machine
so let's click on machine one and let's
go ahead and set this up now we will
have to install some packages like wget
which allows you to download things from
internet we will have to download Hado
package we will also have to download
Oracle jdk which will be used although
Apache works with open jdk it is
advisable that we go for Oracle jdk and
UB 2 machines by default do not have
Java installed so we will have to
download the Oracle jdk package untar it
and then set up our Java and these steps
have to be repeated on both the machines
so that my both machines can be used for
a cloud era
cluster so I'm waiting for my M1 machine
to come up so that I can check its IP
address I can update its IP address and
host name and then I can start
downloading the packages which will be
needed for setting up aoop cluster so my
machine one is up here I can click in
the password box and I can given my
simple password which I had set up for
my machine one and hit on enter so that
should allow you to log in and same
thing applies to Machine 2 which is
still coming up so let's go back to
machine one and let's wait for its basic
utilities and program s to come up so
that we can start configuring our
machine now remember if you can
configure your machine in the simple way
and as smooth as possible then setting
up your cluster will become a cakewalk
so you can click on cancel if there are
some issues like this no need to worry
about it we are going for a simple
Apache cluster on two notes so meanwhile
let me also log in to Machine 2 by
giving in my password and then hit on
enter now in both my machines on the
right corner you might see the Double
Arrow marks which basically tells that
your machine should be connected to
Internet and you should have no problem
in downloading packages from internet
however if you have some issues then we
will have to troubleshoot those and make
sure that you can at least set up one
machine which can also allow you to set
up a Apache Hadoop pseudo distributed
cluster that is a single node cluster
however to have the feel of a two node
cluster or at least a three node cluster
it would be good to have two machines up
and running both connected to Internet
both having Java both have their IP
addresses updated and both having the
Hado package downloaded so now my
machine one is up it looks like it is
connected to internet from the right
corner I can click on this and then I
can type in
terminal and click on
Terminal
so this is my terminal and I'm already
logged in as HDC user which I had
selected in the beginning so let's start
by typing in if config which gives me
the IP address of machine it is
0.16 and what I will do is I will log in
as root by typing in sud sudo Su and giv
your
password you're logged in as root come
back to the Parent Directory and then
let's go to Etc host where I will update
the IP address of this machine which is
192.168.0.1
2016 here let's get rid of this and
let's say
0.116 and my host name of this machine
is M1 so let's update this now I could
get the IP address of my other machine
also so that I could basically make
these machines ping each other so let's
do the same thing here I will type in
terminal and click on this and let's
quickly get the IP address of this
machine which should be a different IP
address than my machine one so let's
type in if have config and this says
0.217 which I will update here so I will
say 192 168
0.217 and that's my machine 2 and same
thing we'll do it in Machine 2
also so let's go to Machine 2 let's
login as root let's give the password
and then let's go into Etc
host remove the erroneous entry and then
give
192.168
0.116 which is my machine one 192 168 0.
217 that is Machine 2 and then save it
and let's check if my machine 2 can ping
machine one using the host name and that
works perfectly fine let's do the same
thing for machine one so we'll say ping
Machine 2 and that should also work
fine it would also be good and required
that we disable firewall so we can say
ufw disable the firewall on machine
one and let's repeat the same on Machine
2 so
ufw
disable and the firewall should be
disabled even in Machine 2 so both the
machines can ping each other both the
machines have firewall disabled their
Etc host is updated and as I said both
machines would not have Java installed
so if we check by giving a command Java
minus version or Java hyphen version it
will say Java is not installed which
basically means that we need to have
Oracle jdk installed on both the
machines or at least download the JD
package on one machine which can then be
copied across other machine so we are
logged in as root and let's first
quickly start installing some packages
so I'll say appg install WG now this can
be used to download packages from
internet and we will download wget
it's done now let's also install open
SSH server so that we can later have a
passwordless access from one machine to
other machine using SSH so I'm
installing open SSS server I've already
installed wget and these two packages
should be enough to begin with we also
need the Oracle jdk to be downloaded
from web so my open SSS setup is almost
done here now let's repeat these steps
quickly on M2 so I'll say apt get
install W get now if you get this kind
of message which basically means that
some other process is using it then we
can always open a quickly different
terminal and that itself should resolve
the issue so now let's go in here and
let's try again it still doesn't work
now let me just log in as root give the
password and then let's try doing this
or we will have to kill the process yeah
so it says there is some kind of lock
now I'm already logged in as root so I
can just say remove from where lib D
package SL loock and then let's try
doing it again it still gives a problem
let's again try doing a installation
step and sometimes you might have this
kind of error message where it says it's
not able to receive a lock or unlock so
let's go in here let's check what do we
have in where lib D package there is a
lock
file and we will have to remove
this okay and now does that work yeah so
now it says it could not get a lock on
some other file so let's remove that
also which is cache archives lock file
and let's try it
again and it's working so sometimes we
might have such issues and we have to
quickly look what is the reason might be
you can always do a Google and try to
fix those issues so it's trying to
connect to Archive and basically
download the package we'll come back to
this machine let's go to machine one
where we had installed W get an open SSS
server we need Java so let's open up the
browser and then let's search for for
Oracle jdk and we can go for 1.8 or even
1.9 that doesn't matter we basically
need a Java to be set up on our machines
now if you look in the usual path which
is user lib there might not be a
directory such as jvm we can see what is
in user lib and it has various other
things but nothing which points to Java
so let's go to our browser and let's
type Oracle jdk
1.8 now that is what I'm interested in
setting up on both the machines let's
look at our Machine 2 status it is still
trying to connect and we might have to
give it some time that's why I was
mentioning that we can always go set up
one machine perfectly and once that is
done we can always do a clone or we can
copy or download the packages now here I
have the package or the link which
points me to Oracle jdk 1.8 let's click
on this
link it will ask you to accept the
agreement by giving your choices and
this is only for the first
time so I say I accept all
cookies and then it basically shows me
the packages here so let's scroll up and
we have different releases of eight now
you don't need to go for a very old one
but then it would be good to have a
stable one one so I can say accept
license agreement and then since mine is
a 64-bit machine I can go for x64 tar
file and that should download my Java
related tar file additionally we also
need Hadoop package so we can open up a
different browser and I can straight
away say
archive.
apache.org although you could also
search for Apache releases and you could
download now this archive page will not
only show you Hado but it will show you
all different Apache packages which can
be downloaded and then we can set up on
our machines so click on Archive of
public software releases and here we
will search for Hadoop click on Hadoop
and then Hadoop has different components
or projects you can say common or core
so click on common and here it lists
down all the different versions of Hado
so let's scroll down and let's pick a
stable one now you can also download the
latest version and set up that but I
would suggest go for a stable one so
let's click on Hadoop
2.6.5 and here we will download the
Hadoop related tar
file again to repeat we will need the
Hado tar file we will need the Java to
be installed on all the nodes so my Java
is getting downloaded my Hadoop is
getting downloaded and these are the two
things which I need to set up my Ado
cluster let's check what is happening in
Machine 2 so it has already downloaded
wget now let's also get open SSH server
here and let it install but I will not
download my Hadoop and Java here because
we have the tar file downloaded on first
machine and once we have a SSS set up we
can always copy the tar files from my
machine one to machine
two let's go back here and let's give it
just one minute and it will download the
packages meanwhile what we can also do
is we can go to the terminal and we can
give our user that is SDC root
privileges so that for any other root
related work we don't have to switch to
root user every time so let's click on
this terminal and basically add our user
to the Pudo list
so here let's clear screen I'm logged in
as root so let's type in viudo hit enter
and here scroll down to the line which
says root and here I can say Escape I I
can say HDC and I can say my HDC user
should have the same privileges as root
now let's say control X twice and just
save it and enter so now your user HDC
will also have the root privileges and
can give a Pudo command now we have also
downloaded our packages in this path so
we have Hadoop we have Java and we need
to basically unpack them we basically
need to untar them so both of them have
been downloaded so let's close these
browsers let's go in here and first
thing what I'll do is I will unar or I
will change my directory to user lib I
will create a direct
here called jvm I will switch to jvm and
then I will say tar xvf home HTC
downloads and then given my jdk package
which needs to be untar here so this is
basically unpacking my jdk tar file
which will create a jdk based directory
which will have the binaries for my
Java once this is done we should have ja
Java installed on this machine it's done
and let's see this is my jdk and if you
look in jdk SL bin these are my Java
related programs so my Java path is user
lib jvm jdk so let's go to this
directory and let's copy this
path and let's update it in the bash
file of root and my dedicated user so
every user has as a bash RC file or a
bash profile now I will update in bash
RC export
javore home let's give this path let's
say export
path Java uncore home/ bin so I can give
my Java commands from anywhere and let's
copy this so that we can update the same
thing in HDC user let's save this and
let's refresh this file using a show
bashrc okay now we can test if my Java
version shows up for my root user and
that shows
1.8.0 this is done you can optionally
also install Vim which basically gives
you a good layout when you are editing
your files in different colors Some
people prefer using Vim when they are
editing their files and I'll show you
the difference once you have viim
installed we can always look into the
same bash RC which will show in multiple
colors remember we need to update the
Java path for our HDC user so now first
let's look at the bash RC file and look
at this this basically tells you the
path which you have set up now same
thing we'll do for our HDC user so let's
log in as
HDC let's get into bash
RC and here I will say
give your Java path save it refresh
it and your Java version should show up
even if you're logged in as HTC so my
Java setup is done now I also need to
untar my Hadoop related directory which
we downloaded and we will do that in a
particular location so let's switch to
user local directory now you could do
that anywhere I'm doing it here and I'll
say sud sudo tar
xvf home HDC downloads and then my
Hadoop related tar file which I would
want to unpack here and this also shows
that my pseudo access works fine for my
SDC user this is unpacking my Hadoop tar
file in the chosen
location and once this is done we will
have a Hado directory created under user
local
let's look and I have a Hadoop directory
which is owned by HDC user and it will
always be good to have our Hadoop path
more simple rather than having user
local Hadoop
2.6.5 so I will create a link and I will
call it doop so sometimes you have to
use the Pudo permission because you're
in local directory and then let's change
the ownership to HDC see for anything
which starts with Hadoop once this is
done we have our link which is Hadoop
pointing to Hadoop 2.6.5 which is also
beneficial if you would want to use a
different version of Hadoop you could
always unlink Hadoop and create a link
pointing to your newer version you don't
have to then change the Hadoop path in
your bash RC every time you work on a
different version so once this is done
let's look into Hadoop and this
basically has a bin directory which has
my binaries or you can say the programs
or commands which we will use to work
with Hardo it has a sbin directory which
basically has the startup scripts and it
has Etc directory which has Hado and
that has my config files so first let's
set the Hado path for my user so I will
go to bash RC file again and here I can
add some lines so I'll say export
Hadoop uncore install so earlier the
parameter was Hadoop _ home but now it's
Hadoop _ install we'll say
user
local Hadoop then we will say
export path you can do it in different
ways so let's keep it simple and let's
say Hadoop uncore install /bin so that I
can give my Hadoop commands from
anywhere rather than going to use user
local Hadoop and similarly I'll say
export path Hadoop undor install SL sbin
so that I can even give my startup and
stop scripts from anywhere in the
machine rather than going to the Hadoop
specific path once this is done save it
and refresh it and if all is fine we
should be able to check our Hadoop
version by giving a Hadoop command so we
have set up our JV
we have unpacked Hadoop and we have
given the entries in my bash RC same
things have to be repeated on Machine 2
but not yet now first thing what we will
do is we will set up a passwordless
access across machines so that I can log
in from machine one to Machine 2 or vice
versa without a password which will also
be needed when you set up a Hadoop
cluster and start your processes across
machines if your SSS setup is done it
will avoid you to given password of your
machines individually so let's say
SSH key gen hyphen T RSA hyphen capital
P and without a passphrase let's set up
SS key which now has created a SSH
directory that has a private and public
key and for our SSH to work fine we need
to have the public key transferred to
other machine now let's go to m 2 and
let's generate the SSH key on M2 also so
our SSH server is already installed as
we did on my first machine we will also
say appt get install
whm we also need to make sure that our
user here has the root access so while
this is getting done you can always open
up a new terminal you can login as
root and you can can go to
viudo and here we will add our user
which is HDC like what we did on first
machine
all
all control X twice do a yes and enter
so we have given the user here the
Privileges to give a sudo command this
is what we did on machine one now this
machine is reacting little slow where it
needs to generate a or it needs to
download a package meanwhile let's open
up a terminal and let's do the SSH key
part which doesn't need downloading and
always remember your SSH keys are user
specific so here SSH key gen hyphen T
RSA hyphen capital P and it's done so we
can check even on this machine we have a
SSH directory and and that has private
and public keys so what we need to do is
we need to copy our public key from
machine one to Machine 2 and from
Machine 2 to machine 1 so here I'll say
SSH copy ID hyphen I I'll give my home
directory I'll say take the RSA public
file and let's copy it to
SDC
M2 say yes and give your password so
that should have copied your public key
and once you have done that you can
always look in SSH now you have a known
undor host file which has entry of
Machine 2 where you have copied your
public key if you look on Machine 2 in
my other
terminal and if I look in SSH it has
authorized keys so when you copy your
public key from machine one to Machine 2
in machine two we have authorized keys
and in machine one one we have known
uncore host now let's repeat the same
step here let's say home. SSH idore RSA
dopu and let's copy it to HDC at M1 say
yes and give the password and that
should have copied your public key to M1
now if you look in SSH this also has
noore host and if we look in M1 that
will have authorized keys which
basically means your SSH setup should be
fine let's test by typing in SSH M2 and
that should allow me to log into M2
without a password let's log out and
let's check the same thing from M2
ssm1 and that works fine we also need to
copy our public keys to the same machine
so I'll say cat from my home directory
idore RS say. public and let's append it
to the same location in SSH directory in
authorized uncore Keys once this is done
test SSH to M2 from M2 itself say yes
and it works fine do a log out and let's
do the same thing on M1 so cat home. SSH
idore RSA dopu let's append it in same
location
in authorized uncore Keys Let's test SSH
to itself say yes and that's fine this
will also be required when we set up a
cluster and we start our processes that
is Hado specific processes on the
machine it will not ask for password
because you have set up SSH across
machines and locally to itself now once
this is done we basically have two
machines which can not only ping each
other but they can also do a SSH to each
other let's also check in Machine 2 if
my installation of whim is done and
that's also done now what we also need
is on this machine that is M2 we
basically need the Java package and we
need the Hadoop package so let's copy
from machine one so I can copy the
complete directory or I can copy the tar
file so I would suggest copying the tar
files and then unpacking them so that we
can have less data transferred over
Network so I can say SCP home HDC
downloads let's take the jdk package and
let's copy it to HDC at M2 in the temp
directory so this shows that you don't
need to download jdk and had on all the
machines just download it on one machine
and then copy it across once your SSH is
set up similarly we can copy the Hadoop
tar file to to the other machine also
this is an easier way in fact you could
write your bash scripts or anible
scripts to deploy all the packages
across the machines now let's go to M2
and here we can then first create a
directory in user lib and call it as jbm
like what we did on first machine and
then I can change my location to jvm I
can say sud sudo tar xvf
and then from temp I'll get the jdk
package and I'll unpack it here once
this is done we need to make sure that
our bash RC is updated or we can even
copy that from machine 1 to Machine 2
now this should create a jdk directory
here on Machine 2 as it did on machine
one and that's owned by if there is a
problem with ownership it's good to
change the ownership manually to root in
case that creates a problem later once
this is done we have our jdk let's see
if everything is fine and it's fine now
similarly I will go to user local
directory I will say sudo tar xvf from
temp let's unpack the doop in user local
location as we did on machine one and
once this is done we need to create a
link we need to change the ownership and
we need to update the bash RC and this
is done now I can see I have a Hadoop
directory it's owned by HDC okay I can
create a link to this call it as Hadoop
let's change the ownership to HDC of
anything that starts with Hadoop and we
have our Hadoop path also set correctly
now all I need is from my machine one
while I'm logged in as SDC I'll say SCP
copy copy The Bash RC from here into HDC
M2 in home HDC which has my Java path my
Hado path updated let's go here and
let's do a source bash RC and then let's
check if my Java version shows up
correctly that's fine let's check if
Hadoop version shows up correctly and
that's fine so now we have two machines
which have Java which have Hadoop
package which can ping each other which
have SSH access and which have firewall
disabled these two machines can then be
used to set up my Hado cluster once we
start editing the config files and that
config files can be found in user local
Hadoop Etc Hadoop in both the
machines user local Hadoop Etc Hadoop
this is where we will edit our config
files and then we are ready to bring up
our cluster which will be a two node
cluster for my Hadoop my strategy would
be on M1 machine I would have a name
node I would have a data node I would
have a resource manager and I would have
a node manager running on my M2 machine
I would have a data node I would have a
node manager and I would have a
secondary name node running so this is
the plan for cluster setup on these two
machines to set up our Hadoop cluster we
will need the config files and I have
updated my config files in GitHub link
so let's go to GitHub you can always
refer to this git link which I'm showing
on the screen where I have the config
files
updated and we can just just easily copy
our config files from here so let's
click on this link and here I have given
the config files so we can click on
Hadoop
2.6.5 and this basically has my five
important config files which we need to
update in both the machines now let's go
to machine one and here let's go to user
local
Hadoop Etc Hadoop and here the first
config file which I will update is core
hyphen site file let's get into this
which has nothing as configuration
specified now as I mentioned when I was
explaining hdfs that in Apache Hadoop we
would have to download the Hadoop
related package we will have to edit the
configs we would have to do the
formatting and then we would have to
start the cluster however if it was
Cloud error or hoton works or any other
vendor specific distribution downloading
the packages editing the config files
formatting the cluster would be taken
care by your installer now here let's go
to the git link and let's get the
contents of core hyphen site file which
basically tells the hdfs path the
location where my name node would run
and the port to which my name node will
listen to so let's click on core hyphen
site file and get the config files or
the properties scroll down and we just
need to give this although there can be
many other properties which can be
specified but we will just go for a
simple setup copy this come to your
terminal and here I can just paste it
now this tells the property is fs.
default FS which is also used if
developers are coding their file system
API and would would want to connect to
sdfs now here I will change my machine
machine name M1 and this is the machine
where my name node will run and it will
use 9,000 Port sdfs colon SL M1 9000
let's save this and our first config
file is edited now the next file which
we would want to edit is maed hyphen
site file and what we can do here is my
maed file shows up as template so I'll
just rename
it as maed hyph site. XML and then let's
edit it which tells what processing
framework we would be using or what
processing layer we will be using let's
go to the git link again and
let's pick up the information of map red
hyphen site file which is here and the
processing layer which we will be using
is Yan so let's copy this again there
can be many more properties specifying
your your values of memory for map and
ruse and many other properties we will
just go for a basic setup which is more
than enough even to test out all the
functionalities of a do cluster so my
processing framework will be Yan let's
save this and we have edited the second
file similarly we will also edit my
third file which is hdfs hyphen site
file so let's go into this which
basically tells what will be my
replication Factor
where will my name node store metadata
on disk if I plan to run a data node
here where will data Note store the
blocks and so on so let's go to hdfs
hyphen site file let's give the
properties so let's go in here and let's
get the content of hdfs hyphen site file
scroll down and let's get all these
values that is
replication the path of metadata on disc
dis the path where my data blocks will
get stored what is the HTTP Port my name
node will use what is the HTTP Port my
secondary name node will use and my
secondary name noes checkpointing
frequency which is by default 1 hour but
we will be setting it up as 10 minutes
let's copy this and here I will paste it
now let's make some changes here quickly
so I plan to run two data nodes so I can
go for a replication of at least two
since I'm planning to run two data notes
I've given a metadata path that this is
the path where my name node will store
metadata on disk metadata on RAM is
dynamically built metadata on disk needs
a path that's why we are giving this as
we plan to run name node here we also
plan to run a data node here and we will
give the path for my data node to store
its blocks now remember since we are in
Apache hadoo cluster we will have to
create this ABC directory the name and
data directory will get automatically
created now this also tells what HTTP
Port my name node will use and here I
will specify my name node would run on
M1 and it will use an HTTP Port 570 for
my secondary name node I would want it
to run on my other machine so I'll
specify M2 and it will use 59 Port now
since I'm planning to run my secondary
name node on my second machine I don't
need to give this property here I'll
give this property in my M2 machines
hdfs file so let's delete this and our
htfs is set up the next file which we
need to edit is Yan hyphen site file
which tells about your resource manager
your resource tracker and some other
properties so let's go into Yan hyphen
site file and let's get the values from
here which if you scroll down you should
be able to find and scroll down and you
have these four properties now there can
be many other properties as I said like
specifying how much memory you want to
allocate for node manager or how many
CPU CES or do you want to enable or
disable physical or virtual memory check
or do you want to enable log aggregation
so you can copy all these properties
from yany site
file and let's place it in
my
machine now these are all my properties
let's carefully check if everything is
fine my resource manager is intended to
run on M1 if you want to run it on some
other machine then you would have to
give the host name of that machine my
resource tracker which helps your
resource manager to know about resources
we'll also run on M1 but on a different
port I have some Shuffle classes which
are relevant now this property tells how
much amount of memory you would want to
allocate for your node manager on this
machine now either we could keep it
minimum or we could let Yan decide it
for us so let me get rid of this and the
CPU course so the default memory and the
default core which Yan will assume for
your machines for your node managers
would be 8 GB and8 course rest
properties can be left as they are you
don't need to make any
changes save them and your yarn is also
done now we will edit a slaves file
which tells on which machines will my
data nodes run and hence my node
managers run so I'll say M1 and M2 so my
five main files are edited which is core
site map red site sdfs Yan and slaves
now you can also edit Hadoop environment
and Yan environment but that's not
mandatory which mentions about your Java
path which mentions the Heap size that
is the amount of ram which will be used
when your process comes up the default
value is 1 GB and you don't need to make
changes so let it be as it is I don't
make any changes to Hadoop environment
now once these config files are edited
let's quickly copy them across M2 and
then we can edit them in M2 I'll say SCP
take the core file and let's copy to SDC
M2 in user local Hadoop Etc Hadoop
that's the path done let's copy the
other files also which is my map red
file so MapIt file let's copy this let's
copy the Yan file slaves file and inst
DFS
file so that's my Yan
file let's copy the hdfs file and let's
copy the slaves file so all my files are
copied or should have been copied by
now to my M2 machine and then we can
accordingly update the things in M2 and
I don't need to really switch to M2 I
can just say SSH
M2 because I can log in from here I can
go into user local Hadoop Etc Hadoop and
now we can look in the core file which
doesn't need any changes because this
tells what would be your sdfs path and
where your name node runs and this would
be same because we would have data nodes
running on every machine talking to the
name node so they need to know where
your name node is running on what port
so we don't make any changes to the Core
file map red file doesn't need any
change so here we have the framework as
Yan also what you can do is to make sure
remove if there is any template file
let's look into hdfs file and this will
have some changes so replication no that
doesn't need a change do we need a path
which tells where metadata is stored no
because our name node does not run on
this
machine do we need a path for data node
yes and let's give just a naming
convention let's add a number two here
which tells me that this is second data
node HTTP Port is fine secondary name
nodes Port is fine and then we can give
the checkpoint period property which
tells how frequently should my secondary
name node do the checkpointing now as I
said the default time frame is 1 hour
but then we can set it to a lower time
frame by giving a
property that is in my hdfs file which
we had deleted from machine one but we
will retain it in Machine 2 this is the
property which tells what is the
frequency of checkpointing that
secondary name node should follow so
let's give it here and this says every
10 minutes I would want my secondary
name node to do a checkpointing and have
a copy of metadata of name node that
name node stores on the disk now I'm not
specifying a path where secondary name
notes should keep a copy of name notes
metadata on disk and by default my
secondary name node will store it in
Temp and that's fine for now so let's
save this now let's also look in Yan
file if we need any change which tells
resource manager will run on M1 that's
fine resource tracker will run on M1
that's fine Shuffle classes some other
properties which tell don't check for
phys physical and virtual memory and log
aggregation so we really don't make any
change to our Yan file and our slaves
file which tells where my data noes will
run that means where my data noes and
node managers will run we don't make any
changes so all my config files are
edited on M1 and on M2 now don't forget
to create the directory which you have
mentioned in the config files that is
ABC and make sure that our HDC user has
the permissions to this or you might
have some failures so I'll say ABC
that's done let's do the same thing on
M1 and let's change the
ownership of this directory now once all
these steps are done are both the
machines are set up to basically have a
Hadoop cluster running but that cannot
happen without we doing a for formatting
formatting is the first step which will
create the initial metadata in the
metadata path so as of now we have
nothing in ABC directory so we will do a
formatting of sdfs which basically
prepares the hdfs to store the data so
I'll say hdfs name node format and this
has to be given only once because this
creates the initial metadata in the name
nodes path which we have mentioned in
his DFS file once the formatting is done
no matter how many times you restart
your machines you'll never do a
formatting again because if you do a
formatting again it will bring your
cluster to the initial State let's do a
formatting which should create my
initial meta data in the ABC directory
and that would also create a slame
directory as we have specified in our
config files once this is done have a
look at your ABC directory and that has
name name has current and in current you
have the initial FS image which is the
file system image which tells as of
2327 your machine has this now once this
is done we can also look into ABC slame
SLC current and here we can look into
the version file which has the initial
identifiers that is your namespace ID
cluster ID and blockpool ID and this was
the reason I mentioned that you should
never ever do a formatting again because
reformatting will change these
identifiers and set them to new ones
however your data notes which will also
have a copy of these might not get
updated now once your formatting is done
once your initial metadata is created we
can just say start hyphen all Dosh and
this script internally will run to two
scripts this script internally triggers
start DFS Dosh and start Yan Dosh and
internally these scripts actually run
Hadoop demon. sh start and then your
process name such as name node or data
node or secondary name note and Yan
demon. sh start resource manager and
node managers for more information you
can always refer to the sbin directory
which talks about these scripts or which
shows these scripts which you can check
in user local Hadoop sbin which has the
individual or startup scripts so now
let's click on start hyphen all Dosh and
if everything is fine it should
basically start your cluster now it says
the script is deprecated use start DF
and start Yan but it will still work now
since we have set up SSH access it does
not ask or prompt for a password it
starts your name node it starts your
data nodes and then it will basically
start your secondary name node and
resource manager finally your node
managers so we will have a two node
cluster now which uses two machines
which we set up that is M1 and M2 it has
one sing single name node it has two
data nodes one secondary name node and
it will have one resource manager which
is the master of processing layer and
then two node managers which are the
processing slaves we can always check
the processes using JPS command for Java
related
processes and we can check on other
machine for my
processes and we have a two node cluster
up and running which has two data nodes
two node managers one name node one
resource manager and one secondary name
node we can also look into the ABC
directory on M2 which will now have a
directory for data node and that will
have a version file which can be looked
into for identifiers and you can always
look into a different version file which
is here so you have two version files
and both of these version file have the
identifiers which they have received
from the name note where will my blocks
get stored it will be stored in current
finalized and then it will be within
this path if we write data to hdfs where
my blocks will come and get stored let's
check the same thing on machine two
which only had a name directory in ABC
which now also has a data directory and
similarly it has the version file at
under current directory or a version
file which is under the block pool
directory so this is my two node cluster
we can quickly give a command that is
hdfs DFS admin report or you can always
check what are the options in hdfs by
typing in hdfs and here you have an
option called DFS admin again you can
check for all the different options with
DFS admin and here on the top we will
have an option called report so these
are all the commands used by an admin so
you have report live dead or
decommissioning so we can check how many
notes we have by typing in hdfs DFS
admin report which should show me that I
have two data notes how much of those
notes is configured for distributed file
system how much is for local machine are
there responding to name node by looking
at the last contact time which will get
updated every 3 seconds and and you have
machine one and machine two which are
two nodes or two live data nodes of your
Hado cluster this is via a command we
can always go and use the browser and
look at the web UI so I can check M1
using its HTTP port to have a look at my
name node which tells me what is my
cluster ID what is my blockpool ID the
configured Capac City how many live
notes we have is there a situation of
under replicated blocks and it tells me
that there are no dead notes you can
click on live notes and that gives you
your two data notes what is their
capacity how much is being used how many
blocks does that have is there any
situation of failed volumes and you can
look for more information you can always
look in here and you can say browse the
file system or look at log logs which
you can also find from your machine in
your Hadoop directory but you can click
on browse the file system as of now we
don't have any data and this is the web
UI for your sdfs for your name node
however this does not allow you to work
with hdfs it only allows you to browse
through hdfs and your Hadoop cluster you
also have a UI for resource manager and
that should be accessible
using the default Port which is for
resource manager and as I mentioned
since we did not configure the amount of
memory and CPU course which is allocated
to every node manager on every node it
will go for default memory settings that
is 8GB and default cores which will be 8
course per node all of those settings
can be changed but then to begin with
you can have a simple cluster with two
node which says there is 16GB memory
available although that's not true you
have 16b CES but then we have two nodes
where we have data nodes running and we
have node managers running which will be
used for processing our data on this
hadu cluster so this is a simple two
node Apache cluster which can then be
used to write data process it and store
data in a distributed fashion thank you
AJ for that fascinating session next up
we have both AJ and Richard to take you
through the entire Hadoop ecosystem and
its components to today we're covering
the Hadoop ecosystem at least the very
fundamentals of all the different parts
that are in the Hadoop ecosystem and
it's very robust it's grown over the
years with different things added in
there's a lot of overlapping in a lot of
these tools but we're just going to
cover these basic tools so you can see
what's available in the Hadoop ecosystem
so let's go back to our Hadoop ecosystem
as you can see we have all our different
setup and let's focus on the Hadoop part
of it first before we look at the
different tools we start with the Hadoop
or hdfs is for d data storage the hdfs
or the Hado file system is currently
used by companies all over the world all
the big names Uber Facebook Visa Intel
Amazon web service douche Bank eBay
pivotal Yahoo all of these are using the
Hadoop file system and Way Beyond this
this is just like a small picture of
some of the main companies using it
these companies used hdfs to overcome
the problem of storing a massive amount
of data let us look how Hadoop or hdfs
came into existence and what hdfs is all
about in the traditional approach all
the data was stored in a single Central
database with the rise of Big Data a
single database was not enough for
storage and I remember the old Sun
computers or the huge IBM machines with
all the flashing lights now all the data
on one of those can be stored on your
phone it's almost a bit of humor how
much this has accelerated over the years
the same thing with our rise of Big Data
no longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out and buy
a sun computer and put it on that one
Sun computer no more can you buy a Craig
machine or an Enterprise IBM server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have uh three different
databases going on so you might uh
actually saw this in one where they
divided up the um user counts a through
G so on by the letter and so the first
query would say what's the first letter
of this uh whatever ID it was and then
it would go into that database to find
it so it had a database telling it which
database to look for stuff that was a
long time ago and to be honest it didn't
work really well nowadays so that was a
distributed database you'd have to track
which database you put it in so what is
hdfs had dup distributed file system
hdfs is a specially designed file system
for storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodity is an interesting
term because I mentioned Enterprise
versus commodity and I'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master uh Damon there's only one active
name node it manages the data nodes and
stores all the metadata so it stores all
the mapping of where the data is on your
Hadoop file system now the name note is
usually an Enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid nameen machine and so then we
have our data nodes our data node data
node data node we have three here the
data node is the slave there can be
multiple data nodes and it stores the
actual data and this is where your
commodity Hardware comes in the best
definition I've heard of commodity
Hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at Hardware that's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main Master node is your um Enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the Hado file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we get our Ed
log it just keeps so big until it's too
big or our main Enterprise uh computer
that we spent all that money on so it
wouldn't break actually fails because
they still fail the solution we make
copies of the edit log and the fs image
files so that's pretty straightforward
you just copy them over so you have both
the most recent edits going on and the
long-term image of your file system and
then we also create a secondary name
node is a node that maintains the copies
of the edit log and the fs image it
combines them both to get an updated
version of the fs image now the
secondary name note only came in the
last um oh I guess two three years where
it became as part of the main system and
usually your secondary name note is also
an Enterprise computer and you'll put
them on separate racks so if you have
three racks of computers you would have
maybe the first two racks would have the
name node and the second rack would have
the secondary name node and the reason
you put them on different racks is you
can have a whole rack go down you could
have somebody literally trip over the
power cable or the switch that goes
between the racks is most common goes
down well if the switch goes down you
can easily switch to the secondary name
node and while you're getting your
switch replaced and replacing that
Hardware because of the way the hdfs
works it still is completely functional
so let's take a look at the name node we
have our edit log our FS image and we
have our secondary name node and you
take that it copies the edit log over
and it copies the fs image and you can
see right here you have all the
different cont ents on your main name
node now also on your secondary name
node and then your secondary name node
will actually take these two your edit
log and your FS image and it will make a
copy so you have a full FS image that
contains it's current it's up to date
the secondary name no creates a periodic
checkpoint of the files and then it
updates the new FS image into the name
node now it used to be this all occurred
on the name node before you had a
secondary name node so now you can use
your secondary name node to both back up
everything going on the name node and it
does that lifting in the back back where
you're combining your edit log and
bringing your FS image uh so it's
current and then you end up with a new
edit log and a new you have your FS
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is a standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our Hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture Ure so we
have our name node and it stores the
metadata and we have our block location
so we have our FS image plus our edit
log and then we have the backup FS image
and edit log and then we have so you
have your rack we have our switch on top
remember I was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the the rack you have your different
data nodes you have your data node one
two 3 four five maybe have uh 10 15 on
this rack you can stack them pretty high
nowadays uh used to be you'd only get
about 10 servers on there but now you
see racks that contain a lot more and
then you have multiple racks so we're
not talking about just one rack we also
have you know rack two rack three four
five six and so on until you have Rack N
so if you had 100 data nodes we would be
looking at 10 racks of 10 data nodes
each and that is literally 10 commodity
server computers hardware and we have a
core switch which maintains the network
bandwidth and connects the name node to
the data nodes so just like each rack
has a switch that connects all your
nodes on the rack you now have core
switches that connect all the racks
together and these also Connect into our
name node setup so now it can look up
your FS image and your edit log and pull
that information your metadata out so
we've looked at the architecture from
the name node coming down and you have
your metadata your Block locations this
then sorts it out you have your core
switches which connect everything all
your different racks and then each
individual rack has their own switches
which connect all the different nodes
and to the core switches so now let's
talk about the actual data blocks what's
actually sitting on those commodity uh
machines and so the Hadoop file system
splits massive files into small chunks
these chunks are known as data blocks
each file in the Hado file system is
stored as a data block and we have a
nice picture here where it looks like a
Lego if you ever played with the Legos
as a kid it's a good example we just
stack that data right on top of each
other but each block has to be the same
symmetry has to be the same size so that
it can track it easily and the default
size of one data block is usually 128 m
megabytes now you can go inad and change
that this standard is pretty solid as
far as most data is concerned when we're
loading up huge amounts of data and
there's certainly reasons to change it
but 128 megabytes is pretty standard
block so why 128 megabytes if the block
size is smaller then there will be two
many data blocks along with lots of
metadata which will create overhead so
that's why you don't really want to go
smaller on these data blocks unless you
have a very certain kind of data
similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as I pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your Lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it at 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is Dev divided now let's look into
how files are stored in the Hadoop file
system so we have a file text let's say
it's 520 megabytes we have block a so we
take 128 megabytes out of the 520 and we
store it in block a and then we have
Block B again we're taking 128 megabytes
out of our 520 storing it there and so
on Block C block D and then block e we
only have 8 megabytes left so when you
add up 128 plus 128 plus 128 plus 128
you only get 512 and so that last 8
megabytes goes into its own block the
final block uses only the remaining
space for storage data node failure and
replication and this is really where
Hadoop shines this is what makes it this
is why you can use it with commodity
computers this is why you can have
multiple racks and have something go
down all the data blocks are stored in
various data notes you take each block
you store it at 128 megabytes and then
we're going to put it on different nodes
so here's our block a Block B Block C
from our last example and we have node
one one node two node three node four
node 5 node six and so each one of these
represents a different computer it
literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node five crashes well that's a big deal
I mean we might not even have just node
5 you might have a whole rack go down
and if you're a company that's building
your whole business off of that you're
going to lose a lot of money so what
does happen when node 5 crashes or the
first rack goes down the data stored in
node 5 will be unavailable as there's no
copy stored elsewhere in this particular
image so the Hado file system overcomes
the issue of data node failure by
creating copies of the data this is
known as the replication method and you
can see here we have our six nodes
here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth notes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with Block B Block C is in
also spread out across the different uh
machines and same with block D and block
e node five crashes will the data blocks
b d and e be lost well in this example
no because we have backups of all three
of those on different machines the
blocks have their copies in the other
nodes due to which the data is not lost
even if the node 5 crashes and again
because they're also stored on different
racks even if the whole rack goes down
you are still up and live with your hudo
file system the default replication
factor is three in total we'll have
three copies of each data block now that
can be changed for different reasons or
purposes uh but you got to remember when
you're looking at a data center this is
all in one huge room these switches are
connecting all these servers so they can
Shuffle the data back and forth really
quick and that is very important when
you're dealing with big data and you can
see here um each block is by default rep
replicated three times that's a standard
there is very rare occasions to do four
and there's even fewer reasons to do two
blocks I've only seen four used once and
it was because they had two data centers
and so each data center kept two
different copies rack awareness in the
Hadoop file system rack is a collection
of 30 to 40 data nodes rack awareness is
a concept that helps to decide where the
replica of the data block should be
stored so here we have rack one we have
our data node one to four remember our
say saying that it used to be you only
put 10 machines and now then it went to
20 now it's 30 to 40 so you can have a
rack with 40 servers on it then we have
rack two and rack three and we put block
one on there replicas of block a cannot
be in the same rack and so I'll put the
replicas onto a different rack and
notice that these are actually these two
are on the same rack but you'll never
have all three stored on the same Rack
in case the whole rack goes down and
replicas of block a are created in rack
2 and they actually do they do by
default create the rep replicas onto the
same rack and that has to do with the
data exchange and maximizing your
processing time and then we have of
course our Block B and it's replicated
onto rack three and Block C which will
then replicate onto rack one and so on
for all of your data all the way up to
block D or whatever how much of data you
have on there hdfs architecture so let's
look over the architecture as a bigger
picture we looked at the name node and
we stores the metadata names replicas
home food data 3 so it has all your
different
your metadata stored on there and then
we have our data nodes and you can see
our data nodes are each on different
racks with our different machines and we
have our name node and you're going to
see we have a heartbeat or pulse here
and a lot of times one of the things
that um confuses people sometimes in
classes they talk about nodes versus
machines so you could have a data node
that's a Hadoop data node and you could
also have a spark note on there Sparks a
different architecture and these are
each Damons that are running on these
computers that's why you refer to them
as nodes and not just always as servers
and machines so even though I use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data node
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey I'm here I'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack one and rack two
and our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and it replicates
it in three different locations and then
we have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer and the client is you've
logged in external to this Hadoop file
system and you're sending it
instructions and so the client whatever
instructions or script you're sending is
first request the name node to read the
data the name node allows a client to
read the requested data from the data
nodes the data is read from the data
nodes and sent to the client and so you
can see here that basically the the name
node connects the client up and says
here here's a data stream and now you
have the query that you sent out
returning the data you asked for and
then of course it goes and finishes it
and says oh metadata operations and it
goes in there and finalizes your request
the other thing the name node does is
you're sending your information cu the
client sends the information in there is
your block operations so your block
operations are uh performs creation of
data so you're going to create new files
and folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues a metadata the metadata goes into
it stores a metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the hdu file system
maybe you're querying maybe you're
asking it to delete if you're sending
data in there it then does the
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the Hadoop file system the
Hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our hu file system client that's
you on your computer and the client jvm
on the client node so we have our client
ient jvm or the Java virtual machine
that is going through and then your
client node and we're zooming in on the
read mechanism so we're looking at this
picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and I also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our uh name node
up here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can I I get the Block
locations and so it goes by using the
RPC remote procedure call it gets those
locations and the name node first checks
if the client is authorized to access
the requested file and if yes it then
provides a block location and a token to
the client which is showing to the slave
for authentication so here's a name node
it tells the client hey here's the token
the client's going to come in and get
this information from you and it tells a
client oh hey here's where the
information is so this is what is
telling your script you sent to query
your D whether you're writing your
script in one of the many setups that
you have available through Theo file
system or a connection through your code
and so you have your client machine at
this point then reads so your FS data
input stream comes through and you have
and you can see right here we did one
and two which is verify who you are and
give you all the information you need
then three you're going to read it from
the input stream and then the input
stream is going to grab it from the
different nodes where it's at and it'll
Supply the tokens to those machines
saying hey this client needs this data
here's a token for that we're good to go
let me have the data the client will
show the authentication token to the
data nodes for the reprocess to begin so
after reaching the end of the data block
the connection is closed and we can see
here where we've gone through the
different steps get Block locations we
have uh step one you open up your
connection you get the Block locations
by using the RPC then you actively go
through the fs data input stream to grab
all those different data brings it back
into the client and then once it's done
it closes down that connection and then
once the client or in this case the
programmer you know manager's gone in
and pig script you can do that there's
an actual coding in each in Hadoop we're
pulling data called pig or Hive once you
get that data back we close the
connection delete all those randomly
huge series of tokens so they can't be
used anymore and then it's done with
that query and we can go ahead and zoom
in just a little bit more here and let's
look at this even a little closer here's
our Hado file system client and our
client jvm our Java virtual machine on
the client node and we have the data to
be read block a Block B and so we
request to read block A and B and it
goes into the name node uh two then it
sends the location in this case um IP
addresses of the blocks for the dn1 and
dn2 where those blocks are stored then
the client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and so you have
here the core switch so your client node
comes in three and it goes to the core
switch and that then goes to Rack switch
one rack switch two and rack switch 3
now if you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high-end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use Enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches so if one of those
goes down you don't care as much you
just have to get in there and swap it in
and out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is Block B and it'll pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack what
whatever the closest setup is for that
query the reason for this is if you have
10 other queries going on you want this
one to pull all the data through one
setup and it minimizes that traffic so
the response from the data noes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says Ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful I don't
know about you I like to be successful
so if we looking at the read mechanism
let's go ahead and zoom in and look at
the right mechanism for the Hado file
system sry hdfs WR mechanism and so when
we we have the hdfs right mechanism
here's our client machine this is again
the programmer on their in computer and
it's going through the client Java
machine or Java virtual machine the jvm
and this is all occurring on the client
node uh somebody's office or maybe it's
on the local server for the office so we
have our name node we have data nodes
and we have the distributed file system
so the client first executes create file
on distributed file system says hey I'm
going to create this file over here then
it goes through the RPC call just like
our read did The Client First executes
create file in the distributed file
system then the DFS interacts with the
name node to create a file name node
then provides a location to write the
data and so here we have our hdfs client
and the fs data output Stream So this
time instead of the data going to the
client it's coming from the client and
so here the client writes the data
through the fs data output stream keep
in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be I mean you know I always refer
to the client as just being this
computer that you're programing is
writing on it could be you have your SQL
Server there where your data is that's
current with all your current sales and
it's archiving all that information
through scoop one of the tools in the
Hadoop file system it could be streaming
data it could be a connection to the
stock servers and you're pulling stock
data down from those servers at a
regular time and that's all controlled
you can actually set that code up to be
controll in many of the different
features in the Hadoop file system and
some of the different resources you have
that sit on top of it so here the client
writes the data through the fs data
output stream and the fs data output
stream as you can see goes into right
packet so it take divides it up into
packets 128 megabytes and the data is
written and the slave further replicates
it so here's our data coming in and then
uh if you remember correctly that's part
of the fs data setup is it tells it
where to replicate it out but the data
node itself is like oh hey okay I've got
the data coming in and it's also given
the tokens of where to send the
replication to and then acknowledgement
is sent after the required replicas are
made uh so then that goes back up saying
hey successful I've written data made
three replications on this as far as our
you know going through the pipeline of
the data nodes and then that goes back
and it says after the data is written
the client performs the close method so
the client's done and says okay I'm done
here's the end of the data we're
finished and after the data is written
the client performs a close method and
we can see here just a quick reshape uh
we go in there just like we did with the
read we create the connection this
creates the name node which lets it know
what's going on step two step three that
also includes the tokens and everything
and then we go into step three where
we're now writing through the fs data
output stream and that sorts it out into
uh whatever data node it's going to go
to and which also tells it how to
replicate it so that data node then
sends it to other data nodes so we have
a replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we can go ahead and just do this
with an example the same setup whether
you're doing a read or a write they're
very similar as we come in here from our
client and our name node and you can see
right here we actually depicting these
as the actual rack and the switches
going on and so as the data comes in you
have your request like we saw earlier it
sends the location to the data nodes and
this actually turns your um your IP
addresses your Dynamic node connections
they come back to your client your hdfs
client and at that point with the tokens
it then goes into the core switch and
the core switch says Hey here it goes
the client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and you can see
here where you're writing in block a
replication of block a and second
replication of block a on the second
server so block a gets replicated on the
second server and the third server at
this point you now have three
replications of block a and it comes
back and says acknowledges it says hey
we're done and that goes back into your
Hado file system to the client who says
okay we're done and finally the U
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the Hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is uh
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant uh whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node can go down if you have a secondary
name nodee something we didn't talk too
much about is how scalable it is as it
uses distributed storage you run into
there you're oh my gosh I'm out of space
or I need to do some heavier processing
let me just add another rack of
computers so you can scale it up very
quickly and it's a linear scalability
where it used to be if you bought a
server you would have to pay a lot of
money to get that uh the Craig computer
remember the big Craig computers coming
out the Craig computer runs 2 million a
year just the maintenance to liquid cool
it that's very expensive compared to
just adding more racks of computer and
extending your data center so it's very
cost effective since commodity Hardware
is used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers you still need your high-end
Enterprise uh for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security and provides data
security for your data so all Theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into p
pulling data or putting data into the
Hado file system and you can see here I
have Oracle virtual machine virtual box
manager I have a couple different things
loaded on there Cloud Dera is one of
them so we should probably explain some
of these things if you're new to Virtual
machines the Oracle virtual box allows
you to spin up a machine as if it is a
separate computer so in this case this
is running I believe Centos a Linux and
it creates like a box on my computer so
the Centos is running on my machine
while I'm running my Windows 10 this
happens to be a Windows 10 computer and
then underneath here I can actually go
under uh let me just open up the general
might be hard to see there and you can
see I can actually go down to system
processor I happen to be on an 8 core it
has 16 dedicated threads registers of 16
CPUs but eight cores and I've only
designated this for one CPU so it's only
going to use one of my dedicated threads
on my computer and this the Oracle
virtual machine is open source you can
see right here we're on the Oracle
www.oracle.com I usually just do a
search for downloading virtual box if
you search for virtual box all one word
it will come up with this page and then
you can download it for whatever
operating system you're working with
there certainly are number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a um
for demoing for yourself the first thing
to note for doing a virtual box and
doing a cloud Dera or Horton setup on
that virtual box for doing the Hadoop
system to try it out you need a minimum
of 12 GB it cannot be a Windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's Cloud Dera and we'll
talk a little bit about claa here in
just a second but they have the cloud
era online live we can go try the cloud
Dera setup I've never used it but cloud
is a pretty good company cloud and
Horton works are two of the common ones
out there I will actually be running a
cloud Dera Hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have Oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different VMware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the cloud Dera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for cloud era you want to go
underneath the cloud era quick start if
you type in a search for cloud era quick
start it'll bring you to this website
and then you can select your platform
and in this case I did virtual box
there's VMware we just talked about
Docker Docker is a very high-end virtual
setup unless you already know it you
really don't want to mess with it then
your KVM is if you're on a Linux
computer that sets up multiple systems
on that computer so the two you really
want to use are usually the virtual box
or do an online setup and you can see
here with the download if you're going
into the Horton version It's called
Horton works and they call it sandbox so
you'll see the term Horton Works sandbox
and these are all test demos you're not
going to deploy a single node Hadoop
systems that would just be kind of
ridiculous and defeat the whole purpose
of having a Horton or having a Hadoop
system if it's only installed on one
computer in a virtual node so uh a lot
of different options if you're not on a
professional Windows version or you
don't have at least 12 gigaby Ram to run
this uh you'll want to try and see if
you can find an online version and of
course simply learn has our own Labs if
you sign up for a classes we set you up
I don't know what it is now but last
time I was in there was a five node uh
setup so you can get around and see
what's going on whether you're studying
for the admin side or for the
programming side in script writing and
if I go into my Oracle virtual box and I
go under my cloud Dera and I start this
up and each one has their own flavors um
Horton uses just a log in so you log
everything in through um a local host
through your Internet Explorer or I
might use Chrome Cloudera actually opens
up a full interface so you actually are
in that setup and you can see when I've
uh started it let me go back here I once
I downloaded this this is a big download
by the way I had to import The Appliance
in Virtual box uh the first time I ran
it it takes a long time to configure the
setup and the second time it comes up
pretty quick and with the Cloudera quick
start again this is a pretend single
node it opens up and you'll see that it
actually has Firefox here so here's my
web browser I don't have to go to Local
Host I'm actually already in the quick
start for cloud era and if we come down
here you can see getting started I has
some information analyze your data
manage your cluster your general
information on there and what I always
uh want to start to do is to go ahead
and open up a terminal window so we'll
open up a terminal widen this a little
bit let me just maximize this out here
so you can see so we are now in a
virtual machine this virtual machine is
cintos Linux so I'm on a Linux computer
on my Windows computer and so when I'm
on this terminal window this is your
basic terminal if I do new list you'll
see documents Eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the Linux
system so this is a Linux computer and
then Hadoop is running on here so now I
have Hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a Hado file
system DFS minus LS now notice the ls is
the same I have LS for list and LS for
list and I click on here and it'll take
it just a second reading the Hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments I have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it I
have this environment out here which is
my slides I have this environment here
where I did a list that's looking at the
files on the Linux Centos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the Hadoop file
system so three completely separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have I have whatever
files I my personal files and the um of
course we're also looking at the screen
for my Windows 10 and then we're looking
at the screen here uh here's our list
there that's looking at the files and
this is the screen for Centos Linux and
then this is looking at the files right
here for the Hadoop file system so three
completely separate files this one here
which is the Linux is running in a
virtual box so this is a virtual box I'm
using one core to run it or one CPU and
everything in there is it has its own
file system you can see we have our
desktop and documents and whatever in
there and then you can see here we right
now have no files in our Hadoop file
system and this Hadoop file system
currently is stored on the Linux machine
but it could be stored across 10 Linux
machines 20 100 this could be stored
across uh in pedabytes I mean it could
be really huge or it could just be in
this case just just a demo where we're
putting it on just one computer and then
once we're in here let me just see real
quick if I can go under view zoom in
view zoom in and this is just a standard
browser so I could use any like the
Control Plus and stuff like that to zoom
in and this is very common to be in a
browser window with the hoodo file
system so right now I'm in a Linux and
I'm going to do oh let's just create a
file we go file my new file and I'm
going to use VI and this is a VI editor
just a basic editor and we go ahead and
type something in here um 1 two 3 4
maybe it's columns 44 66 77 of course I
do file system just like your regular
computer can also so in our VI editor
you hit your colon I actually work with
a lot of different other editors and
we'll write quit VI so let's take a look
and see what happened here I'm in my
Linux system I type in LS for list and
we should see my new file and sure
enough we do over here there it is let
me just highlight that my new file and
and if I then go into theop system hdfs
DFS minus LS for list we still show
nothing it's still empty so what I can
simply do is I can go hdfs DFS minus put
and we're going to put uh my new file
and this is just going to move it from
the Linux system because I'm in this
file folder into the Hadoop file system
and now if we go in and we type in our
list for a new file system you will see
in here that I now have just the one
file on there which is my new file and
very similar to Linux we can do cat and
the cat command simply uh evokes reading
the file uh so hdfs DFS minus cat and I
had to look it up remember Cloud Dera
the the format is going to be a user uh
then of course the um path location and
the file name and in here when we did
the list here's our list so you can see
it lists our file file here and we
realize that this is under uh user Cloud
Dera and so I can now go user Cloud Dera
my new file and the minus cat and we'll
be able to read the file in here and you
can see right here this is the file that
was in the Linux system is now copied
into the cloud era system and it's 1
1345 that what I entered in there and if
we go back to the Linux and do list
you'll still see it in here my new file
and we can also do something like this
in our hdfs minus MV and we'll do my new
file and we're going to change it to my
new new file and if we do that
underneath our hudo file system the
minus MV will rename it so if I go back
here to our Hadoop file system LS you'll
now see instead of my new file it has my
new new file coming up and there it is
my new new file so we've renamed it we
can also go in here and delete this so I
can now come in here so in our hdfs DFS
we can also do a remove and this will
remove the file and so if we come in
here we run this we'll see that when I
come back and do the list the file is
gone and now we just have another empty
uh folder with our hoodo file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so MK
for make directory we'll call this my um
dur so we're going to make a directory
Myer it'll take it just a second and of
course if we do um the list command
you'll see that we now have uh the
directory in there give it just a second
there it comes Myer and just like we did
before I can go in here and um we're
going to put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
um setup I called it my new file so this
is coming from the Linux system and
we're going to put that into my dur
that's the Target in my Hadoop setup and
so if I hit enter on there I can now do
uh the Hadoop list and that's not going
to show the file cuz remember I put it
in a subfolder so if I do theup just
this will show my directory and I can do
list and then I can do my dur for my
directory and you'll see underneath the
my directory in the Hadoop file system
it now has my new file put in there and
with any good uh operating system we
need a minus help so just like you can
type in help in your Linux you can now
come in here and type in htfs help and
it shows you a lot of the commands in
there underneath the Hado file system
most of them should be very similar to
the Linux on here and we can also do
something like this uh Hado version and
the Hadoop version shows up that we're
in Hadoop
2.60 um CDH is that we're Cloud Dera 5
and compiled by Jenkins and it has a
date and all the different information
on our Hado file system so this is some
basics in the terminal window let me go
ahead and close this out because if
you're going to play with this you
should really come in here let me just
maximize the cloud Dera and it opens up
in a browser window and so once we're in
here again this is a browser window
which you could access uh might look
like any access for a Hadoop file system
one of the fun things to do when you're
first starting is to go under Hue you'll
see it up here at the top has Cloud Dera
Hue Hadoop your hbas your Impala your
spark these are standard installs now
and Hue is basically an overview of the
file system and so it'll come up here
and you can see where you can do queries
as far as if you have a hbase or a hive
U The Hive database we can go over here
to the top where it says file browser
and if we go under file browser now this
is the Hadoop file system we're looking
at and once we open up the file browser
you can now see there's my directory
which we created and if I click on my
directory there's my new file which is
in here uh and if I click on my new file
it actually opens it up and you can see
from our hudo file system this is in the
hudo file system the file that we
created so we covered uh the terminal
window you can see here's a terminal
window up here it might be if you were
in a web browser it look a little
different because it actually opens up
as a web browser terminal window and
we've looked a little bit at Hue which
is one of the most basic components of
Hadoop one of the original components
for going through and looking at your
data and your databases of course now
they're up to uh the hue4 it's gone
through a number of changes and you can
see there's a lot of different choices
in here for other different tools in the
hudo file system and I'll go ahead and
just close out of this and one of the
cool things with the virtual uh box I
can either uh save the machine State
send the shutdown signal or power off
the machine I'll go and just power off
the machine completely now suppose you
have a library that has a collection of
huge number of books on each floor and
you want to count the total number of
books present on each floor what would
be your approach you could say I will do
it myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you you could then say if each friend
could count the books on every floor
then obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing So when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you're talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its RAM and CPU course for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person one who would be
taking care of books on floor one and
Counting them person two on floor two
then you have someone on floor three and
someone on floor four so every
individual would be counting the books
on every floor in parallel so that
reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these discounts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of of a particular
floor or you can say each person is
doing a kind of activity or basically a
task on every floor and the task is
counting the books on every floor now
then you could have some aggregation
mechanism that could basically reduce or
summarize this total count and in terms
of map reduce we would say that's the
work of reducer so when you talk about
Hadoop map reduce it processes data on
different node machines now this is the
whole concept of Hadoop framework right
that you not only have your data stored
across machines but you would also want
to process the data locally so instead
of transferring the data from one
machine to other machine or bringing all
the data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data process
assist on the machines wherever that is
stored so we know in case of Hadoop
cluster we would have our data stored on
multiple data nodes on their multiple
Diss and that is the data which needs to
be processed but the requirement is that
we want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
map reduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of map reduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will Aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your map
reduce Works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about map reduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of a
doop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use map
reduce programming model and run a map
reduce algorithm in a local mode but
what does that mean if you would go for
a local mode it basically means it would
do all the mapping and reducing on the
same node using the processing capacity
that is RAM and CPU cores on the same
machine which is not really efficient in
fact we would want to have our map
reduce work on multiple notes which
would obviously have mapping phase
followed by a reducing phase and
intermittently there would be data
generated there would be different other
phases which help this whole proc
processing so when you talk about Hadoop
map reduce you are mainly talking about
two main components or two main phases
that is mapping and reducing mapping
taking care of map tasks reducing taking
care of reduced tasks so you would have
your data which would be stored on
multiple machines now when we talk about
data data could be in different formats
we could or the developer could specify
what is the format which needs to be
used to understand the data which is
coming in that data then goes through
the mapping internally there would be
some shuffling sorting and then reducing
which gives you your final output so the
way we Access Data from sdfs or the way
our data is getting stored on sdfs we
have our input data which would have one
or multiple files and one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a Hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 MB which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if I have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster I would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name nodes Ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every Chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map Tas doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function function which basically
says what each of these map tasks has to
do on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduced STS would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phas which is
like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on hdfs now in case of
Hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in park your
data could be in row text CSV tsv binary
format and all of these formats are
supported however remember if you're are
talking about data being compressed then
you have to also look into what kind of
splitability the compression mechanism
supports otherwise when map reduce
processing happens it would take the
complete file as one chunk to be
processed so sdfs accepts input data in
different formats this data is stored in
sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as I said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when I
say individual element I could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of D limiter
or without D limiter are broken down
into individual elements and does your
ma creates key value pairs now these key
value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
Aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller Tes or tupes as you would say
finally your output is getting stored in
the designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
map reduce one of the key factors here
is the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we our data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes and each slave node
would have again one or multiple diss to
process this data basically we have to
go for parallel processing approach we
have to use the map reduce now let's
look at the map reduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on hdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to Google and we can basically
search for Hadoop map reduce Yahoo
tutorial this is one of the good links
and if I look into this link I can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
Define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the bite of of the line and the value is
the line content itself you can have key
value input format which passes lines
into key value pairs everything up to
the first tab character is the key and
the remainder is the line you could also
have sequence file input format which
basically works on binary format so you
have input format and in the same way
you can also search for output format
which takes care of how the data is
handled after the processing is done so
the key value pairs provided to this
output collector are then return return
to Output files the way they are return
is governed by output format so it
functions pretty much like input format
as described in earlier right so we
could set what is the output format to
be followed and again you have text
output sequence file output format null
output format and so on so these are
different classes which take care of how
your data is handled when it is being
read for processing or how is the data
being written when the processing is
done so based on the input format the
file is broken down into splits and this
logically represents the data to be
processed by individual map tasks or you
could say individual mapper functions so
you could have one or multiple splits
which need to be processed depending on
the file size depending on what
properties have been set now once this
is done you have your input splits which
are subjected to mapping phase
internally you have a record reader
which communicates with the input split
and converts the data into key value
pairs suitable to be read by mapper and
what is mapper doing it is basically
working on these key value pairs the map
task giving you an intermittent output
which would then be forwarded for
further processing now once that is done
and we have these key value pairs which
is being worked upon my map your map
tasks as a part of your mapper function
are generating your key value pairs
which are your intermediate outputs to
be processed further now you could have
as I said a combiner phase or internally
a mini reducer phase Now combiner does
not have its own class so combiner
basically uses the same class as the
reducer class provided by the developer
and its main work is to do the reducing
or its main work is to do some kind of
mini aggregation on the key value pairs
which were generated by map so once the
data is coming in from the combiner then
we have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if I did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on your output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partitioner decided or
determined for your data Tob processed
it can also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio Stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that your reducing or aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the out
files now this is how your map reduce
Works wherein the final output data can
be not only stored but then read or
access from sdfs or even used as an
input for further map reduce kind of
processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically basically means one
or multiple map tasks working on your
chunks of data you could have a combiner
phase which is optional which is not
mandatory then you have a partitioner pH
which decides on how many reduced task
or how many reducers would be used to
work on your data internally there is
sorting and shuffling of data happening
and then basically based on your output
format your record reader will write the
output to sdfs directory now internally
you would also remember that data is
being processed locally so you would
have the output of each task which is
being worked upon stored locally however
we do not access the data directly from
data nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
map reduce workflow when you talk about
map reduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an API which intends to to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of Hado Yan
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
Hadoop version one we had job tracker
and then the slaves were called task
trackers in Hado version two instead of
job track tracker you have resource
manager and instead of task trackers you
have node managers so basically your
resource manager has to assign the job
to the task trackers or node managers so
your node managers as we discussed in
Yan are basically taking care of
processing which happens on every node
so internally there is all of this work
Happening by resource manager node
managers and application master and you
can refer to the Yan based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing Master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted your application to be run
on Yan processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
Yan part as of now I mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how Yan handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some RAM and CPU cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your map reduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on his
[Music]
DFS so let's have a quick demo on map
reduce and see how it works on a Hadoop
cluster now we have discussed briefly
about map reduce which contains mainly
two phases that is your mapping phase
and your reducing phase and mapping
phase is taken care by your mapper
function and your reducing phase is
taken care by your reducer function now
in between we also have sorting and
shuffling and then you have other phases
which is partitioner and combiner and we
will discuss about all those in detail
in later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a map reduce
which is already existing as a package
jar file within your Apache hadu cluster
or even in your Cloud era cluster now we
can build our own map reduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoo
cluster on Yan or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which I have brought up
and basically this would have my Apache
Hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a Simple Start hyphen all Dosh now I
know that the script is dicated and it
says instead use start DFS and start
yarn but then it will still take care of
starting off my cluster on these two
nodes where I would have one single name
node two data nodes one secondary name
node one resource manager and two note
managers now if you have any doubt in
how this cluster came up you can always
look at the previous sessions where we
had a walk through in setting up a
cluster on Apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
Less Than 3 GB of your total machine RAM
and you could have a Apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web UI which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the UI is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up I
can just do a JPS to look at Java
related processes and that will show me
what are the process which are running
on C1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my M1 machine which is my second
machine which I've configured here I can
always do a JPS and that shows me the
processes running which also means that
my cluster is up with two data nodes
with two node managers and here I can
have a look at my web UI so I can just
do a refresh and the same thing with
this one just do a refresh so I had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web UI using your name
notes host name and 570 Port it tells me
what is my cluster ID what is my
blockpool ID it gives you information of
what is the space usage how many live
notes you have and you can even browse
your file system so I have put in a lot
of data here I can click on browse the
file system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our map reduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this I have
just pulled in some of my Hadoop logs
and I have put it on my hdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which I've
downloaded from web now we can either
run a map reduce on a single file or in
a directory which contains multiple
files let's look at that before looking
a demo on map ruce also remember map
ruce will create a output directory and
we need to have that directory created
plus we need to have the permissions to
run the map reduce job so by default
since I'm running it using admin ID I
should not have any problem but then if
you intend to run map reduce with a
different user then obviously you will
have have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which I've created which will
contain my output once the map reduce
job finishes and this is my cluster file
system if you look on this UI this shows
me about my Yann which is available for
taking care of any processing it as of
now shows that I have total of 8 GB
memory and I have 8 we course now that
can be depending on what configuration
we have set or how many notes are
available we can look at noes which are
available and that shows me I have two
node managers running each has 8 GB
memory and 8 V course now that's not
true actually but then we have not set
the configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8 GB RAM and 8 V
course now this is my Yan UI we can also
look at Schuler which basically shows me
the different cues if they have been
configured where you will have to run
the jobs we'll discuss about all these
in later in detail now let's go back to
our terminal and let's see where we can
find some sample applications which we
can run on the cluster so once I go to
the terminal I can well submit the map
reduce job from any terminal now here I
know that my Hadoop related directory is
here and within Hadoop you have various
directories we have discussed that in
binaries you have the commands which you
can run in sbin you basically have the
startup scripts and here you also notice
there is a share directory in the end if
you look in the share directory you
would find Hadoop and within Hadoop you
have various subd directories in which
we will look for map reduce now this map
reduce directory has some sample jar
files which we can use to run a map
reduce on the cluster similarly if you
are working on a cloud era cluster you
would have to go into opt claer parcel
CDH SL lib and in that you would have
directories for sdfs map reduce or as
DFS yon where you can still find the
same jars it is basically a package
which contains your multiple
applications now how do we run a map
reduce we can just type in Hadoop and
hit enter and that shows me that I have
an option called jar which can be used
to run a jar file now at any point of
time if you would want to see what are
the different classes which are
available in a particular uh jar you
could always do a jar minus xvf for
example I could say jar xvf and I could
say user local Hadoop share Hadoop map
reduce and then list down your jar file
so I'll say Hadoop map reduce examples
and if I do this this should basically
unpack it to show me what classes are
available within this particular jar and
it has done this it has created a meta
file and it has created a org directory
we can see that by doing a LS and here
if you look in LS org since I ran the
command from your home directory I can
look into or paty Hadoop examples which
shows me the classes which I have and
those classes contain which mapper or
reducer classes so it might not be just
mapper and reducer but you can always
have a look so for example I'm targeting
to use word count program which does a
word count on files and gives me a list
of words and how many times they occur
in a particular file or in set of files
and this shows me that what are the
classes which belong to word count so we
have a int sum reducer so this is my
reducer class I have tokenizer mapper
that is my mapper class right and
basically this is what is used these
classes are used if you run a word count
now there are many other programs which
are part of this jar file and we can
expand and see that so I can say Hadoop
jar and give your path so I'll say
Hadoop jar user local Hadoop share
Hadoop map reduce Hadoop map reduce
examples and if I hit on enter that will
show me what are the inbuilt classes
which are already available now these
are certain things which we can use now
there are other jar files also for
example I can look at dup and here we
can look at the jar files which we have
in this particular path so this is one
Hadoop map reduce examples which you can
use you can always look in other jar
files like you can look for Hadoop map
reduce client job client and then you
can look at the test one so that is also
an interesting one so you can always
look into her doop map reduce client job
client and then you have something
ending with this so if I would have
tried this one using my Hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and Terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a Hadoop jar as I said on Hadoop
map reduce I think that was client and
then we have job client and then test
STAR now this has lot of other classes
which can be used or programs which can
be used for doing a stress testing or
checking your cluster status and so on
one of them interesting one is test d fs
iio but let's not get into all the
details in first instance let's see how
we can run a map reduce now if I would
want to run a map reduce I need to give
Hadoop jar and then my jar file and if I
hit on enter it would say it needs the
input and output it needs which class CL
you want to run so for example I would
say word count and again if I hit on
enter it tells me that you need to give
me some input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our Yan
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in a local mode
but let's first try how it runs on the
cluster so how do we do that now here I
can do a h DFS LS SL command to see what
I have on my sdfs now through my UI I
was already showing you that we have set
of files and directories which we can
use to process now we can take up one
single file so for example if I pick up
new data and I can look into the files
here what we have and we can basically
run a map reduce on a single file or
multiple files so let's take this file
whatever that contains and I would like
to do a word count so that I get a list
of words and their occurrence in this
file so let me just copy this now I also
need my output to be written and that
will be written here so here if I want
to run a map reduce I can say Hadoop
which we can pull out from history so
Hadoop jar word count now I need to give
my input so that will be new data and
then I will give this file which we just
copied now I'm going to run the word
count on on a single file and I will
basically have my output which will be
stored in this directory the directory
which I have created already Mr output
so let's do this output and this is fair
enough now you can give many other
properties you can specify how many map
jobs you want to run how many reduced
jobs you want to run do you want your
output to be compressed do you want your
output to be merged or many other
properties can be defined when you are
specifying word count and then you can
pass in an argument to pass properties
from the command line which will affect
your output now once I go ahead and
submit this this is basically running a
simple inbuilt map reduce job on our
Hadoop cluster now obviously internally
it will be looking for name node now we
have some issue here and it says the
output already exists what does that
mean so it basically means that Hadoop
will create an output for you you you
just need to give a name but then you
don't need to create it so let's give
let's append the output with number one
and then let's go ahead and run this so
I've have submitted this command now
this can also be run in background if
you would want to run multiple jobs on
your cluster at the same time so it
takes total input parts to processes one
so that is there is only one split on
which your job has to work now it will
internally try to contact your resource
manager and basically this is done so
here we we can have a look and we can
see some counters here now what I also
see is for some property which it is
missing it has run the job but it has
run in a local mode it has run in a
local mode so although we have submitted
so this might be related to my Yan
settings and we can check that so if I
do a refresh when I have run my
application it has completed it would
have created an output but the only
thing is it did not interact with your
Yan it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so map reduce remember
is a programming model right now if you
run it on Yan you get the facilities of
running it on a cluster where Yan takes
care of resource management if you don't
run it on Yan and run it on a a local
mode it will use your machine's RAM and
CPU cores for processing but then we can
quickly look at the output and then we
can also try running this on Yan so if I
look into my hdfs and if I look into my
output Mr output that's the directory
which was not used actually let's look
into the other directory which is ending
with one and that should show me the
output created by this map reduce
although it ran in a local mode it
fetched an input file from your sdfs and
it would have created output in sdfs now
that's my part file which is created and
if you look at part minus r minus these
zeros if you would have more than one
reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
I can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my map
reduce let's have have a look into this
so the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample map reduce job I
will also show you how we can run it on
Yan now let's run map ruce on Yan and
initially when we tried running a map
reduce it did not hit Yan but it ran in
a local mode and that was because there
was a property which had to be changed
in map reduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that I had given a property
which says m.f framework. name and that
was not the right property name and it
was ignored and that's why it ran in a
local mode so I changed the property to
map R.F framework. name restarted my
cluster and everything should be fine
now and that map red hyphen sight file
has also been copied across the noes now
to run a map reduce on a Hadoop cluster
so that it uses Yan and Yan takes care
of resource allocation on one or
multiple machines so I'm just changing
the output here and now I will submit
this job which should first connect to
the resource manager and if it connects
to the resource manager that means our
job will be run using Yan on the cluster
rather than in a local mode so now we
have to wait for this application to
internally connect to resource manager
and once it starts there we can always
go back to the web UI and check if our
application has reached Yan so it shows
me that there is one input part to be
processed that's my job ID that's my
application ID which you can even
monitor status from the command line now
here the job has been submitted so let's
go back here and just do a Refresh on my
Yan UI which should show me the new
application which is submitted it tells
me that it is in accepted State
application master has already started
and if you click on this link it will
also give you more details of how many
map and reduced tasks would run so as of
now it says the application Master is
running it would be using this node
which is M1 we can always look into the
logs we can see that there is a one task
attempt which is being made and now if I
go back to my terminal I will see that
is waiting to get some resources from
the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here I can just do refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back I tested this application
on Yan and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that Yan can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally Yan takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
Yan or you might have already followed
the Yan based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what Yan can allocate
to it sometimes you can also see a
slowness in what web UI shows up and
that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for Apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as I said the memory which
shows up here 16 GB and 16 course is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my Yan should be
able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again I had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically I restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process should start so here I've
have submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
an appm that is application Master it is
looking for the number of splits which
is one it's getting the application ID
and it basically then starts running the
job it also gives you a tracking URL to
look at the output and now we should go
back back and look at our Yan UI if our
application shows up here and we will
have to give it a couple of seconds when
it can get the final status changed to
running and that's where my application
will be getting resources now if you
closely notice here I have allocated
specific amount of memory that is 1.5 GB
for node manager on every node and I
have basically given two cores each
which my machines also have and my Yan
should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving and we
can see the progress bar here which
basically will show what is happening
and if we go back to the terminal it
will show that first it went in deciding
map and reduce it goes for map once the
mapping phase completes then the
reducing phase will come into existence
and here my job has completed so now it
has basically used we can always look at
how many map and reduced tasks were run
it shows me that there was one map and
one reduced task now with the number of
map tasks depends on the number of
splits and we had just one file which is
less than 128 MB so that was one split
to be processed and reduce task is
internally decided by the reducer or
depending on what kind of property has
been set in Hado config files now it
also tells me how many input records
were read which basically means these
were the number of L in the file it
tells me output records which gives me
the number of total words in the file
now there might be duplicates and that
which is processed by internal combiner
further processing or forwarding that
information to reducer and basically
reducer works on 335 records gives us a
list of words and their count now if I
do a refresh here this would obviously
show my application is completed it says
succeeded you can always click on the
application to look for more information
it tells me where it ran now we do not
have a history server running as of now
otherwise we can always access more
information so this leads to history
server where all your applications are
stored but I can click on this attempt
tasks and this will basically show me
the history URL or you can always look
into the logs so this is how you can
submit a sample application which is
inbuilt which is available in the jar on
your Hadoop cluster and that will
utilize your cluster to run now you
could always as I said when you are
running a particular job remember to
change the output directory and if you
would not want it to be processing a
single individual file you could also
point it to a directory that basically
means it will have multiple files and
depending on the file sizes there would
be multiple splits and according to that
multiple map tasks will be selected so
if I click on this this would submit my
second application to the the cluster
which should first connect to resource
manager then resource manager has to
start an application Master now here we
are targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my Yan provides it the resources we will
have the application running on our Yann
cluster so it has already started if you
see it is going further then it would
launch 10 map tasks and it would the
number of reduced tasks would be decided
on either the way your data is or based
on the properties which have been set at
your cluster level let's just do a quick
refresh here on my Yan UI to show me the
progress also take care that when you
are submitting your application you need
to have have the output directory
mentioned however do not create it
Hadoop will create that for you now this
is how you run a map reduce without
specifying properties but then you can
specify more properties you can look
into what are the things which can be
changed for your mapper and reducer or
basically having a combiner class which
can do a mini reducing and all those
things can be done so we will learn
about that in the later sessions now in
this tutorial we will have some demo on
running a map reduce and processing data
to solve some realtime business problems
now I have set up some code in Eclipse
which can be either tested on your
Windows machine by running it in a local
mode or packaging your code in jar
transferring it to your cluster and then
basically running it on your cluster
nodes so we'll see both of these
examples now let's assume and let's
understand about a problem say for
example we have a telecom based company
which would want to process its data say
it would want to find out the number of
subscribers and the kind of calls they
are making or for example let's imagine
a online website or a music website
where users listen to various tracks the
data gets collected and then basically
it has to be processed so imagine you
have a company which is uh hosting music
online and you have users who either are
subscribers or basically create their
accounts listen to different tracks and
then basically use these Services now
what if I would want to process such
data for example if I would want to find
out what is the number of unique
listeners or number of times the track
was shared with other users or number of
times the track was listened to on the
radio or in total or even was skipped on
the radio now in that case I would want
want to process the data to find out
information so we will solve this kind
of problem using the map reduce
programming model the map reduce
approach which as I explained earlier
goes for mapping and then for goes for
reducing and in between it has different
phases that is shuffling and sorting you
have your partitioner phase you have a
mini reducer which is your combiner
phase although all of these intermittent
phases are taken care by the framework
itself the developer or the person who
is developing the solution is
responsible to work on the mapper
function and the reducer function now
for that we can basically be writing our
code to process this data by giving a
mapper and a reducer function data we
can look into example and say for
example let me pull out some data here
let's look in say some files I have and
for example in this case it would be
this kind of data now that magnitude
could be anything right now here I have
the data which the First Column talks as
the user ID or the membership ID the
second is the track ID you have then
your if the track was shared online the
fourth one is number of times the track
was listened to in total and the fifth
one is if a particular track was skipped
now I could have this data in huge
numbers and then I could be processing
it but we will take a simple small
example to understand how map reduce
does this so this is a file which I
already uploaded on the cluster and
which will be as my input file now let's
look at the code so what we would need
is for this kind of processing we would
first need to understand the data now
here the First Column as I said is user
ID and second one is track ID which can
then be used to basically process the
data we need to write a mapper class
which would emit the track ID from this
data so I have it here and let me also
open up a constant class for this which
is here so as I mentioned we will have
to write a mapper class which would emit
track ID from the data and user IDs with
some intermediate key value pairs now
that is what your mapping phase does it
works on the input splits it basically
does the mapping and it gives you a list
of of data Elements which are nothing
but your intermediate key value pairs to
explain it in a simple way I would say
just let's work on this data sequence so
let's create a constant class as shown
here so this is my package now I create
a class called Last FM constants and
then I am here declaring some variables
with some constant values for each of
the field which I just showed in the
file you have user ID you have track ID
you you have is scrobbled or shared
radio and is skipped now these are my
constant which will be used while I
process then we will have to work on a
mapper class which could or which would
immediate uh emit intermediate key value
pairs that is your track ID and user ID
now how do we do that so here is an
example so we basically would have a
mapper class as it's seen here this is
my mapper class which will be used to
process or do the mapping phase now here
we have the class name which is unique
listener and unique listeners mapper
which extends the mapper class that
means I would have to import the
relevant packages for my code which I've
done on the top here then I have
variables that is track ID user ID which
use in writable so Hadoop has its own
data types say in writable long writable
Boolean writable which are similar to
what you have in Java as int Boolean
long but these data types which are used
by Hadoop are basically an
implementation of writeable and
writeable comparable interfaces so those
are two interfaces which are then
responsible for these classes which we
are using as data types in our code here
we start our map task which would then
consider key which is an object value as
in text and then you have your data
types that say inable text and object we
are also handling exception and then
what we do is we work on the file so we
would split it based on the D limiter
now in my case the D limiter is a pipe
then what we do is we set for the track
ID using our constants that is what we
have seen here which is for your user ID
track ID and so on and we do the same
thing we for our user ID we look look
into the values and then we basically
emit out just the track ID and user ID
that would be my intermediate key value
pairs now here I'm also using a counter
named invalid record count now that is
mainly to count if there are any invalid
records which do not exist in the file
in an expected format now you know we
don't do this uh in case of invalid
records if we don't do this what would
happen our if we had invalid records in
our file then our program might fail and
that's the reason I'm using counters.
invalid record. count and I'm going to
use it for my mapper once we have our
mapper written which basically will look
into the file and emit the track ID and
user ID then I would write my reducer
class now this is how my reducer class
looks where I'm saying public static
class unique listener reducer which
extends reducer class and then the data
types which it would need so inable for
the values which it works on so our
reduced task will work on track ID and
this reducer class is to aggregate the
results so we cannot directly use some
reducer as the records we are getting
are not unique the records might be
duplicates it might be the same user
with the same membership ID listening to
a different track or sharing it and we
cannot be just using a generic red ucer
so here we work on the reducer and this
is how my code would look so what my
reducer does it basically would help me
in solving the problem such as basically
aggregating and Counting the number of
tracks which were shared or listened to
or overall the number of tracks and then
you have your tracks which were skipped
one of the main task of your reducer
class is on working on the intermediate
data which is created by your mapper or
you can say multiple map tasks which
would be running on multiple splits on
one or multiple noes and your reducers
work is to aggregate the result based on
the keys here we are using set to
eliminate duplicate user IDs now once we
have written our reducer class which
basically works on the user ID set it
eliminates the duplicate user IDs and
then it basically gives me a count of
the track IDs in an aggregated way to
solve my use case once I've done that I
also need a driver class which basically
tells about my overall code so here we
are having a job configuration where I
say my name of the job could be unique
listeners per track I'm setting the jar
by class calling it as unique listeners
that's my class I'm mentioning my mapper
I'm mentioning my reducer now if you
notice I'm not using a combiner class
for for this use case we would not need
that so combiner class is a mini reducer
which basically helps in reducing the
data or aggregating the data before it
reaches the reducer class I am also
talking about the key which would be
using in writeable and then the value
which would also be inable as all my
values are in numeric if I had my key in
something else or if I had names instead
of user ID then I could have used text
class I also specify what would be my
put and output path which will be
specified as an argument and then
basically I'm printing out number of
invalid records so this is my map reduce
program to work on solving our business
use case also notice I'm using the
relevant packages which are being used
in the code and for these packages and
for my this code to compile we need to
make sure that we have added the right
dependencies now you could have created
your code with palom and using Maven or
based on the classes what you are using
you can always add the jars the relevant
jars to the build path so here we can
look at the build path what I have and
we can see what jars I have used so the
main ones are your Commons I have Hadoop
core now you can ignore Hive or Json
gson which I have here those are for
different applications so the main is
common CLI and Hadoop core depending on
what you are using within your
application so that has to be added to
your build path also we are having the
Java 1.8 now if I wanted to run this
application or test it on my local
machine I could have also set up the
configurations however it is preferred
to run the code on a Yan based cluster
if you would want to try it on Windows
then you can always go to the Run
configuration you can basically specify
your application which you would want to
run you can then say what is your class
name you can be passing in your
arguments here and in your environment
you can specify Hadoop as a local IP
however I suggest package it as jar and
run it on a cluster so what you could do
is you could select your class now my
unique listeners. Java class is also
getting the constants from Last FM
constants so both of them belong to the
same project and I'm using that here for
my mapper and for my reducer so in
mapper I refer to Last FM constants
where I've given constant values for all
of the these fields once you have your
code ready you can always package it as
jar by saying export and select the jar
option in Java click on next and then
you can select your project and give it
a name so I have I'm pointing into a
different jar file but I can do a browse
I've already packaged it as jar and you
can see I have a jar here so I can
select this I can say save and that
would be my jar if I'm making some
changes it will anyways overwrite it
once you have your your jar ready what
you need to do is place it on your
cluster now I have already done that I
have a cluster here let me bring it up
and what we can do is you can use
different ways you can have a Apache
cluster you could have a cloud era
cluster wherein you need to place so
let's get into this now here I'm using a
already set up lab environment you can
be doing an FTP you can upload your code
using Hue I have done an FTP from my
local machine and uploaded it to the
cluster I could click on web console
which basically gives me a console to
try out things you could as I said you
need the jar and then you need to push
your jar to your cluster let me log in
here and once I'm logged in I am on a
edge node which allows me to connect to
a cluster which is cloudas based and now
I can check on my hdfs path in my user
directory I should have multiple files
and directories and in in one of the
directories I have placed in this file
so we can look in here which is sample
Mr in and that's my directory where I
have the input so I can look in Sample
Mr in and the same file which I showed
in the beginning I have uploaded it here
which is the listeners file which we can
even check so I can say listeners. txt
and I can even do a cat so this is the
file which is already existing here
which has the content which we spoke
about although not huge content but it
is more than enough for us to test our
code and obviously we can upload huge
data and then have the same map reduce
program helping us in answering our
questions we also need the jar file and
the jar file should be here which I have
uploaded so I need to run this now to
run your map reduce you can say Hadoop
jar you will give your jar name which is
this one now I need to give my package
name name with my class name so I'll say
orc example Hadoop codes and then I need
to give my class which is unique
listeners now if I hit enter here it
will ask me to give an input and output
as my code says to pass in the arguments
so we will pass in the arguments here so
I'll say my directory where I have the
data now I could be picking up one file
or multiple files to process this so I
will say just one file which is here uh
uh and that's my file which is sample Mr
in that is what I want to use so I'll
say sample Mr in and I need to give my
file name so I can say listeners. txt
and then I can give an output which will
get created when you run your map R so I
can say sample Mr and then I can say
output one and this is the directory
which will get created which will have
my output now you can run this job in
this way you can even run it in a local
mode by specifying arguments on the
command line you can give different kind
of properties if you want your map
reduce jobs output to be in a compressed
format you can do all that so let's run
this and this should connect to the
resource manager the job is processing
one input file it will start with the
mapping phase first now it looks that
the job has failed due to some reason
let's have a look I just looked into the
job and I realized failed the main
reason was I was trying to write an
output in the directory to which I don't
have access I need to have access to
write the output in a directory to which
my user id has permissions for this we
will have to submit the job again with
the right path where it can write the
output so we can do this this is my
class I need input so I'll say and then
we can say sample Mr in and I'm looking
for listeners do txt and I need to give
an output which should be in this path
and then we can say sample Mr output one
and then submit the job now once I've
submitted the job as I said it has one
input part to process it is working on
one split because the file which we are
trying to work on is smaller than the
block size it goes for the mapping face
and then it goes for reducing and it's
done so if you carefully look at the map
reduce output here it says say the
number of outputs it had to process was
just four so every line by default is
considered as a record and we had
totally four lines the output is
basically working on again giving you
four records right because we are doing
a split based on the D limiter then this
would become an input to combiner if we
had a combiner class but we don't use
that so the output from your map goes to
the reduce which will basically work on
the input records and create output
records now we can have a look at this
the output of this job which is stored
in hdfs and I can either be giving a
complete path or I can just mention the
directory which I used and that should
by default take me to the directory
which should have my output now based on
how many reduced tasks were used you
will have number of part files which
show up here so we have one map and one
reduced task that could have controlled
or that could have been controlled by by
giving things on the command line so
here I have run it in a Yan mode where
Yann was used to allocate resources for
my applications and we can always check
that on the Yan UI or also by going to
say cloud era manager if that is
available if you're not using Cloud eras
cluster then you can always in Apache
cluster go to your Yan and you can go
into the UI wherever your resource
manager is running so that is one option
or if you have a cloud data cluster you
can look at in applications which will
show all the applications which were
recently run so this was the thing which
failed earlier because of permissions
and this is the one which succeeded now
I have a job ID which can always take me
to the Yan UI the history server where I
see how many map and jobs were run and
for further information you can always
go and look into the map and reduce
tasks so this was a map task which ran
within a container which was allocated
by your Yan and we can also look on the
Node and logs what really happened you
can also look into the reduce task you
can also look at the counters which we
were seeing on the command line on how
many map and reduce Stars how many bytes
were readed what was the garbage
collection time how much CPU time was
spent in milliseconds and you get all
the counters here you can specifically
be looking at counters for map or for
reduce so your Yan UI helps you to look
into for more information now if I go
back to my console and I have the output
file I can basically look into it by
selecting the output file and I can do a
cat which basically will show me what is
my output so this is my map reduce and
basically what it has done has it has
aggregated and pulled out the
information for your different listeners
based on the data what we have provided
let's look at one more example of using
map reduce programming model to solve a
realtime business case or a problem now
the problem in hand is that we have some
data collected from a telecom Giant and
basically we have some sample data here
which lists the list of subscribers
which are using the services now if I
look into the file I have call data
records which basically gives me
information about the data collected by
a telecom company so this Telecom
company keeps records of its subscribers
and it calls this particular file as
call data records now what does this
call data records contain it basically
has a from phone number as the first
field it has the two phone number that
is call being made to a particular
number then we have the call start time
following a Tim stamp you have a call
end time and then we have finally if
this call was a distance call or what we
call as STD call now what we need to do
is we need to use our knowledge of map
reduce we need to use the map reduce
programming model and we need to come up
with a code to find out all the phone
numbers for example who were making more
than 60 Minutes of STD calls now here
the flag one basically means it was an
STD call and zero means it was a local
call how do we do that using map reduce
so this is again a problem where you
would want to count through the data and
you would want to aggregate the values
to come up with result so let's look at
a sample code for this one so here I
have my eclipse and again like a
previous example we are having a class
which declares some constants for the
fields so you have phone number with
zero phone number with one call start
time call end time and an STD flag so
these are the constants which I would be
using in my code and here is my main
class which will use the map reduce
basically to solve this problem now I'm
importing the packages and as I
explained earlier these packages are
mainly to make sure that we can use the
classes in our code in the right way so
here now the order of your driver class
or your mapper and reducer does not
matter right the first thing what we
need is we need a mapper which will do
the map task so here I'm creating a
mapper which is tokenizer mapper and
that extends your mapper class it
accepts the data types that that is
object text and long writable as
explained earlier these are your data
types which are Hadoop specific and data
types like in writable long writeable
Boolean writable and many others depend
on the writeable and writeable
comparable interfaces now here we start
with taking up our phone number we
basically also take duration in minutes
so these are the variables and I'm using
the appropriate data type for those then
I start writing my map task now what
does my map task do it basically works
on the string which we have and it
breaks it into individual elements based
on a d limiter once that is done then we
are also checking if that particular
string which we are looking for has a
STD flag because we would want to find
out how many customers or how many of
them were making phone calls which were
more than 60 minutes and if these calls
were STD calls then basically I work on
the phone number and I set it using the
CDR constants for which we have already
created a class using the phone number
call end time call start time and I also
compute or calculate the long duration
because we need to find out the calls
which were more than 60 Minutes finally
we extract the phone numbers and the
duration of the call made by a
particular phone number so this would be
my mapper giving an intermediate output
which would then have to be sorted and
shuffled and then handed over to reducer
what does my reducer do it uses the
right data types it basically starts
with a sum as zero it would look into
all the keys and values and wherever it
would find Keys which are repeating and
the duration is more than 60 it would
give me an aggregated result this is my
reducer and finally we have a driver as
I explained earlier which has job
configuration your mapper reducer and
also we are using just as an example a
combiner class which does not have a
class of its own but it is basically
using the same reducer class once your
code is ready check if it compiles check
if you have all the dependencies met and
package it as jar transfer it to the
cluster and run it with or on top of yan
so what we can do is I have already
moved it here and we can look into this
machine I already have my jar file which
basically also needs a input which I
have already pushed to my cluster so we
can look in for the file which should be
existing in Sample Mr in directory which
is within my user and my name directory
and I have the call data records which
basically shows the data which I was
showing in the notepad file now I can
say Hadoop jar and point it to my jar
which is STD subscribers jar we need to
use the the package so I'll say or
example Hadoop codes that's my package
and my class name my class name is STD
subscribers so I will say STD
subscribers Dot and then you need to
give your input so we will say sample Mr
in and I will give in a particular file
which is call data records. txt and then
we can point it to an output directory
which will get created Auto
automatically so I will say output two
and that should have my result and like
we ran our first example now I'm again
running it on one simple file you can
imagine this as you can replace one
single file with a directory which has
multiple files where might be the
Telecom company was already collecting
data for couple of months and they would
like to analyze this and you can run it
in this way so once this is done we have
our output which can be seen by going
into the direct Tre saying sample Mr
output 2 and again this would have gone
for one single reducer so we can look at
whatever we gave as an output so it was
Sample Mr output 2 and that is my
directory so since this is a directory
my cat command does not work on it you
need to give the file so the command is
by giving the specific file not by
giving the directory so it is cat sample
Mr output to /part minus r and then you
can give five zeros and that should be
my out which would give me an
information of which were the users or
which were the phone numbers which made
calls greater than 60 minutes and if
these calls were STD calls and what was
the duration of the call so this is how
you can use map reduce programming model
to solve your realtime business cases
always remember you have to code and
create your mapper and reducer function
and rest will be done by the frame
Hadoop version one or map reduce version
one well that's outdated now and nobody
is using Hadoop version one but it would
be good to understand what was in Hadoop
version one and what were the
limitations of Hadoop version one which
brought in the thought for the future
processing layer that is Yan now when we
talk about Hadoop we already know that
Hadoop is a framework and Hadoop has two
layers one is your storage layer that is
your sdfs Hadoop distributed file system
which allows for distributed storage and
processing which allows fault tolerance
by inbuilt replication and which
basically allows you to store huge
amount of data across multiple commodity
machines when we talk about processing
we know that map reduce is the oldest
and the most mature processing
programming model which basically takes
care of of your data processing on your
distributed file system so in Hadoop
version one map reduce performed both
data processing and resource management
and that's how it was problematic in map
reduce we had basically when we talk
about the processing layer we had the
master which was called job tracker and
then you had the slaves which were the
task trackers so your job tracker was
taking care of allocating resources it
was performing scheduling and even
monitoring the jobs it basically was
taking care of assigning map and reduce
tasks to the jobs running on task
trackers and task trackers which were
collocated with data nodes were
responsible for processing the jobs so
task trackers were the slaves for the
processing layer which reported their
progress to the job tracker so this is
what was happening in Hadoop version one
now when we talk about Hadoop version
one we would have say client machines or
an API or an app application which
basically submits the job to the master
that is job tracker now obviously we
cannot forget that there would already
be an involvement from name node which
basically tells which are the machines
or which are the data nodes where the
data is already stored now once the job
submission happens to the job tracker
job tracker being the master demon for
taking care of your processing request
and also resource management job
scheduling would then be interacting
with your multiple task trackers which
would be running on multiple machines so
each machine would have a task tracker
running and that task tracker which is a
processing slave would be collocated
with the data nodes now we know that in
case of doop you have the concept of
moving the processing to wherever the
data is stored rather than moving the
data to the processing layer so we would
have task trackers which would be
running on multiple machines and these
task trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how how many resources and when
we talk about resources we are talking
about the CPU cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was eventually overburdened
right because it was managing jobs it
was tracking the resources from multiple
task trackers and basically it was
taking care of job scheduling so job
tracker would be overburdened and in a
case if job tracker would fail then it
would affect the overall processing so
if the master is killed if the master
demon dies then the processing cannot
proceed now this was one of the
limitations of Hadoop version one so
when you talk about scalability that is
the capability to scale due to a single
job tracker scalability would be hitting
a bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4,000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40,000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing Master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as I mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduced slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-map reduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of Hadoop version one and map
reduce that the only kind of processing
you could do is map reduce and map
reduce programming model although it is
good it is oldest it has matured over a
period of time but then it is very rigid
you will have to go for mapping and
reducing approach and that was the only
kind of processing which could be done
in Hadoop version one so when it comes
to doing a realtime analysis or doing ad
hoc query or doing a graph based
processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in Hadoop
version one which was having map reduce
version one as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for Yan
so Yan it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as I mentioned
before Yan in Hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was map
reduce we had the storage layer we had
the processing but then kind of limited
processing which could be done now this
was one thing which brought in a thought
that why shouldn't we have a processing
layer which can handle different kind of
workloads as I mentioned might be graph
process processing might be realtime
processing might be massive parallel
processing or any other kind of
processing which would be requirement of
an organization now designed to run map
reduce jobs only and having issues in
scalability resource utilization job
tracking Etc that led to the need of
something what we call as Yan now from
Hadoop version two onwards we have the
two main layers have changed a little
bit you have the store storage layer
which is intact that is your hdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called Yan yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
Yan works but then Yan is taking care of
your processing layer it does support
map ruce so map ruce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing Frameworks
Yan can be used to solve the issues
which Hadoop version one was posing
something like Resource Management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by Yan now when
we talk about Yan we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10,000 nodes
and can run more than 100,000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for Hadoop version one which
were primarily map reduce kind kind of
processing can run on Yan without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
propriety data access engines you can
perform realtime analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what Yan
offers so what is Yan as I mentioned Yan
stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster Resource
Management layer for your Apache Hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you you would
basically be telling the C cluster that
I would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
map reduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a map
reduce that might be a pig script which
is triggering a map reduce that could be
Hive with t as an execution Engine That
Could Be a spark application that could
be a graph processing application in any
of these cases you would still you as in
in sense client or basically an API or
the application would be requesting for
resources Yan would take care of that so
Yan would provide the desired resources
now when we talk about resources we are
mainly talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the CPU
course or as in terms of yan we say
virtual CPU course we would talk about
Ram that is in GB or MB or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and Yan would take care of of
this so with Yan you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional map
reduce which is mainly batch oriented
you could have an interactive execution
engine something as Tas you could have
hbase which is a column oriented or a
four-dimensional database and that would
be not only storing data on sdfs but
would also need some kind of processing
you could have streaming function alties
which would be from storm or Kafka or
spark you could have graph processing
you could have inmemory processing such
as spark and its components and you
could have many others so these are
different Frameworks which could now run
and which can run on top of yan so how
does Yan do that now when we talk about
Yan this is how a overall Yan
architecture looks so at one end you
have the client now client could be
basically your Ed Edge node where you
have some applications which are running
it could be an API which would want to
interact with your cluster it could be a
user triggered application which wants
to run some jobs which are doing some
processing so this client would submit a
job request now what is resource manager
doing resource manager is the master of
your processing layer in Hadoop version
one we basically had job tracker and
then we had task trackers which were
running on individual nodes so your task
trackers were sending your heartbeats to
the job tracker your task trackers were
sending it their resource information
and job tracker was the one which was
tracking the resources and it was doing
the job scheduling and that's how as I
mentioned earlier job tracker was
overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mention when we say yet another resource
negotiator so appm would be existing in
a Hado version two now when we talk
about your resource manager resource
manager is the master for processing
layer so it would already be receiving
heartbeats and you can say resource
information from multiple node managers
which would be running on one or
multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if
I'm talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
RAM for processing and some amount of
CPU cores and that is just a portion of
of what the complete node has so if my
node has say imagine my node has around
100 100 GB RAM and I have save 60 cores
all of that cannot be allocated to node
manager so node manager is just one of
the components of Hadoop ecosystem it is
the slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different Services which are
running might be Cloud era or hoton
Works related Services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 GB Ram per
node and say 40 CPU course so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing Master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as I mentioned your resource
manager has these services or components
which basically helps it to do the
things it is basically a an architecture
where multiple components are working
together to achieve what Yan allows so
resource manager has mainly two
components that is your scheduler and
applications manager and these are at
high level four main components here so
we talk about resource manager which is
the processing Master you have node
managers which are the processing slaves
which are running on every noes you have
the concept of container and you have
the concept cep of application Master
how do all these things work now let's
look at Yann components so resource
manager basically has two main
components you can say which assist
resource manager in doing what it is
capable of so you have scheduler and
applications manager now there is when
you talk about resources there is always
a requirement for the applications which
need to run on cluster of resources so
your application which has to run which
was submitted by client needs resources
and these resources are coming in from
multiple machines wherever the relevant
data is stored and a node manager is
running so we always know that node
manager is collocated with data nodes
now what does the Schuler do so we have
different kind of schedulers here we
have basically a capacity Schuler we
have a fair scheduler or we could have a
fifo scheduler so there are different
schedulers which take care of resource
allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to Hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as I mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of Hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means multiple
applications could be running in the
cluster and they would have a fair share
of the resources you could have a
capacity scheduler which would basically
have dedicated or fixed amount of
resources across the cluster now
whichever Schuler is being used Schuler
is mainly responsible for allocating
resources then it's your applications
manager now this is responsible for
accepting job submissions now as I said
at higher level we could always say
resource manager State doing everything
it is allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application Master
it provides the service for restarting
the application Master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as I said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting on which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as I mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its Ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks will stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exist now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and a
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
it's work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when I say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resp sources
for example it would be saying can I
have 1 GB of RAM and one CPU core from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
I again have 1 GB and one CPU core from
you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has as your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which are called container so
this request of holding resource can be
considered as a container so basically a
container can be of different sizes we
will talk about that so resource manager
negotiates the resources with node
manager now node manager which is
already giving an update of the
resources it has what amount of
resources it holds how much busy it is
can basically approve or deny this
request so node manager would basically
approve in saying yes I could hold these
resources I could give you this
container of this particular size now
once the container has been approved or
allocated or you can say granted by your
node manager resource manager now knows
that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called appm so
this is a piece of of code which would
also be running in one of the containers
it would be running in one of the
containers which would then take care of
execution of tasks in other containers
so your application Master is per
application so if I would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
Masters one appm being responsible for
per application now what does this app
Master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your appm would
run in one of the containers and then it
would use the other containers which
node manager has guaranteed that it will
give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the App Master will run the
processing tasks Within These designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application Master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application Master application Master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as I said is a
collection of resources like CPU memory
your disk which could be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master and
it basically is granting this request or
basically is allocating these containers
now again we could have different sizing
of the containers let's take an example
here so as I mentioned from the total
resources which are available for a
particular node some portion of
resources are allocated to the node
manager so let's imagine this is my node
where node manager as a processing slave
is running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of RAM
and CPU course is basically allocated to
the node manager so I could say out of
total 100 GB Ram we can say around 60
cores which the particular node has so
so this is my Ram which the node has and
these are the CPU cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be 70% or 60% of the total
resources so we could say around 60 GB
RAM and then we could say around 40
vores have been allocated to node
manager so there are these settings
which are given in the Yan hyphen site
file now apart from this allocation that
is 60 GB RAM and 40 V course we also
have some properties which say what will
be the container sizes so for example we
could have a small container setting
which could say my every container could
have 2 GB RAM and say one virtual CPU
core so this is my smallest container So
based on the total resources you could
calculate how many such small containers
could be running so if I say 2 GB Ram
then I could have around 30 containers
but then I'm talking about one virtual
CPU core so totally I could have around
30 small containers which could be
running in parallel on a particular node
and as of that calculation you would say
10 CPU Cordes are not being utilized you
could have a bigger container size which
could say I would go for 2 CPU cores and
3 GB Ram so 3 GB RAM and 2 CPU cores so
that would give me around 20 containers
of bigger size so this is the container
sizing which is again defined in the Yan
hyphen site file so what we know is on a
particular node which has this kind of
allocation either we could have 30 small
containers running or we could have 20
big containers running and same would
apply to multiple nodes so node manager
based on the request from application
Master can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
Master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application Master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on Yan then it
would be 10 application Masters one
responsible for each application your
application Master is the one which also
interacts with the Schuler to basically
know how much amount of resources could
be allocated for one application and
your application Master is the one which
uses these resources but it can never
negotiate for more resources to node
Manager application Master cannot do
that application master has to always go
back to resource manager if it needs
more resources so it is always the
resource manager and internally resource
manager component that is application
manager which negotiates the resources
at any point of time due to some node
failures or due to any other
requirements if application Master needs
more resources on one or multiple notes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is this is how it looks so your
client submits the job request to
resource manager now we know that
resource manager internally has schuer
and applications manager node managers
which are running on multiple machines
are the ones which are tracking their
resources giving this information to
resource manager so that resource
manager or I would say its component
applications manager could request
resources from multiple node managers
when I say request resources it is these
containers so your resource manager
basically will request for the resources
on one or multiple noes node manager is
the one which approves these containers
and once the container has been approved
your resource manager triggers a piece
of code that is application Master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
we'll use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or I would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
allocates a container application Master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run and application
Master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other
processing
so before we look into the demo on how
Yan works I would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloud era so you
can just look for Yann untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which I explained just now
so as we mentioned mentioned here so you
basically have the master process you
have the worker process which basically
takes care of your processing your
resource manager being the master and
node manager being the slave this also
talks about the resources which each
node manager has it talks about the Yan
configuration file where you give all
these properties it basically shows you
node manager which reports the amount of
resources it has to resource manager now
remember if worker know shows 8 into to8
CPU cores and 128 GB RAM and if your
node manager says 64 V course and RAM
128 GB then that's not the total
capacity of your node it is some portion
of your node which is allocated to node
manager now once your node manager
reports that your resource manager is
requesting for containers based on the
application what is a container it is
basically a logical name given to a
combination of Vore and RAM it is with
within this container where you would
have basically the process running so
once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application Master within the
container and what does that application
Master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about map reduce if
you have already followed the map reduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as I said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to Yan so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
Cloud era or hoton Works related
Services running and other processes
which might be running and based on that
some portion of RAM and CPU cores would
be allocated to node manager so that's
how it would be done in the Yan hyphen
site file and this basically shows you
what is the total amount of memory and
CPU course which is allocated to node
manager then within every machine where
you have a node manager running on every
machine in the Yan hyphen site file you
would have such properties which would
say what is the minimum container size
what is the maximum container size in
terms of ram what is the minimum for CPU
code what is the maximum for CPU cores
and what is the incremental size in
where RAM and CPU cores can increment so
these are some of the properties which
Define how containers are allocated for
your application request so have a look
at this and this could be uh a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in Yan which talks about Fair
schuer or you basically having different
cues in which allocations can be done
you also have different ways in which
cues can be managed and different
schedulers can be used so you can always
look at this series of blog you can also
be checking for Yan schedulers and then
search for uh dup definitive guide and
that could give you some information on
how it looks when you look for Ado
definitive guide so if you look into
this book which talks about the
different resources as I mentioned so
you could have a fe4 Schuler that is
first in first out which basically means
if a long running application is
submitted to the cluster all other small
running applications will have to wait
there is no other way but that would not
be a preferred option if you look in
fifo Schuler if you look for capacity
scheduler it basically means that you
could have different cues created and
those cues would have resources alloc
located so then you could have a
production queue where production jobs
are running in a particular queue which
has fixed amount of resources allocated
you could have a development queue where
development jobs are running and both of
them are running in parallel you could
then also look into Fair Schuler which
basically means again multiple
applications could be running on the
cluster however they would have a fair
share so when I say fair share in brief
what it means is if I had given 50% of
resources to a que for production and
50% of resources for a que of
development and if both of them are
running in parallel then they would have
access to 50% of cluster resources
however if one of the que is unutilized
then second Q can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how cues
can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with Yan in the form
of a demo to understand and learn on how
Yan works we can look into a particular
cluster now here we have a designated
cluster which can be used you could be
using the similar kind of commands on
your Apache based cluster or a cloud era
quick start VM if you already have or if
you have a cloud era or a hot and works
cluster running there are different ways
in which we can interact with Yan and we
can look at the information one is
basically looking into the admin console
so if I would look into Cloud era
manager which is basically an admin
console for a cloud eras distribution of
a dupe similarly you could have a hot
enworks cluster and access to the admin
console so if you have even read access
for your cluster and if you have the
admin console then you can search for
Yan as a service which is running you
can click on Yan as a service and that
gives you different tabs so you have the
instances which tells basically what are
the different roles for your Yan service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as I was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for Yan app map reduce
application Master resource CPU course
what is the CPU course allocated for map
reduce map task reduce task you can be
looking at Yan node manager resource CPU
course which basically says every node
manager on every node would be allocated
with six CPU cores and the container
sizing is with minimum allocation of one
CPU core and the maximum could be two
CPU cores similarly you could also be
searching for memory allocation and here
you could then scroll down to see what
kind of memory allocation has been done
for the node manager so if we look
further it should give me information of
node manager which basically says here
that the container minimum allocation is
2 GB the maximum is 3gb and we can look
at node manager which has been given 25
GB per node so it's a combination of
this memory and CPU course which is the
total amount of resources which have
been allocated to every node manager now
we can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on Yan
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on Yan you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web UI and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web UI and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 GB memory allocated so
that could be say 25 GB per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
I could get more information so this
tells me that I have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 GB memory allocated per node and six
scores out of which some portion is
being utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root que and within root
you have default que and you have
basically users queue based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root.
default has 50% of resources and the
other que also has 50% of resources
which also gives me an idea that a fair
scheduler is being used we can always
confirm that if we are using a fair
scheduler or a capacity scheduler which
takes care of allocations so search for
scheduler and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of Schuler is
being used and what are the allocations
given for that particular Schuler so
here we have Fair scheduler it shows me
you have under root you have the root Q
which has been given 100% capacity and
then you have within that default which
also takes 100% so this is how you can
understand about Yan by looking into the
Yan web UI you can be looking into the
configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your Yan UI what I can also
do is I can be going into Hue which is
the web interface and your web interface
also basically allows you to look into
the jobs so you can click on Hue web UI
and if you have access to that it should
show up or you should have a way to get
to your Hue which is a graphical user
interface mainly comes with your Cloud
era you can also configure that with
Apache hoton Works has a different way
of giving you the web UI access you can
click and get into Hue and that is also
one way where you can look at Yan you
can look at the job
which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
Yan web UI or here in Hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here I can just remove this one
which would basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here I have list of all the
applications and it says this was a map
reduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful and this
was basically a probably a hive query
which triggered a map reduce job you can
click on the application and that tells
you how many tasks were run for it so
there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata data
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the Yan UI to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduce
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web UI to look
into the jobs you can be finding in lot
of useful information here you can also
be looking at how many sources were used
and what happened to the job was it
successful did it fail and what was the
job status now apart from web UI which
always you might not have access to so
in a particular cluster in a production
cluster there might be restrictions and
the organization might not have uh
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud era manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your Edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in map red
which gives you different options where
you can look at the map reduce related
jobs you can look at different cues if
there are cues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if I just say map
red and Q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the cues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list and that
should give you different cues which
were being used now here we know that
per user a q dynamically gets created
which is under root. users and that
gives me what is the status of the queue
what is the capacity has there been any
kind of maximum capacity or capping done
so we get to see a huge list of cues
which dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root. default I could have also
picked up one particular cue and I could
have said show me the the jobs so I
could do that now here we can also give
a Yan command so let me just clear the
screen and I will say Yan and that shows
me different options so apart from your
web interface something like web UI
apart from your Yan's web UI you could
also be looking for information using
Yan commands here so these are some list
of commands which we can check now you
can just type in Yan and version if you
would want want to see the version which
basically gives you information of what
is the Hadoop version being used and
what is the vendor specific distribution
version so here we see we are working on
cloud eras distribution 5.14 which is
internally using Hadoop 2.6 now
similarly you can be doing a Yan
application list so if you give this
that could be an exhaustive list of all
the applications which are running or
applications which have completed so
here we don't don't see any applications
because right now probably there are no
applications which are running it also
shows you you could be pulling out
different status such as submitted
accepted or running now you could also
say I would want to see the services
that I finished running so I could say
Yan application list and app States as
finished so here we could be using our
Command so I could say Yan application
list and then I would would want to see
the app states which gives me the
applications which have finished and we
would want to list all the applications
which finished now there that might be
applications which succeeded right and
there is a huge list of application
which is coming in from the history
server which is basically showing you
the huge list of applications which have
completed so this is one way and then
you could also be searching for one
particular application if you would want
to search a particular application if
you have the application ID you could
always be doing a grip that's a simple
way I could say basically let's pick up
this one and if I would want to search
for this if I would want more details on
this I could obviously do that by
calling in my previous command and you
could do a GP if that's what you want to
do and if you would want to search is
there any application which is in the
list of my applications that shows my
application I could pull out more
information about my application so I
could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application ID so I could say Yan logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so I can say Yan logs
application ID now we copied an
application ID and we could just give it
here we could give other options like
app owner or if you would want to get
into the Container details or if you
would want to check on a particular node
now here I'm giving Yan logs and then
I'm pointing it to an application ID and
it says the log aggregation has not
completed might be this was might be
this was an application which was
triggered based on a particular
interactive shell or based on a
particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill application so
here you can be saying yan yan
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app States you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status I could be giving
my application ID so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application ID what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much GB memory and how
many C Core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now I could kill an application
if the application was already running I
could always do a Yan application minus
kill and then I could be giving my
application now I could try killing this
however it would say the application is
already finished if I had an application
running and if my application was
already given an application ID by The
Source manager I Could Just Kill it I
can also say Yan node list which should
give me a list of the node managers now
this is what we were looking from the
Yan web UI and we were pulling out the
information so we can get this and kind
of information from your command line
always remember and always try to be
well accustomed with the command line so
you can do various things from the
command line and then obviously you have
the web uis which can help you with a
graphical interface easily able to
access things now you could be also
starting the resource manager which we
would not be doing here here because we
are already running in a cluster so you
could give a Yan resource manager you
could get the logs of resource manager
if you would want by giving Yan demon so
we can try that so you can say Yan and
then demon so it says it does not find
the demon so you can give something like
this get level and here I will have to
give the node and the IP address where
you want to check the logs of resource
man manager so you could be giving this
for which we will have to then get into
cloud data manager to look into the
nodes and the IP address you could be
giving a command something like this
which basically gives you the level of
the log which you have and I got this
resource manager address from the web UI
now I can be giving in this command to
look into the demon log and it basically
says you would want to look at the
resource manager related log L and you
have the log 4J which is being used for
logging the kind of level which has been
set as info which can again be changed
in the way you're logging the
information now you can try any other
commands also from Yan for example
looking at the Yan RM admin so you can
always do a Yan RM admin and this
basically gives you a lot of other
informations like refreshing the cues or
refreshing the noes or basically looking
at the admin ACLs or getting groups so
you could always get group names for a
particular user now we could search for
a particular user such as Yan or hdfs
itself so I could just say here I would
want get groups and then I could be
searching for say username hdfs so that
tells me hdfs belongs to a Hadoop group
similarly you could search for say maed
or you could search for Yan so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when
you're doing commissioning
decommissioning but then in case of
cloud era or hoton Works kind of cluster
you would not be manually giving this
command because if you are doing a
commissioning decommissioning from an
admin console and if you are an
administrator then you could would just
restart the services which are affected
and that will take care of this but if
you were working in an Apache cluster
and if you were doing commissioning
decommissioning then you would be using
in two commands refresh nodes and
basically that's for refreshing the noes
which should not be used for processing
and similarly you could have a command
refresh noes which comes with htfs so
these are different options which you
can use with your Yan on the command
line you could also be using curl
commands to get more information about
your cluster by giving curl minus X and
then basically pointing out to your
resource manager web UI address now here
I would like to print out the cluster
related metrics and I could just simply
do this which basically gives me a high
level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or CPU course and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
Schuler information so you would just
replace the metrics with Schuler and you
could get the information of the
different cues now that's a huge list we
can cancel this and that would give me
the list of all the cues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each que you could also
get cluster information on application
IDs and Status running of applications
running in Yan so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say I would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
notes so you can always be looking at
not specific information which gives you
how many notes you have but this this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
HTTP interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample map reduce job
which could then be triggered on Yann
and it would use the resources now I can
look at my application here and I can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have lot of
files and directories which we have here
now I could pick up one of these and I
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and I could run a
simple word count or I could be running
a hive query which triggers a map reduce
job I could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if I would say Spark to
Shell now I know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do a spark to Shell by
default it will contact Yan so it gets
an application ID it is running on Yan
with the master being Yan and now I have
access to the interactive way of working
with spark now if I go and look into
applications I should be able to see my
application
which has been started here and it shows
up here so this is my application
3827 which has been started on Yan and
as of now we can also look into the Yan
UI and that shows me the application
which has been started which basically
has one running container which has one
CPU core allocated 2GB RAM and it's in
progress although we are not doing
anything there so we can always look at
our applications from the Yan UI or as I
mentioned from your applications tab
within Yan Services which gives us the
information and you can even click on
this application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which I triggered using
spark shell similarly I can basically be
running a map reduce now to run a map
reduce I can say Hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt Cloud
era Parcels
CDH lib Hadoop map reduce Hadoop map
reduce examples and then we can look at
this particular jar file and if I hit on
enter it shows me the different classes
which are part of this jar and here I
would like to use word count so I could
just give this I could say word count
now remember I could run the job in a
particular que by giving in an argument
here so I I could say minus D map red.
job. q. name and then I can point my job
to a particular queue I can even give
different arguments in saying I would
want my map reduce output to be
compressed or I want it to be stored in
a particular directory and so on so here
I have the word count and then basically
what I can be doing is I can be pointing
it to a particular input path and then I
can have my output which can be getting
stored here here again a directory which
we need to choose and I will say output
new and I can submit my job now once
I've submitted my job it connects to
resource manager it basically Gets a Job
ID it gets an application ID it shows
you from where you can track your
application you can always go to the Yan
UI and you can be looking at your
application and the resources it is
using so my application was not a big
one and it has already completed it
triggered one map task it launched one
reduced task it was working on around
12466 records where you have then the
output of map which is these many number
of output records which was then taken
by a combiner and finally by a reducer
which basically gives you the output so
this is my Yan application which has
completed now I could be looking into
the Yan UI and if my job has completed
you might not see your application here
so as of now it shows up here the word
count which I ran it also shows me my
previous Park shell job it shows me my
application is completed and if you
would want further information on this
you can click and go to the history
server if you have been given access to
it or directly go to the history server
web UI where your application shows up
it shows how many map and reduce task it
was running you can click on this
particular application which basically
gives you information of your map
introduced tasks you can look at
different counters for your application
right you can always look at map
specific tasks you can always look into
one particular task what it did on which
node it was running or you can be
looking at the complete application log
so you can always click on the logs and
here you have click here for full log
which gives you the information and you
can always look for your application
which can give you information of App
Master being launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released
released so you can always look into the
log for more information so this is how
you can interact with Yan this is how
you can interact with your command line
to look for more information or using
your Yan web UI or you can also be
looking into your Hue for more
information we're going to start getting
into the tools because you had all those
pictures of all those Cool Tools we have
so we're going to look at the first two
of those tools and uh in the tools we
have scoop and Flume and this is for
your data collection and ingestion so
where does the need for scoop come in in
our big data Hado file system processing
huge volumes of data requires loading
data from diverse sources into Hadoop
cluster you can see here we have our
data processing and this process of
loading data from the heterogeneous
sources comes with a set of challenges
so what are the challenges maintaining
data consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terab terabytes and pedabytes
of data over the course of time loading
bulk data to hudo was not possible this
one of the big challenges that came up
when they first had the Hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to Hadoop very easily so
think your Enterprise server you want to
take the from MySQL or your SQL and you
want to bring that data into your Hadoop
Warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between Hadoop and
external data storage such as relational
data bases and my SQL server or the
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server so
scoop equals SQL plus Hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is is the middle ground and brings
the import into the Hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from Hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel Import and Export
it has import results of SQL query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
Kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so when we
look at parallel Import and Export scoop
uses yarn yet another resource
negotiator framework to Import and
Export data this provides fault
Tolerance on a top of parallelism scoop
allows us to import the result return
from an SQL carry into the Hadoop file
system or the hdfs and you can see here
where the import results of SQL query
come in scoop provides connectors for
multiple relational database management
system rdbms's databases such as MySQL
and Microsoft SQL server and it has
connectors for all major rdbms databases
scoop supports Kerberos computer network
Authentication Protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing The Hop cluster and the client
comes in and sends their command which
goes into scoop the client submits the
import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have enter Enterprise data warehouse
document based systems you have connect
connector for your data warehouse a
connector for document based systems
which reaches out to those two entities
and we have our connector for the rdbms
so connectors help in working with a
range of popular databases multiple
mappers perform map tasks to load the
data onto hdfs the Hadoop file system
and you can see here we have the map
task if you remember from Hadoop Hadoop
is based on map reduce because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over it only accesses the mappers and it
opens up multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbas high is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can out
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our rdbms data store and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your um
company's database maybe it's an archive
at Google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think um with
scoop you think SQL you think my SQL
server or Microsoft SQL Server that kind
of setup uh so it gathers the metadata
and you see the scoop import so
introspect database to gather metadata
primary key information and then it
submits uh so you can see submits map
only job remember we talked about map
reduce it only needs the map side of it
because we're not reducing the data
we're just mapping it over scoop divides
the input data set into splits and uses
individual map test to push the split
into hdfs so right into the Hadoop file
system and you can see down on the right
is kind of a small depiction of a Hadoop
cluster and then you have scoop export
so we're going to go the other direction
and with the other direction you have
your Hadoop file system storage which is
your Hadoop cluster you have your scoop
job and each one of those clusters then
gets a map mapper comes out to each one
of the computers that has data on it um
so the first step is you got to gather
the metadata so step one you gather the
metadata step two submits map only job
introspect database to gather metadata
primary key information scoop divides
the input data set into splits and uses
individual map test to push the splits
to rdbms scoop will export Hadoop files
back to rdms tables and you can think of
this in a number of different manners
one of them would be if you're restoring
a backup from the Hadoop file system
into your Enterprise machines there's
certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our URL so
specify the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify The
Connection Manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use Hadoop map reduce home directory
override Hadoop mapped home username uh
set authentication username and of
course help print uses instructions and
with the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
The Connection Manager class to use
manually specify jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the Hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentic indication username and
finally you can print out all your help
setup so you can see the format for
scoop is pretty straightforward both
Import and Export so let's uh continue
on our path and look at scoop processing
and what the computer goes through for
that and we talk about scoop processing
first scoop runs in the Hadoop cluster
it Imports data from the rdbms the nosql
database to the Hadoop file system so
remember we might not be importing the
data from a rdbms it might actually be
coming from a no SQL and there's many
out there he uses mappers to slice the
incoming data into multiple formats and
load the data into hdfs it exports data
back into an rdbms while making sure
that the schema of the data in the
database is maintained so now that we've
looked at the basic commands in our
scoop and the scoop processing or at
least the basics as far as um theory is
concerned let's just jump in and take a
look at a demo on
scoop
for this demo I'm going to use our Cloud
Dera quick start if you've been watching
our other demos we've done you'll see
that we've been using that pretty
consistently certainly this will work in
any of your um your Horton sandbox which
is also a single node testing machine
Cloud Dera is one of um there's the
docker version instead of virtual box
and you can also set up your own had
doop cluster plan a little extra time if
you're not an admin it's actually a
pretty um significant Endeavor for an
admin if you've been admin Linux
machines for a very long time and you
know a lot of the commands I find it for
most admins it takes them about two to
four hours the first time they go in and
create a virtual machine and set up
their own Hadoop in this case though and
you're just learning and getting setup
best to start with Cloudera Cloudera
also includes an installed version of
MySQL that way you don't have to worry
install the the SQL version for
importing data from and to once you're
in the cloud era quick start you'll see
it opens a nice sentos Linux um
interface and it has the desktop setup
on there this is really nice for
learning so you're not just looking at
command lines and from in here it should
open up by default to uh Hue if not you
can click on Hue Hugh is a a kind of a
fun little uh web-based interface under
Hue I can go under query I can pick an
editor and we'll go right down to scoop
uh so now I'm just going to load the
scoop editor inner Hue now I'm going to
switch over and do this all in command
line I just want to show that you can
equally do this in a hue through the
webbase interface the reason I like to
do the command line is specifically on
my computer it runs much quicker or if I
do the command line here and I run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason I do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our MySQL
so we have something to scoop in
otherwise I don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in we'll
zoom in this and increase the size of
our screen so for this demo our Hands-On
I'm going to use Oracle virtual box
manager and the cloud era quick start if
you're not familiar with this we do have
another tutorial we put out and you can
send a note in the YouTube video below
and let our team know and they'll send
you a link or come visit www.s
simplylearn
docomo box on my Windows computer so
we're going to be in Linux and it'll be
the cloud Dera version uh with scoop and
we'll also be using MySQL my SQL Server
once inside the Cloudera virtual box um
we'll go under the Hue editor now we're
going to do everything in terminal
window but I just want you to be aware
that under the Hue editor you can go
under query editor and you'll see as we
come down here here's our scoop on this
so you can run your Scoop from in here
now before we do this we have to do a
little exploration in MySQL a MySQL
server that way we know what data is is
coming in so let me go ahead and open up
a terminal window in Cloud era you have
a terminal window at the top here that
you can just click on and open it up and
let me just go ahead and zoom in on here
go View and zoom in now to get into my
SQL Server you simply type in MySQL and
this part will depend on your setup now
the cloud era quick start comes up that
the username is root and the password is
cloud Dera kind of a strange Quirk is
that you can put a space between the
minus U and the root but not between the
minus p and the cloud era usually you
put in a minus capital P and then it
prompts you for your password on here
for this demo I don't worry too much
about you knowing the uh password on
that so we'll just go right into my SQL
Server since this is the standard
password for this quickart and you can
see we're now into my SQL and we're
going to do just a couple of quick um
commands in here there show databases
and you followed by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these um shell
commands so it knows it's the end of
your shell command and you'll see in
here in the quick start Cloud era quick
start the MySQL comes with a standard
set of databases these are just um some
of these have to do like with the uzi
which is the uzi part of Hadoop where
others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see in the
list here we have a retailor DB and then
we can simply do uh use
retailor DB this will set that as a
default in MySQL and then we want to go
ahead and show the tables and if we show
the tables you can see under the
database the retail DB database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products uh so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard um
SQL command and if you did our Hive
language you'll know remember it's the
same for um hql also on this which we're
just going to select star everything
from departments so there's our
departments table and we're going to
list everything on the Departments table
and you'll see we have about six lines
in here and it has a department ID and a
department name uh two for Fitness three
for Footwear so on and so forth now at
this point I can just go ahead and exit
but it's kind of nice to have this data
up here so we can look at it and flap
back and forth between the screens so
I'm going to open up another terminal
window and we'll go ahead and zoom in on
this also and it isn't too important for
this particular particular setup uh but
it's always kind of f fun to know what
your setup you're working with what is
your host name and so we'll go ahead and
just type that in this is a Linux
command and it's uh host name minus F
and you see we're on quick start Cloud
era no surprise there now this next
command is going to be a little bit
longer because we're going to be doing
our first scoop command and I I'm going
to do two of them we're going to list
databases and list tables it's going to
take just a moment to get through this
uh because there's a bunch of stuff
going on here so we have scoop we have
list databases we have connect and under
the connect command we need to let it
know how we're connecting we're going to
use the jdbc this is a very standard one
uh jdbc MySQL so you'll see that if
you're doing an SQL database that's how
you start it off with and then the next
part this is where you have to go look
it up it's how it was created so if your
admin created a MySQL server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as Local Host so you'll see
something like local host sometimes
there's a lot of different formats uh
but the most common is either local host
or the actual connection so in this case
we want to go ahead and do quick start
3306 and so quick start is the name of
the Local Host database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quick start for um for Hadoop under
Cloud daa it's Port 3306 is where that's
coming in so that's where all that's
coming from uh and so there's our path
for that and then we have to put in our
password we typ type password and if you
look it up password on the cloud era
quick start is Cloudera and we have to
also let it know the username and again
if you're doing this you'd probably put
in a minus Capital you can actually just
do for prompt CL the for the password so
if you leave that out it'll prompt you
uh but for this doesn't really matter I
don't care if you see my password it's a
default one for cloud era quick start
and then the username on here is simply
root and then we're going to put put our
semicolon at the end and so we have here
our full setup and we go ahead and list
the databases uh and you'll see you
might get some warnings on here I
haven't run the updates on the quick
start um I suggest you're not running
the updates either if you're doing this
for the first time because it'll do some
reformatting on there and it quickly pop
up and you can see here's all of our um
the tables we went in there and if we go
back to on the previous window we should
see that these tables match so here we
come in and here we have our databases
and you can see back up here where we
had uh the CM customers employees and so
on so the databases match and then we
want to go ahead and list the uh tables
for a specific database so let's go
ahead and do that I'm a very lazy typist
so I'll put the up arrow in and you can
see here scoop list databases we're just
going to go back and change this from
databases to list tables so we want to
list the tables in here same connection
so most of the connection is the same
except we need to know which tables
we're listing and and interesting fact
is you can create a table without being
under a database so if you left this
blank it will show the open tables that
aren't connected directly to a database
or under a database but what we want to
do is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that
retailor DB because that's the database
we're going to be working with and this
will go in there and show the tables
listed under that database and here we
go we got categories customers
departments order items and products if
we flip back here real quick there it is
the same thing we had we had U
categories customers departments order
items and so on and so let's go ahead
and run our first import command and
again I'm that lazy typer uh so we're
going to do scoop and instead of list
tables we want to go ahead and import so
there's our import command and so once
we have our import command in there then
we need to tell it exactly what we're
going to import so everything else is
the same we're importing from the retail
DB so we keep that and then at the very
end we're going to tag on-- table that
tells us we can tell out what table
we're importing from and we're going to
import departments there we go so this
is pretty straightforward because what's
nice about this as you can see the
commands are the same I got the same
connection um I change it for the
whatever database I'm in um then I come
in here our password and the username
are going to be the same that's all
under the MySQL server setup uh and then
we let it know what table we're entering
at we run this and this is going to
actually go through the mapper process
in Hadoop so this is a mapping process
it takes the data and it Maps it up to
different parts in the setup in Hadoop
on there and then saves that data into
the Hadoop file system and it does take
it a moment to zip through which I kind
of skipped over for you uh since it is
running a you know it's designed to run
across the cluster not on a single node
so when you're running on a single node
it's going to run slow even if you
dedicate uh a couple cores to it I think
I put dedicated four cores to this one
uh and so you can see right down here we
get to the end is now mapped in that
information and then we can go in here
we can go under um can flip back to our
our Hue and under Hue on the top I have
there's databases and the second icon
over is your Hado file system and we can
go in here and look at the hudo file
system and you'll see it show up
underneath our documents there it is
departments Cloudera departments and um
you can see there's always a delay when
I'm working in Hue which I don't like
and that's the quick start issue uh
that's not necessarily running out on a
server when I'm running out on a server
you pretty much have to run through some
kind of server interface I still prefer
the terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker uh but we'll flip back on over
here to uh the command line and we can
do the Hadoop type in the Hadoop fs and
then list minus LS and if we run this
you'll see underneath our Hado file
system there is our departments which
has been added in and we can also do uh
Hadoop fs and this is kind of
interesting for those who've gone
through the Hadoop file system
everything you'll you'll recognize this
on here but I'm going to list it the
contents of departments and you'll see
underneath departments uh we have part
part M 0000 001 002 003 and so this is
interesting because this is how Hadoop
saves these files this is in the file
system this is not in Hive so we didn't
directly import this into Hive uh we put
this in the Hado file system depending
on what you're doing you would then
write the schema for Hive to look at the
Hadoop file system certainly visit our
Hive tutorial for more information on
hive specific uh so you can see in here
are different files that it forms that
are part of departments and we can do
something like this we can uh look at
the contents of one of these files FS
minus LS or a number of the files and
we'll simply do uh the full path which
is user Cloud era and then we already
know the next one is departments and
then after departments we're going to
put slash part star so this is going to
say anything that has part in it um so
we have part- M 000000 and so on uh we
can go ahead and cat use that cat
command or that list command to bring
the up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a a Linux command had doop
Linux command to cat catenate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here Fitness Footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our uh MySQL
server uh when we went in here we did a
select all on here there it is Fitness
Footwear apparel golf outdoors and fan
shop and then of course it's really
important let's flip back on over here
to be able to tell it where to put the
data uh so we go back to our import
command so here's our scoop import we
have our connect we have the DB
underneath our connection our MySQL
server we have our password our username
the table going where it's going to I
mean the table where it's coming from uh
and then we can add a Target on here we
can put in uh Target Dash directory and
you do have to put the full path that's
a aoop thing it's a good practice to be
in and we're going to add it to
Department uh what to Department one and
so here we now add a Target directory in
here and user Cloud era Department 1 and
this will take just a moment before so
I'll go ahead and skip over the process
since it's going to run very slowly it's
only running on like I said a couple
cores and it's also on a single node and
now we can do the uh Hadoop let's just
do the up Arrow file system list we want
just straight list and when we do the
Hadoop file system uh minus LS or list
you'll see that we now have Department
one and we can of course do uh list
Department one and you can see we have
the files inside Department one and they
mirrored what we saw before with the
same files in there the part mm o 0000
and so on if we want to look at them
it'd be the same thing we did before
with the cat so except instead of
departments uh we'd be Department one
there we go and then that's going to
come up with the same data we had before
now one of the important things when
you're importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think had doop Big Data
put it all in there I know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn uh a couple hundred terabytes
into a petabyte very rapidly and
suddenly you're having to really add on
to that data store and you're storing
duplicate data sometimes so you really
need to be able to filter your data out
and so let's go ahead and use our up
Arrow to go to our last import uh since
it's still a lot the same stuff uh so we
have all of our commands under import we
have the target uh we're going to change
this to Department two so we're going to
create a new directory for this one and
then after Department uh there's another
command that we didn't really slide in
here and that's our mapping and I'll
show you what this looks like in a
minute we're going to put M3 in there
that doesn't have nothing to do with the
filtering I'll show you that in a second
though what that's for and we just want
to put in where uh so where and what is
the we in this case we want to know
where Department ID and if you want to
know where that came from we can flip
back on over here we have Department
uncore IDs this is where that's coming
from that's just the name of the column
on here so so we come in here to
Department ID is greater than four
simple um logic there you can see where
you'd use that for maybe creating
buckets for ages uh you know age from 10
to 15 20 to 30 you might be looking for
I mean there's all kinds of reasons why
you you could use the wear command on
here and filter information out maybe
you're doing word counting and you want
to know words that are used less than a
100 times you want to get rid of the'
and is and and and uh all the stuff
that's used over and over again uh so
we'll go ahead and put the where and
then Department ID is greater than four
we'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
this will create our department 2 setup
on this uh and I'll go ahead and skip
over some of the runtime again it runs
really slow on a single node uh real
quick page through our commands uh let's
see here we go our list and we should
see underneath the list the department 2
on here now and there it is Department 2
uh and then I can go ahead and do list
Department 2 you'll see the contents in
here uh and you'll see that there is
only three maps and it could be that the
data created three Maps but remember I
set it up to only use three mappers uh
so there's 0o one and two and we can go
ahead and do a cat on there remember
this is Department 2 so we want to look
at all the contents of these three
different files and there it is it's
greater than four so we have golf is
five outdoor six uh fan shop is seven uh
so we we've effectively filtered out our
data and just storing the data we want
on our file system so if you're going to
store data on here the next stage is to
export the data uh remember a lot of
times you have MySQL server and we're
continually dumping that data into our
long-term storage and access the Hadoop
file system uh but what happens when you
need to pull that data out and uh
restore a database or uh maybe you have
um you just merged with a new company a
favorite topic merging companies and
merging databases that's listed under
Nightmare and how many different names
for company can you have so you can see
where uh being able to export is also
equally important and let's go ahead and
do that and I'm going to flip back over
to my SQL Server here and we'll need to
go ahead and create our database we're
going to export into now I'm not going
to go too much in detail on this command
we're simply creating a table and the
table's going to have um it's pretty
much the same table we already have in
here from departments but in this case
we're going to going to create a table
called
d uh so it's the same setup but it's
it's just going to we're just giving it
a different name a different schema and
so we've done that and we'll go ahead
and do a select star from
D there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new databas a new data table
and it's empty in there uh so now we
need to go ahead and Export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our Linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our Command here's scoop Import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export and the connection is going
to remain the same so same connect same
uh database we're also we're still doing
the retail DB uh we have the same
password so none of that changes uh the
big change here is going to be the table
instead of departments uh remember we
changed it and gave it a new name and so
we want to change it here also D so
Department we're not going to worry
about the mapper count and the wear was
part of our import there we go and then
finally it needs to know where to export
from so instead of Target directory we
have an export directory that's where
it's coming from uh still user Cloud era
and we'll keep it as Department 2 uh
just so you can see how that data is
coming back with the that we filtered in
and let's go ahead and run this it'll
take it just a moment to go through its
steps and again because it's slow I'm
just going to go and skip this so you
don't have to sit through it and once
we've wrapped up our export we'll flip
back on over here to mySQL use the up
arrow and this time we're going to
select star from department and we can
see that there it is it exported the
golf outdoors and fan shop uh and you
can imagine also that you might have to
use the wear command in your export also
so there's a lot of mixing the command
line for scoop is pretty straightforward
uh you're changing the different
variables in there whether you're
creating a table listing a table listing
databases very powerful tool for
bringing your data into the Hadoop file
system and exporting it so now that
we've wrapped up our demo on scoop and
gone through a lot of basic commands now
Flume is a distributed service for
collecting aggregating and moving large
amounts of log data so kind of focused a
little bit on a slightly different set
of data although you'll find these
overlap a lot you can certainly use
Flume to do a lot of things that you can
do in scoop and vice versa Flume ingests
the data so we're looking at like say
adjacent call to a website XML documents
um unstructured and semi-structured data
most commonly digested by Flume best
example I saw was a Twitter account
pulling Twitter feeds into a Hadoop
system so it injest online streaming
data from social media Twitter log files
so we want to know what's going on with
error codes on your servers and all
those log files web server what's going
on in your web server we can bring all
this stuff in and just dump it into the
Hadoop data file system to be looked at
and process later and it's a web server
cloud social media data again all those
different sources it can be it's kind of
endless you know it just depends on what
your company needs versatility of Hadoop
is what makes it such a powerful source
to add into a company and so it comes in
there you have your Source it goes
through the channels it then goes
through kind of a sync feature to makees
sure everything is in sync and then it
dumps it into the Hadoop file system so
we've covered in the Hadoop file system
the first two things let's look at some
of the scripting languages they have and
so we have the two here and you can also
think of these um it actually says
scripting and SQL queries a lot of times
they're both referred to as queries so
you have both the Pig and the hive so
the history of Hive begins with Facebook
Facebook begin using Hadoop as a
solution to handle the growing big data
and we're not talking about a data that
fits on one or two or even five
computers uh we're talking data that
fits on if you've looked at any of our
other Hood dup tutorials you'll know
we're talking about very big data and
data pools and Facebook Facebook
certainly has a lot of data it tracks as
we know the Hadoop uses map reduce for
processing data map reduce required
users to write long codes and so you'd
have these really extensive Java codes
very complicated for the average person
to use not all users reversed in Java
and other coding languages this proved
to be a disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in SQL
SQL has been around for a long time the
standard uh SQL query language Hive was
developed with the vision to incorporate
the concepts of tables columns just like
SQL so why hiive well the problem was
for processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well versed with the coding
languages you have your processing you
have your analyzing and so the solution
was uh required a language similar to
SQL which was well known to all the
users and thus the hive or hql language
evolved what is Hive Hive is a data
warehouse system which is used for
quering and analyzing large data sets
stored in the hdfs or the Hadoop file
system Hive uses a query language that
we call hiveql or hql which is similar
to SQL so if we take our user the user
sends out their hive queries and then
that is converted into a map reduce
tasks and then accesses the Hadoop map
reduce system let's take a look at the
architecture of Hive architecture of
Hive we have the hive client uh so that
could be the programmer or maybe it's
the manager who knows enough SQL to do a
basic query to look up the data they
need the hive client supports different
types of client applications and
different languages perer for performing
queries and so we have our Thrift
application and the hive Thrift client
Thrift is a software framework Hive
server is based on Thrift so it can
serve the requests from all programming
language that support Thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc Java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python C++ spark uh Java you
can find just about any connection in
any of the main scripting languages and
so we have our high Services as we look
at deeper into the architecture Hive
supports various Services uh so you have
your Hive server basically your Thrift
application or your hive Thrift client
or your jdbc or your hive jdbc driver
your odbc application or your hive obbc
driver they all Connect into The Hive
server and you have your hive web
interface you also have your CLI now the
hive web interface is a guy is provided
to execute Hive queries and we'll
actually be using that later on today so
you can see kind of what that looks like
and get a feel for what that means
commands are executed directly in CLI
and then the CLI is a direct terminal
window uh and I'll also show you that
too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver Hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver The Hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler Hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimized logical plan in the form
of a graph of map reduce and hdfs tasks
is obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed when we look at the
architecture we also have to note the
metastore metastore is a repository for
Hive metadata stores metadata for Hive
tables and you can think of this as your
schema and where is it located and it's
stored on the Apache Derby DB processing
and resource management is all handled
by the map reduce V1 you'll see map
reduce V2 the yarn and the tez these are
all different ways of managing these
resources depending on what version of
Hadoop you're in Hive uses map reduced
framework to process queries and then we
have our distributed storage which is
the hdfs and if you looked at our Hadoop
uh tutorials you'll know that these are
on commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about Big Data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on Enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow And Hive uh so in our
data flow And Hive we have our Hive in
the Hadoop system and underneath the
user interface or the UI we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our meta store that all goes into
the map reduce and the Hado file system
so when we execute a query you see it
coming in here it goes into the driver
step one step two we get a plan what are
we going to do refers to the query
execution uh then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it uh
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the send
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between Hive and H doop
to process the query and that's going
into your map reduce and your hop file
system or your HD fs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metast store to
update or let it know what's going on
which also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the metast store execution
engine Communications is bidirectionally
with the metastore to perform operations
like create drop tables metastore stores
information about tables and columns so
again we're talking about the schema of
your database and once we have that we
have a by Direct directional send
results communication back into the
driver and then we have the fetch
results which goes back to the client so
let's take a little bit look at the hive
data modeling Hive data modeling so you
have your hive data modeling you have
your tables you have your partitions and
you have buckets the tables in Hive are
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional SQL server or my SQL Server
where you might have Enterprise
equipment and a lot of uh people pulling
and moving stuff off of there the tables
are going to look very similar and this
makes it very easy to take that
information and let's say you need to
keep current information but you need to
store all of your years of transactions
back into the Hadoop Hive so you you
match those those all kind of look the
same the tables are the same your
databases look very similar and you can
easily import them back you can easily
store them into the hive system
partitions here tables are organized
into partitions for grouping same type
of data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employes are
concerned and finally we have buckets uh
data present in partitions can be
further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency uh at this level a lot of
times you're T you're working with the
programmer in the admin of your Hado
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
Hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources Hive data
types so we're talking about Hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types A lot of this
will look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in SQL in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and M miscellaneous data type and
these should be very they're kind of
self-explanatory but just in case uh
numerical data is your floats your
integers your short integers all of that
numerical data comes in as a number a
string of course is characters and
numbers and then you have your date time
stamp and then we have kind of a general
way of pulling your own created data
types in there that's your miscellaneous
data type and we have complex data types
so you can store arrays you can store
maps you can store structures uh and
even units in there as we dig into Hive
data types uh and we have the primitive
data types and the complex data types so
we look at primitive data types and
we're looking at numeric data types data
types like an integer a float a decimal
those are all stored as numbers in the
hive data system a string data type data
types like characters and strings you
store the name of the person you're
working with uh you know John Doe the
city uh Memphis the state Tennessee
maybe it's uh Boulder Colorado USA or
maybe it's hyperbad uh India um that's
all going to be string and stored as a
string character and of course we have
our date time data type data types like
timestamp date interval those are very
common as far as tracking sales anything
like that so you just think if you can
type a stamp of time on it or maybe
you're dealing with a race and you want
to know the interval how long did the
person take to complete whatever task it
was all that is datetime data type and
then we talk miscellaneous data typee
these are like Boolean and binary and
when you get into Boolean and binary you
can actually almost create anything in
there but your yes NOS 01 now let's take
a look at complex data types a little
closer uh we have arrays so your syntax
is of data type and it's an array and
you can just think of an array as a
collection of same um entities one two
three four if they're all numbers and
you have Maps this is a collection of
key value pairs uh so understanding Maps
is so Central to Hadoop uh so when we
store Maps you have a key which is a set
you can only have one key per mapped
value and so you in Hado of course you
collect uh the same keys and you can add
them all up or do something with all the
contents of the same key but this is our
map as a primitive type data type and
our collection of key value Pairs and
then collection of complex data with
comment so we can have a structure we
have like column name data type comment
col column comment uh so you can get
very complicated structures in here with
your collection of data and your
commented setup and then we have units
and this is a collection of
heterogeneous data types uh so the
Syntax for this is Union type data type
data type and so on so it's all going to
be the same a little bit different than
the arrays where you can actually mix
and match different modes of Hive Hive
operates in two modes depending on the
number and size of data nodes we have
our local mode and our map reduce mode
when we talk about the local mode it is
used when Hadoop is having one data node
and the data is small processing will be
very fast on a smaller data sets which
are present in local machine and this
might be that you're have a a local file
of stuff you're uploading into the hive
and you need to do some processes in
there you can go ahead and run those
Hive processes and queries on it usually
you don't see much in the way of a
single node a dup system if you're going
to do that you might as well just use
like an SQL database or um even a Java
SQ light or something python is SQ light
so you don't really see a lot of single
node Hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in Hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when Hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large data sets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers uh we're
usually talking with the Hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers
15 100 where this data is spread across
all those different Hadoop nodes
difference between Hive and
rdbms and remember rdbms stands for the
relational database management system
let's take a look at the difference
between Hive and the rdbms with Hive
Hive enforces schema on read and it's
very important that whatever is coming
in that's when hive's looking at it and
making sure that it fits the model um
the rdbms enforces a schema when it
actually writes the data into the
database so it's read the data and then
once it starts to write it that's where
it's going to give you the error or tell
you something's incorrect about your
scheme High data size is in pedabytes
that is hard to imagine um you know when
we're looking at your personal computer
on your desk maybe you have 10 terabytes
if it's a high-end computer but we're
talking pedabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when rdbms
data size is in terabytes very rarely do
you see an rdbms system that's spread
over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has um a high-end
amount of rights to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there you're
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rdbm
Master you're going to run into a lot of
problems with Hive you can take it as
big as you want Hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important uh they call it
worm which is write w wants o read R
many times M they refer to it as worm
and that's true of any of a lot of your
Hadoop setup it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rdbms from years and
years and years of business or whatever
your company does or scientific research
and putting that into a huge data pool
so that you can now do queries on it and
get that information out of it with the
rdbms it's based on the notion of read
and write many times uh so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales the account changes because
they have a different licensing now
whatever software you're selling all
that kind of stuff where the data is
continually fluctuating and then Hive
resembles a traditional database by
supporting SQL but it is not a database
it is a data warehouse this is very
important and it goes with all the other
stuff we've talked about that we're not
looking at a database but a data
warehouse to store the data and still
have fast and easy access to it for
doing queries um you can think of um
Twitter and Facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically um those posts aren't going
to change they made the post they're
posted they're there and they're in
their database but they have to store it
in a warehouse in case they want to pull
it back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with Hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe
$1,000 per terabyte um the rdb m s is
not scalable at a low cost when you
first start on the lower end you're
talking about 10,000 per terabyte of
data including all the backup on the
models and and all the added Necessities
to support it as you scale it up you
have to scale those computers and
Hardware up uh so you might start off
with a basic server and then you upgrade
to a sun computer to run it uh and you
spend you know tens of thousands of
dollars for that Hardware upgrade with
Hive you just put another computer into
your hadu file system so let's look at
some of the features of Hive uh when
we're looking at the features of Hive
we're talking about the use of SQL like
language called hiveql a lot of times
you'll see that as hql which is easier
than long codes this is nice if you're
working with your shareholders you come
to them and you say Hey you can do a
basic SQL query on here and pull up the
information you need this way you don't
have to take all have your programmers
jump in every time they want to look up
something in the database they actually
now can easily do that if they're not uh
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to The rdbms hence easier to
understand and um one of the things I
like about this is when I'm bringing
tables in from a MySQL server or SQL
Server there's almost a direct
reflection between the two so when
you're looking at one which is a data
which is canly changing and then you're
going into the archive database it's not
this huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language uh you mirror that
same schema into the hdfs into the hive
U making it very easy to go between the
two and then using hi ql multiple users
can simultaneously query data uh so
again you can have multiple clients in
there and they send in their query
that's also true with the rdbms which
kind of cues them up because it's
running so fast you don't notice the um
lag time well you get that also with the
hql as you add more computers in the
query can go very quickly depending on
how many computers and how much um
resources each machine has to pull the
information and Hive supports a variety
of data types uh so with Hive it's
designed to be on the Hadoop system
which you can put almost anything into
the Hadoop file system so with all that
let's take a look at a demo on hiveql or
hql before I dive into the Hands-On demo
let's take a look at the website hive.
apache.org that's the main website uh
since Apache it's an Apache open source
uh software this is the main software or
the main site for the build and if you
go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating Hive into to beehive
and so if you see beehive versus Hive uh
note The Beehive is a new releas is
coming out that's all it is and it
reflects a lot of the same functionality
of Hive it's the same thing and then we
like to pull up some kind of um
documentation on commands and for this
I'm actually going to go to Horton Works
Hive cheat sheet and that's because
Horton works and Cloud are two of the
most common used builds for Hadoop and
for which include Hive and all the
different Tools in there and and so
Horton Works has a pretty good PDF you
can download cheat sheet on there I
believe Cloudera does too but we'll go
ahead and just look at the Horton one
because it's the one that comes up
really good and you can see when we look
at the query language it Compares MySQL
server to hiveql or hql and you can see
the basic select we select from columns
uh from table where conditions exist you
know most basic uh command on there and
they have different things you can do
with it just like you do with your um
SQL and if you scroll down you'll see um
data type ypes so here's your integer
your float your binary double string Tim
stamp and all the different data types
you can use some different semantics
different Keys features functions uh for
running a hive query command line setup
and of course the hive shell uh setup in
here uh so you can see right here if we
Loop through it it has a lot of your
basic stuff and we're basically looking
at SQL across a Horton database we're
going to go ahead and run our Hadoop
cluster Hive uh demo and I'm going to go
ahead and use a Cloudera quick start
this is in the virtual box so again we
have an oracle virtual box which is open
source and then we have our Cloudera
quick start which is the Hadoop setup on
a single node now obviously Hadoop And
Hive are designed to run across a
cluster of computers so we talk about a
single node is for Education testing
that kind of thing and if you have a
chance you can always go back and look
at our demo we had on um setting up a
had doop system in a single cluster just
set a note Down Below in the YouTube
video and our team will get in contact
with you and send you that link if you
don't already have it or you can contact
us at the www.s simply learn.com now in
here it's always important to note that
you do need um on your computer if
you're running on Windows because I'm on
a Windows machine you're going to need
probably about 12 gigabytes to actually
run this uh it used to be get by with a
lot less but as things have evolved they
take up more and more resources and you
need the professional version if you
have the home version I was able to get
that to run but boy it did take a lot of
extra work to get the home version to
let me use the virtual setup on there
and we'll simply click on the cloud era
quick start and I'm going to go and just
start that up and this is starting up
our Linux so we have our Windows 10
which is a computer I'm on and then I
have the virtual box which is going to
have a Linux operating system in it and
we'll skip ahead so you don't have to
watch the whole install something
interesting to know about the cloud era
is that it's running on Linux Centos and
for whatever reason I've always had to
click on it and hit the escape button
for it to spin up and then you'll see
the Doss come in here now that our Cloud
Dera is spun up on our virtual machine
with the Linux on uh we can see here we
have our it uses the Thunderbird browser
on here by default and automatically
opens up a number of different tabs for
us and a quick note cuz I mentioned like
the restrictions on getting set up on
your own computer if you have a home
edition computer and you're worried
about setting it up on there you can
also go in there and spin up a one month
free service on Amazon web service to
play with this uh so there's other
options you're not stuck with just doing
it on the quick start menu you can spin
this up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to not is that we've come
in here into Cloud era and I'm going to
access this in two ways uh the first one
is we're going to use Hue and I'm going
to open up Hue and it'll take it a
moment to load from um the setup on here
and Hue is nice if I go in and use Hue
as an editor into Hive or into the
Hadoop setup usually I'm doing it as a
um from an admin side because it has a
lot more information a lot of visuals
less to do with you know actually diving
in there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
other ways you can upload it into Hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
Hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window Under
The Hive shell now in the Hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see Hive there
we go there's our Hive set up I go and
click on hive and this will open it up
our query down here and now it has a
nice little B that shows our Hive going
and we can go something very simple down
here like show databases and we follow
it with the semicolon and that's the
standard in Hive is you always add our
uh punctuation at the end there and I'll
go ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start I
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name I haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like uh
assistant function tables um your
databases up here there's all kinds of
things you can research you can look at
through Hue as far as a bigger picture
the downside of this is it always seems
to lag for me whenever I'm doing this I
always seem to run slow so if you're in
Cloud Dera you can open up a terminal
window they actually have an icon at the
top you can also go under applications
and under applications system tools and
terminal either one will work it's just
a regular terminal window and this
terminal window is now running
underneath our Linux so this is a Linux
terminal window or on our virtual
machine which is resting on our regular
Windows 10 machine and we'll go ahead
and zoom this in so you can see the text
better on your own video and I simply
just clicked on view and zoom in and
then all we have to do is type in Hive
and this will open up the shell on here
and it takes it just a moment to load
when starting up high I also want to
note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on in your action
you might have to do pseudo hiive and
put in your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the Linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple uh hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go and create a dat
database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if I do
show we'll just do the up Arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both Linux and
in Hive so I can go back and paste
through all the commands I've typed in
and we can see now that I have my
there's the course the default database
and then there's the office database so
now we've created a database it's pretty
quick and easy and we can go ahead and
drop the database we can do drop
Database Office now this will work on
this database because it's empty if if
your database was not empty you would
have to do Cascade and that drops all
the tables in the database and the
database itself now if we do show
database and we'll go ahead and recreate
our database because we're going to use
the office database for the rest of this
um Hands-On demo a really handy command
to Now set with the SQL or hql is to use
office and what that does is that sets
office as a default database so instead
of having to reference the database
every time we work with a table it now
automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is is
you put the database name period table
and I'll show you in just a minute what
that looks like and how that's different
if we're going to have a table in a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have Hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
and just do a list which is of course a
Linux command you can see all the files
I have in here this is the default load
we can change directory to documents we
can list in documents and we're actually
going to be looking at employee. CSV a
Linux command is the cat you can use
this actually to combine documents
there's all kinds of things that cat
does but if we want to just display the
um contents of our employee. CSV file we
can simply do cat employee CSV and when
we're looking at this we want to know a
couple things one there's a line at the
top okay so the very first thing we
notice is that we have a header line the
next thing we notice is that the data is
comma separated and in this particular
case you'll see a space here generally
with these you got to be real careful
with spaces there's all kinds of things
you got to watch out for because they
can cause issues these spaces won't
because these are all strings that the
space is connected to if this was a
space next to the integer you would get
a null value that comes into the
database without doing something extra
in there now with most of Hadoop that's
important to know that you're writing
the data once reading it many times and
that's true of almost all your Hadoop
things coming in so you really want to
process the data before it gets into the
database and for those who of you have
studied uh data transformation that's
the etal where you extract transfer form
and then load the data so you really
want to extract and transform before
putting it into the hive then you load
it into the hive with the transform data
and of course we also want to note the
schema we have an integer string string
integer integer uh so we kept it pretty
simple in here as far as the way the
data is set up the last thing that
you're going to want to look up uh when
is the source uh since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
homecloud era documents and these are
just text documents we're working with
right now we're not doing anything fancy
so we can do a simple get edit employee.
CSV and you'll see it comes up here it's
just a text document so I can easily
remove these added spaces there we go um
and then we go and just save it and so
now it has the new setup in there we've
edited it the gedit is usually one of
the default that loads into Linux um so
any text editor will do back to the hive
shell so let's go ahead and create a
table employeee and what I want you to
note here is I did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where I have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so I
can do all of my commands at once now
just so I don't have any typo errors I
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had uh the different
values in here which was ID name
Department year of joining and salary
and the ID is an integer name is a
string department string you're joining
integer salary an
and they're in Brackets we put closed
black brackets around them and you could
do this all as one line and then we have
row format delimitated Fields terminated
by comma and this is important because
the default is tabs so if I do it now it
won't find any terminated Fields so
you'll get a bunch of null values loaded
into your table and then finally our
table properties we want to skip the
header line count equals 1 now this is a
lot of work for uploading a single file
it's kind of goofy when you're uploading
a single file that you have to put all
this in here but keep in mind Hive and
Hadoop is designed for writing many
files into the database you write them
all in there and then you can they're
saved it's an archive it's a data
warehouse and then you're able to do all
your queries on them so a lot of times
we're not looking at just the one file
coming up we're loading hundreds of
files you have your reports coming off
of your main database all those reports
are being loaded you have your log files
you have I mean all this different data
is being dumped into Hadoop and in this
case Hive on top of Hadoop and so we
need to let it know hey how do I handle
these files coming in and then we have
the semicolon at the end which lets us
know to go ahead and run this line and
so we'll go ahead and run that and now
if we do a show tables uh you can see
there's our employee on there we can
also describe if we do describe employee
uh you can see that we have our ID
integer name string department string
year of uh joining integer and salary
integer and then finally let's just do a
select star from employee very basic um
SQL and hql command uh selecting data
and it's going to come up and we haven't
put anything in it so as we expect
there's no data in it so if we flip back
to our um Linux terminal window you can
see where we did the cat employee. CSV
and you can see all the data we expect
to come into it and we also did our PWD
and right here you see the path you need
that full path when you are U loading
data you know you can do a browse and if
I did it right now would just the
employee. CSV as a name it will work but
that is a really bad habit in general
when you're loading data because it's uh
you don't know what else is going on in
the computer you want to do the full
path almost in all your data loads so
let's go ahead and flip back over here
to our Hive shell we're working in and
the command for this is load data uh so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
I'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
and it we just paste the full path in
there which I have um stored over on the
side like a good prepared um demo and
you'll see here we have home clera
documents employee. CSV so it's a whole
path for this text document in here and
we go ahead and hit enter in there and
then we have to let it know where the
data is going so now we have a source
and we need a destination and it's going
to go into the table and we'll just call
it employee we'll just match the table
in there and because I want it to
execute we put the my colon on the end
it goes ahead and executes all three
lines now if we go back if you remember
we did the select star from employee
just using the up aror to page through
my different um commands I've already
typed in you can see right here we have
uh as we expect we have Rose Sam Mike
and Nick and we have all their
information showing in our four rows and
then let's go ahead and do uh select and
count just look at a couple of these
different select options you can do
we're going to count everything from
employe
now this is kind of interesting cuz the
first one just pops up with a basic uh
select because it doesn't need to go
through the full map reduce phase but
when you start doing a count it does go
through the full map reduce setup in the
hive and Hadoop and because I'm doing
this demo on a single node Cloud era
virtual box on top of a Windows 10 all
the benefits of running it on a cluster
are gone and instead is now going
through all those added layers so it
takes long to run you know like I said
uh when you do a single node as I said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running out on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from U our cheat sheet
which we brought up here from Horton
it's a pretty good one there's all these
different commands we can do we'll look
at one more command where we do the U uh
what they call subqueries right down
here uh cuz that's really common to do
do a lot of subqueries and so we'll do
select uh star or all different columns
from employee now if we weren't using
the office database it would look like
this from office. employee and either
one will work on this particular one
because um we have office set as a
default on there uh so from office
employee and then the command where
creates a subset and in this case we
want to know where the salary is greater
than 25 ,000 there we go and of course
we end with our semicolon and if we run
this query you can see it pops up and
there's our salaries of people top
earners uh we have row and it and mic
and HR uh kudos to them of course
they're fictitional I don't actually we
don't actually have a row and a mic in
those positions or maybe we do so
finally we want to go ahead and do is
we're done with this um table now
remember you're dealing with the data
warehouse so you usually don't do a lot
of dropping of tables and databases but
we're going to go ahead and drop this
table here before we drop it one more
quick note is we can change it so what
we're going to do is we're going to
alter table office employee and we want
to go ahead and rename it there's some
other commands you can do in here but
rename is pretty common and we're going
to rename it to and it's going to stay
in office and uh turns out one of our sh
shareholders really doesn't like the
word employee he wants employees plural
it's a big deal to him so let's go ahead
and change that name for the table it's
that easy cuz it's just changing the
metad data on there and now if we do
show tables you'll see we now have
employees not employee uh and then at
this point maybe we're doing some house
cleaning because this is all practice so
we're going to go ahead and drop table
and we'll drop table employees because
we change the name in there so if we did
employee it just give us an error and
now if we do show tables you'll see all
the tables are gone now the next thing
we want to go and take a look at and
we're going to walk back through the
loading of data uh just real quick cuz
we're going to load two tables in here
here and let me just float back to our
terminal window so we can see what those
tables are that we're loading and so up
here we have customer we have a customer
um file and we have an order file we
want to go ahead and put the customers
and the orders into here so those are
the two we're doing and of course it's
always nice to see what you're working
with uh so let's do our cat customer.
CSV we could always do gedit but we
don't really need to edit these we just
want to take a look at the data in
customer and important in here is again
we have a header so we have to skip a
line comma separated uh nothing odd with
the data we have our schema which is um
integer string integer string integer so
you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat order. CSV and we can see we
have o ID which I'm guessing is the
order ID we have a date oh something new
we've done integers and strings but we
haven't done date when you're importing
new and you never worked with the date
date's always one of the more trickier
fields to port in and that's true of
just about any scripting language I've
worked with all of them have their own
idea of how date's supposed to be
formatted what the default is this
particular format where it's year and it
has all four uh digits Dash month two
digits Das day is the standard import
for the hive so you'll have to look up
and see what the different formats are
if you're going to do a different format
in there coming in or you're not able to
pre-process the data but this would be a
pre-processing the data thing coming in
if you remember correctly from uh our
edel which is uh e just in case you
weren't able to hear me last time ETL
which stands for extract transform then
load so you want to make sure you're
transforming this data before it gets
into here and so we're going to go ahead
and bring um both this data in here and
really we're doing this so we can show
you the basic join there is if you
remember from our setup merge join all
kinds of different things you can do but
joining different data sets is so common
so it's really important to know how to
do that so we need to go ahead and bring
in these two data sets and you can see
where I just created a table customer
here's our schema the integer name age
address salary here's our eliminated by
commas and our table properties where we
skip a line well let's go ahead and load
the data first and then we'll do that
with our order and let's go ahead and
put that in here and I've got it split
into three lines so you can see it
easily we got load data local in path so
we know we're loading data we know it's
local and we have the path here's the
complete path for uh oops this is
supposed to be order CSV grab the wrong
one uh of course it's going to give me
errors because you can't recreate the
same table on there and here we go
create table here's our um integer date
customer the basic setup that we had
coming in here for our schema row format
commas table properties skip header line
and then finally let's load the data
into our order table load data local in
path home Cloud ER documents order. CSV
into table order now if we we did
everything right we should be able to do
select star from customer and you can
see we have all seven customers and then
we can do select star from order and we
have uh four orders uh so this is just
like a quick frame we have you know a
lot of times when you have your customer
databases in business you have thousands
of customers from years and years and
some of them you know they move they
close their business they change names
all kinds of things happen uh so what we
want to do is we want to go ahead and
find just the information connected to
these orders and who's connected to them
and so let's go ahead and do it's a
select because we're going to display uh
information so select and this is kind
of interesting we're going to do
c.id um and I'm going to Define c as
customer as a customer table in just a
minute then we're going to do C.N name
and again we're going to define the c c.
AG so this means from the customer we
want to know their ID their name their
age and then you know I'd also like to
know the order amount uh uh so let's do
o for do amount and then this is where
we need to go ahead and Define uh what
we're doing and I'll go and capitalize
from customer so we're going to take the
customer table in here and we're going
to name it C that's where the C comes
from so that's a customer table C and we
want to join order as o that's where our
o comes from so the o. amount is what
we're joining in there and then we want
to do this on we got to tell it how to
connect the two tables c.id equals o. C
customer uncore ID so now we know how
they're joined and now remember we have
seven customers in here we have four
orders and as it processes we should get
a return of four different names joined
together and they're joined based on of
course the orders on there and once
we're done we now have the order number
the person who made the order their age
and the amount of the order which came
from the order table uh so you have your
your different information and you can
see how the join works here very common
use of tables and hql and SQL and let's
do one more thing with our database and
then I'll show you a couple other Hive
commands and let's go ahead and do a
drop and we're going to drop Database
Office and if you're looking at this and
you uh remember from earlier this will
give me an error and let's just see what
that looks like it says fail to execute
exception one or more tables exist so if
you remember from before you can't just
drop a database unless you tell it to
Cascade that lets it know I don't care
how many tables are in it let's get rid
of it and in Hado since it's an an art
it's a warehouse a data warehouse you
usually don't do a lot of dropping uh
maybe at the beginning when you're
developing the schemas and you realize
you messed up you might drop some stuff
uh but down the road you're really just
adding commodity machines to take up so
you can store more stuff on it so you
usually don't do a lot of database
dropping and some other uh fun commands
to know is you can do um select round
2.3 as round value you can do a roundoff
in uh Hive uh we can do as floor value
which is going to give us a two so it
turns it into an integer versus a float
it goes down you know basically
truncates it uh but it goes down and we
can also do ceiling which is going to
round it up so we're looking for the
next integer above there's a few
commands we didn't show in here because
we're on a single node as as an admin to
help spedate the process you usually add
in partitions for the data and buckets
um you can't do that on a single node
because the when you add a partition it
partitions it across separate nodes but
beyond that you can see that it's very
straightforward we have SQL coming in uh
and all your basic queries that are in
SQL are very similar to hql what exactly
is pig pig is a scripting platform that
runs on Hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses SQL like
queries they're definitely not SQL but
some of them resemble SQL queries and
then we use that to analyze our data Pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at map reduce versus Hive versus
pig so we start with a compiled language
your map reduce and we have Hive which
is your SQL like query and then we have
pig which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to SQL but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember SQL like
query which is what Hive is based off
looks for structured data and so when we
get into scripting languages like Pig
now we're dealing more with
semi-structured and even unstructured
data with a Hadoop map reduce we have a
need to write long complex codes with
Hive no need to write complex codes you
could just put it in a simple SQL query
or hql hiveql and in pig no need to
write complex codes as we have pig latin
now remember in the map reduce it can
produce structured semi-structured and
unstructured data and as I mentioned
before Hive can process only structured
data think rows and columns where Pig
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and colums
semi-structured as your HTML XML
documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format Twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our Hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
Hive and pig we have a higher level of
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
Hive or Pig this is the advantage Pig
has over Hive it can process uh only
structured data in Hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to note that separates the uh
different query languages is when we
look at map and reduce map reduce
supports partitioning features as does
Hive Pig no concept of partitioning in
pigs it doesn't support your
partitioning feature your partitioning
features allow you to partition the data
in such a way that it can be queried
quicker you're not able to do that in
pig map reduce uses Java and python
while Hive uses an SQL like query
language known as hiveql or hql Pig
Latin is used which is a procedural data
flow language map reduce is used by
programmers pretty much as
straightforward on Java Hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers has
been known to go in and use a hive for
quick query and anybody's been able to
use Pig for a quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under Hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce and pig
under Pig Code performance is lesser
than map reduce but better than Hive so
if we're going to look at uh speed and
time the map reduce is is going to have
be the fastest performance on all of
those where Pig will have second and
high follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig Latin Pig Latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using Pig laddin it is
similar to SQL and then we have the
runtime engine runtime engine represents
the execution environment created to run
Pig Latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces map reduced programs uses
hdfs or her dup file system for storing
and retrieving data and as we dig deeper
into the pig architecture we'll see that
we have pig latin scripts programmers
write a script in pig Laden to analyze
data using Pig then you have the grunt
shell and it actually says grunt when we
start it up and we'll show you that here
in a little bit which goes into the pig
server and this is where we have our
parser parser checks the syntax of the
pig script after checking the output
will be a dag directed a celic graph and
then we have an Optimizer which
optimizes um after your dag your logical
plan is passed to The Logical Optimizer
where an optimization takes place
finally the compiler converts the dag
into map reduce jobs and then that is
executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that um they kind
of end you always want to execute
everything once you've created it and so
dump is kind of our execution U
statement and you can see right here as
we were talking about earlier once we
get to the execution and it's coded into
map reduce then the map reduce processes
it onto the
hdfs working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users so you have load
data and WR Pig script and pig
operations so when we look at the
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users there's step one we
load data and write Pig script and step
two in this step all the pig operations
are performed by parser Optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and and then we get to step
three execution of the plan in this
stage the results are shown on the
screen otherwise stored in the hdfs as
per the code so it might be of a small
amount of data you're reducing it to and
you want to put that on the screen or
you might uh be converting a huge amount
of data which you want to put back into
the Hadoop file system for other use
let's take a look at the pig latin data
model the data model of pig latin helps
pig to handle various types of data for
example we have Adam Rob or 50 adom
represents any single value of primitive
data type in pig latin like integer
float string it is stored as a string
tupal so we go from our atom which our
most basic things so if you look at just
Rob or just 50 that's an atom that's our
most basic object we have in pig latin
then you have a tupal tupal represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
Rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've USS you
might have uh the ID number the name
where they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tupal and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tupal it is the same as a table in rdbms
and is represented by brackets and you
can see here we have our table with Rob
five Mike 10 and we also have a map a
map is a set of key value pairs key is
of character array type and a value can
be of any type type it is represented by
the brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is Mike and 10 Pig
Latin has a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an ID number a name an age and
a place and we break this apart we look
at this model from Pig Latin perspective
uh we start with our field and if you
can remember a field contains basically
an atom it is one H particular data type
and the atom is stored as a string which
it then converts it into either an
integer number or character string next
we have our tupal and in this case you
can see that it represents a row so our
tupal would be three comma Joe comma 29
comma California and finally we have our
bag which contains three rows in it in
this particular example let's take a
quick look at Pig execution modes Pig
Works in two execution modes depending
on where the data is recited and where
the pig script is going to run we have
local mode here the pig engine takes
input from the Linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mode local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using Pig and
we have the map reduce mode here the pig
engine directly interacts and executes
in hdfs and map reduce in the map reduce
mode queries written in pig latin are
translated into map reduced jobs and are
run on a Hadoop cluster by default Pig
runs in this mode there are three modes
in pig depending on how a pig latin code
can be written we have our interactive
mode batch mode and embedded mode the
interactive mode means coding and
executing the script line by line when
we do our example we'll be in the
interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension. Pig and the file is directly
executed and then there's embedded mode
Pig lets its users Define their own
functions udf's in a programming
language such as Java so let's take a
look and see how this works Works in a
use case in this case use case Twitter
users on Twitter generate about 500
million tweets on a daily basis the
Hadoop map reduce was used to process
and analyze this data analyzing the
number of tweets created by a user in
the Tweet table was done using map
reduce and Java programming language and
you can see the problem it was difficult
to perform map reduce operations as
users were not well-versed with written
complex Java codes so Twitter used
Apache pig to overcome these problems
and let's see how let's start with the
problem statement analyze the user table
and tweet table and find out how many
tweets are created by a person and here
you can see we have a user table we have
Alice Tim and John with their ID numbers
one two three and we have a tweet table
in the Tweet table you have your um the
ID of the user and then what they
tweeted uh Google was a good whatever it
was tennis dot do spacecraft Olympics
politics whatever they're tweeting about
the following operations were performed
for analyze the given data first the
Twitter data is loaded into the pig
storage using load command and you can
see here we have our data coming in and
then that's going into Pig storage and
this data is probably on Enterprise
computer so this is actually active
Twitter's going on and then it goes into
Hado file system remember the Hado file
system is a data warehouse for storing
data and so the first step is we want to
go ahead and load it into the pig
storage into our data storage system the
remaining operations performed are shown
Below in join and group operation the
tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from uh usernames and tweet
to the ID linked directly to the name so
Alice was user one Tim was two and John
three and so now they're listed with
their actual tweet the next operation is
the aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count so it's very straightforward we
just want to count how many tweets each
user is doing and finally the result
after the account operation is joined
with the user table to find out the
username and you can see here where LS
head 3 Tim 2 and John 1 Pig reduces the
complexity of the operations which would
have been lengthy using map reduce in
joining group operation the tweet and
user tables are joined and grouped using
co-group command the next operation is
the aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
we're talking about three lines of
script versus a map reduced code of
about 80 lines finally we could find out
the number of tweets created by a user
in a simple way so let's go quickly over
some of the features of pig that we
already went through most of these uh
first ease of programming as Pig Latin
is similar to SQL lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time is the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kind of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create
userdefined functions Pig offers a large
set of operators such as join filter and
so on it allows for multiple queries to
process un parallel and optimization and
compilation is easy as it is done
automatically and
[Music]
internally
so enough Theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do in pick today's setup we'll
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go ahead and use cloud era
quick start and we'll be doing this in
Virtual box we do have a tutorial in
setting that up you can send a note to
our simply learn team and then get that
linked to you once your Cloud era quick
start has uh spun up and remember this
is virtual box we've created a virtual
machine and this virtual Mach machine is
Centos Linux once it's spun up you'll be
in a full Linux system here and as you
can see we have a Thunderbird browser
which opens up to the Hadoop basic
system browser and we can go underneath
the Hue where it comes up by default if
you click on the pull down menu and go
under editor you can see there's our
Impala our Hive uh Pig along with a
bunch of other query languages you can
use and we're going under Pig and then
once you're in pig we can go ahead and
use our command line here here and just
click that little blue button to start
it up and running we will actually be
working in terminal window and so if you
in the cloud era quick start you can
open up the terminal window up top or if
you're in your own setup and you're
logged in you can easily use all of your
commands here in terminal window and
we'll zoom in that way you get a nice
view of what's going on there we go now
for our first command we're going to
ahead and do a Hadoop command and import
some data into the Hadoop system in this
case a pig input and let's just take a
look at this we have uh Hadoop let's it
know it's going to be Hadoop command DFS
there's actually four variations of DFS
so if you have hdfs or you know whatever
that's fine all four of them Point used
to be different setups underneath
different things and now they all do the
same thing and we want to put this file
which in this case is under home Cloud
era documents and Sample and we just
want to take that and put it into the
pig input and let's take a look at that
file if I go under my document browsers
and open this up you'll see it's got a
simple ID name profession and age we
have one Jack engineer 25 and that was
in one of our earlier things we had in
there and so let's go ahead and hit
enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our Pig input and then a lot of the uh
Hadoop commands mimic the Linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or has a hyphen before it
so we execute that with Hadoop DFS
hyphen cat SL Pig input because that's
what we called it that's where we put
our sample CSV at and we execute this
you can see from our Hadoop system is
going to go in and pull that up and sure
enough it pulls out the data file we
just put in there and then we can simply
enter the pig Latin or Pig editor mode
by typing in Pig and we can see here uh
by our grunt I told you that's how it
was going to tell you you were in pig
latin there's our grunt command line so
we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way that this works is
I'm going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be Pig input we have that in single
brackets you remember that's where the
data is in the Hado file system where we
dumped it into there we're going to
using Pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as and in
this case we have an ID character array
name character array profession
character array and age character array
and we're just going to do them all as
character arrays just to keep this
simple for this one and then when I hit
um put this all in here you can see
that's our full command line going in
and we have our semicolon at the end so
when I hit enter it's now set office up
but it hasn't actually done anything yet
it doesn't do anything until we do dump
office so there's our Command to execute
whatever we've loaded or whatever setup
we have in here and we run that you can
see it go through the different
languages and this is going through the
map reduce remember we're not doing this
locally we're doing this on the Hado
setup and once we finished our dump you
can see we have ID name profession age
and all the information that we just
dumped into our Pig oh we can now do
let's say um oh let's say we have a
request just for we'll keep it simple in
here but just for the name and age and
so we can go office we'll call it each
as our variable underscore each and
we'll say for each office generate name
comma Ag and for each means that we're
going to do the this for each row and if
you're thinking map reduce you know that
this is a map function uh because it's
mapping each row and generating name and
age on here and of course we want to go
ahead and close it with a semicolon and
then once we've created our query or the
um command line in here let's go ahead
and dump
officecore each in with our semicolon
and this will go go through our map
reduce uh setup on here and if we were
on a large cluster the same processing
time would happen in fact it's really
slow because I have multiple things on
this computer and this particular
virtual box is only using a quarter of
my processor it's only dedicated to this
and you can see here there it is name
and age and it also included the top row
since we didn't delete that out of there
or tell it not to and that's fine for
this examle but you need to be aware of
those things when you're processing a
significantly large amount of data or
any data and we can also do um office
and we'll call this DSC for descending
so maybe the boss comes to you and says
hey can we order office by ID descending
and of course your boss you've taught
him how to uh your shareholder sounds a
little drug say boss you've talked to
the shareholder and you said uh and
you've taught them a little bit of Pig
Latin and they know that they can now
create office description and we can
order office by ID description and of
course once we do that we have to dump
officecore description so that it'll
actually execute and there goes into our
map reduce it'll take just a moment for
it to come up because again I'm running
on on on the quarter of my processor and
you can see we now have our IDs in
descending order returned let's also
look at and this is so important with
anytime you're dealing with big data
let's create office with a limit and you
could of course do any of this instead
of with office we could do this with
office descending so you get just the
top two IDs on there we're going to
limit just to two and of course you
execute that we have to dump officecore
limit you can just think of dumping uh
your garbage into to the pig pin for the
pig to eat uh there we go dump office
limit two and that's going to just limit
our office to the top two and for our
output we get our first row which had
our ID name profession and age and our
second row which is Jack who's an
engineer Let's do an uh filter we'll
call it officecore filter you guessed it
equals filter office by profession
equals and keep note this is uh similar
to how python does it with the double
equal signs for equal for doing a true
false statement so for your logic
statement remember to use two equal
signs in Pig and we're going to say it
equals doctor so we want to find out how
many doctors do we have in our list and
we'll go ahead and do our dump we're
dumping all our garbage into the pig pen
and we're letting Pig take over and see
what it can find out and see who's a
doctor on our list and we find uh
employee ID number two Bob is a doctor
30 years old for this next section uh
we're going to cover something we see a
lot nowadays in data analysis and that's
word counting tokenization that is one
of the next big steps as we move forward
in our data analysis where we go from
say stock market analysis of highs and
lows and all the numbers to what are
people saying about companies on Twitter
what are they saying on the web pages
and on Facebook suddenly you need to
start counting words and finding out how
many words are total how many are in the
first part of the document and so on
we're going to cover a very basic word
count uh example and in this case I've
created a document called word rows.
text and you can see here we have simply
learn is a company supporting online
learning simply learn helps people
attain their certifications simply learn
is an online community I love simply
learn I love programming I love data
analysis and I went and save this into
my documents folder so we could use it
and let me go ahead and open up a new uh
terminal window for our word count let
me go and close the old one so we're
going to go in here and instead of doing
this as Pig we're going to do pig minus
X local and what I'm doing is I'm
telling the pig to start the pig shell
but we're going to be looking at files
local to our virtual box or this sentos
machine and let me go ahead and hit
enter on there just maximize this up
there we go and it'll load Pig up and
it's going to look just the same as the
pig we were doing which was defaulted to
high to our Hadoop system to our hdfs
this is now defaulted to the local
system now we're going to create lines
we're going to load it straight from the
file remember last time we took the hdfs
and loaded it into there and then loaded
it into Pig since we're g the local
we're just going to run a local script
we have lines equals load home the
actual full path home Cloud era
documents and I called it word rows.
text and as line is a character array so
each line and I've actually you can
change this to read each document I
certainly have done a lot of document
analysis and then you go through and do
word counts and different kind of counts
in there so once we go ahead and create
our line in instead of doing the dump
we're going to go ahead and start
entering all of our different setups or
each of our steps we want to go through
and this is take a look at this next one
because the load is straightforward
we're loading from this particular file
since we're locals loading it directly
from here instead of going into the Hado
file system and it says as and then the
each line is read as a character array
now we're going to do words equal for
each of the lines generate Flat tokenize
Line space as word now there's a lot of
ways to do this this is if you're a
programmer you're just splitting the
line up by spaces there's actual ways to
tokenize it you got to look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the uh
flatten takes the line and just creates
a uh it flattens each of the words out
so this is uh we're just going to
generate a bunch of words for each line
and then each each of those words is as
a word a little confusing in there but
if you really think about it we're just
going down each line separating it out
and we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenize line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
grouped equals group words by words so
we're going to group all all the same
words together and if we're going to
group them then we want to go ahead and
count them and so for count we'll go
ahead and create a word count variable
and here's our for each so for each
grouped grouped is our line where we
group all the words in the line that are
similar we're going to generate a group
and then we're going to count the words
for each group so for each line where we
group the words together we're going to
generate a group and that's going to
count the words we want to know the word
count in each of those and that comes
back in our word count and finally we
want to take this and we want to go
ahead and dump word count and this is a
little bit more uh what you see when you
start looking at grunt scripts you'll
see right here these these lines right
here we have each of the steps you take
to get there so we load our file for
each of our um lines we're going to
generate and tokenize it into words then
we're going to take the words and we're
going to group them by same words uh for
each grouped we're going to generate a
group and we're just is going to count
the words so we're going to summarize
all the words in here and let's go ahead
and do our dump word count which
executes all this and it goes through
our map reduce it's actually a local
Runner you'll see down here you start
seeing where they still have map reduce
but is a special Runner we're mapping it
that's a part of each row being counted
and grouped and then when we do the word
count that's a reducer the reducer
creates these keys and you can see I is
used three times a came up once n came
up once is two continue on down here to
attain online people company analysis
simply learn they took the uh top rating
with four uh certification so all these
things are then countered in the how
many words are used uh and in data
analysis this is probably the very the
beginnings of data analysis where you
might look at it and say oh they
mentioned love uh three times so
whatever's going on in this post it's
about love and uh what do they love and
then you might attach that to the
different objects in here here so you
can see that uh Pig Latin is fairly easy
to use there's nothing really you know
it may it takes a little bit to learn
the script uh depending on how good your
memory is as I get older my memory leaks
a little bit more so I don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduced localized run comes out and
like I said it's very easy to use that's
why people like Pig Latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things I like
about Pig Latin is when I'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
uh you start doing one line at a time
and so I can go lines equal load and
there's my loaded text and maybe I'll
just dump lines and then it's going to
run it's going to show me all the lines
that I'm working on in the small amount
of data and that way I can test that if
I got an error on there that said oh
this isn't working maybe I'll be like oh
my gosh I'm in map reduce or I'm in the
basic um grunt shell instead of the
local path grunt uh so maybe it'll
generate an error on there and you can
see see here it just shows each of the
lines going down so spark real time data
analysis and I told you spark is its own
animal so we're going to touch very
little on spark as far as how big and
robust it is but we're going to talk a
little bit about spark spark is an open-
Source distributed computing engine for
processing and analyzing huge volumes of
realtime data so it runs 100 times
faster than map reduce map reduces the
basics of the Hadoop system which is
usually set up in a Java code in spark
the map reduce instead of running um
what happens in map reduce is it goes
pulls it into the ram writes it to the
hard drive reads it off the hard drive
shuffles it around writes it back to the
hard drive pulls it off the hard drive
does his processing and you get the
impression it's going in and out of ram
to the hard drive and back up again so
if you don't have a lot of RAM and you
have older computers and you don't have
the ram to process something then spark
and hop are going to run the same speed
otherwise spark goes hey let's keep this
all on the RAM and run faster and that's
what we're talking about is provides
inmemory computation of data so it's
fast you can see the guy running through
the door there speedy versus a very slow
Hadoop wanding around and it's used to
process and analyze real-time streaming
data such as stock market and baking
data so the spark can have its own stuff
going on and then it can access the
Hadoop database it can pull data just
like scoop and Flume do so it has all
those features in it and uh you can even
run spark with its own yarn outside of
Hadoop there's also spark on msos which
is another resource manager although
yarn is most commonly used and currently
spark pretty much becomes installed with
Hadoop and so your spark running on top
of Hadoop will use the same nodes it has
its own manager and it utilizes the ram
so you'll have both you can have U the
spark on top of there and here we go you
have your driver program your spark
context it goes into your cluster
manager your yarn then you have your
worker nodes which are going to be
executing tasks and cash and it's
important to remember when you're
running the spark setup even though
these are commodity machines we're still
usually a lot of them are like 128 GB of
RAM so that spark can run these high-end
processes certainly if it's not accessed
very much and you're building a um
Hadoop cluster you could drop that Ram
way down if you're doing just queries
without any kind of processing on there
and you're not doing a lot of queries
but you know generally spark you're
looking at higher end uh there's still
commodity machines to do your work and
now we get into the Hadoop machine
learning and so machine learning is its
own animal I keep saying that these are
all kind of unique things mahout is
being phased out I mean people still use
it it's still important if you can write
your basic machine learning that has
most of the tools in there you certainly
can do it in mahout mahout again writes
to the hard drive reads from the hard
drive you can do all that in spark and
it's faster because it's just in Ram and
so spark has its own machine learning
tools in it and you can also use py
spark which then accesses all the
different python tools and there's
there's just so many tools you can dump
into spark mahout is very limited but
it's also very basic which in itself can
be really good sometimes simple is
better so mow is used to create scalable
and distributed machine learning
algorithms so here we have our mahout
environment it builds a machine learning
application so you're doing linear
regression you're doing clustering
you're doing classification models it
has a library that contains inbuilt
algorithms for all of these and then it
has collaborative filtering and again
there's our classification and there's
our clustering regression so you have
your different machine learning tools we
can easily classify a large amount of
data using mahout so this brings us to
the next set of tools we have or the
next tool which is the Apache ambari
Amari is an open-source tool responsible
for keeping track of running
applications and their statuses think of
this as like a traffic cop uh more like
a security guard you can open it up and
see what's going on and so the Apache
and barari manages monitors and
Provisions Hadoop clusters provides a
central Management Service to start stop
and configure Hadoop services so again
it's like a traffic cop hey stop over
there start keep going hey what's going
on over that area in the through Lane on
the highspeed freeway and you can open
this up and you have a really easy view
of what's going on and so you can see
right here you have the umari web the
umari web is what you're looking at
that's your interface that you've logged
into the ambari server this will be
usually on the master node it's usually
if you're going to install on barage
you'll just install it on the same node
and it connects up to the database and
then it has agents and each agent takes
a look and see what's going on with its
host server and if you're going to have
uh two more systems and we talked about
spark streaming there's also CFA and
Apache for streaming data coming in and
cfa's distributed streaming platform to
store and process streams of records and
it's written in Scala builds realtime
screaming data pipelines that reliably
get data between app applications builds
real-time streaming applications that
transforms data into streams so it kind
of goes both ways on there so CFA uses a
messaging system for transferring data
from one application to another so we
have our sender we have our message CU
and then we have our receiver pretty
straightforward very solid setup on
there with the cafka paty storm storm is
a processing engine that processes
realtime streeting at a very high speed
and it's written in closure they utilize
the function based programming style of
closure and it's based on list to give
it the speed that's why Apache storm is
built on there so you could think of
Kafka as a slow moving very solid
communication Network where Storm is
looking at the real- time data and
grabbing that streaming data that's
coming in fast so has ability to process
over a million jobs in a fraction of
seconds on a node so it's massive it can
really reach out there and grab the data
and it's integrated with the dup to
harness higher Thorp puts so this is the
two big things about storm if you are
polling I think they mentioned stock
coming in or something like that where
you're looking for the latest data
popping up storm is a really powerful
tool to use for that so we've looked at
a couple more tools for bringing data in
we probably should talk a little bit
about security security has in Hadoop
has the Apache Ranger and Apache noox
are the two most popular one and the
ranger the Apache Ranger Ranger is a
framework to enable Monitor and manage
data Securities across the Hadoop
platform so the first thing it does is
it provides centralized Security
Administration to manage all security
related tasks the second thing it does
is it has a standardized authorization
across all Hadoop components and third
it uses enhanced support for different
authorization methods role-based Access
Control attribute based Access Control
Etc so your patchy Ranger can go in
there and your administrator coming in
there can now very easily monitor who
has what rights and what they can do and
what they can access so there's also
Apache nox nox is an application Gateway
for interacting with the rest apis and
the uis of Hadoop developers and so we
have our application programmer
interfaces our user interfaces and we
talk about rest apis this means we're
pulling this is looking at the actual um
data coming in what applications are
going on so if you have an an
application where people are pulling
data off of The Hop system or pushing
data into the dup system the nox is
going to be on that setup and it
delivers three groups of user-facing
services one proxy Services provides
access to Hadoop via proxying the HTTP
request two authentication Services
authentication for rest API access and
web SSO flow for user interfaces so
there's our rest and finally Client
Services client development can be done
with the scripting through DSL or using
the KNX shell classes so the first one
is if you have a website coming in and
out your HTTP request again here three
different services are what's coming in
and out of the Hadoop file system so
there's a couple of the security setups
let's go ahead and take a look at
workflow system the uzi and there's some
other ones out there Uzi is the one
that's specific deop there's also like a
zookeeper out there and some other ones
Uzi is pretty good Uzi is a workflow
scheduler system to manage Hadoop jobs
and so you have a workflow engine and a
coordinator engine so it consists of two
parts what's going on and coordinating
what's going on and uh directed asick
graph dags which specifies a sequence of
actions to be executed these consist of
workflow jobs triggered by time and data
available and If you're not familiar
with directed Asic graphs or dags or
whatever terminology you want to throw
at this this is basically a flowchart
you start with process a then the next
process would be process B when process
a is done and it might be that process C
can only be done when process D and F
are done so you want to be able to
control control this you don't want it
to um process the machine learning
script and then pull the data in that
you want to process it on you want to
make sure it's going in the right order
so these consist of workflow jobs and
they're triggered by time and data
availability so maybe you're pulling
stocks in the middle of the night and
once the stock is all pulled so there's
our time sequence it says Hey they've
been posted on the other websites they
post them usually after the stock market
closes the highs and lows and everything
then once that data has been brought in
you know on a Time specific bring the
data in a certain time once the data is
available then we want to trigger our
machine learning script for what's going
to happen next and so we can see here we
have a start our map reduce program our
action node and it begins and either we
have a success then we notify the client
of success usually an email sent out in
successful completion quick demo on H
base you can see some Hands-On let's
start with an introduction to hbase back
in the days data used to be less and was
mostly structured you see we have
structured data here we usually had it
like in a database where you had uh
every field was exactly the correct
length so if you had a name field it was
exactly 32 characters the old access
database in Microsoft uh the files are
small if we had you know hundreds of
people in one database that was
considered Big Data this data could be
easily stored in relational database or
rdbms and we talk about relational
database uh you might think of Oracle
you might think of SQL Microsoft SQL
MySQL all of these have evolved even
from back then to do a lot more today
than they did but they still fall short
in a lot of ways and they're all
examples of an rdms or relationship
database then internet evolved and huge
volumes of structured and
semi-structured data got generated and
you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam filter you know
we're talking about all the HTML Pages
XML which a lot of time is displayed on
our HTML and help desk pages Json all of
this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
Apache hbas Apache hbas was the solution
for this let's take a look at the
history the hbas history and we look at
the hbas history we're going to start
back in 2006 November Google released a
paper on on big table and then in 2017
just a few months later h-based
prototype was created as a Hadoop
contribution later on in the Year 2007
in October first usable hbas along with
the Hado .15 was released and then in
January of 2008 hbas became the sub
project of Hadoop and later on that year
in October all the way into September
the next year hbase was released the0 81
version the 0.19 version and20 and
finally in May of 2010 hbas became
Apache top level project and so you can
see in the course of about four years
hbas started off as just an idea on
paper and has evolved all the way till
2010 as a solid project under the Apache
and since 2010 is continued to evolve
and grow as a major source for storing
data in semi-structured data so what is
hbas hbas is a column oriented database
management system derived from Google's
no SQL database big table that runs on
top of the Hadoop file system or the
hdfs it's an open- source project that
is horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no esql
database written in Java which permits
faster querying uh so Java is the
backend for or the hbase setup and it's
well suited for sparse data sets so it
can contain missing or na values and
this doesn't Boggle it down like it
would another database companies using
hbas so let's take a look and see who is
using this uh nosql database for their
servers and for storing their data and
we have Horton Works which isn't a
surprise because they're one of the like
claa Horton Works they are behind had
doop and one of the big developments and
backing of it and of course Apache hbas
is the um open source behind it and we
have Capital One as Banks you also see
Bank of America where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it uh
so their information might be very
sparse they might have one Bank way back
when they collected information as far
as the person's family and what their
income for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as he
starts saying where you have data that
is uh very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubs spots using
it Facebook
uh certainly all of your Facebook
Twitter most of your social medias are
using it and then of course there's JP
Morgan Chase and Company another bank
that uses the hbas as their data
warehouse for nosql let's take a look at
an hbas use case so we can dig a little
bit more into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia Services
across China the China mobile and China
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or CDR and so these CD
RS and all these records of these calls
and how long they are and different
aspects of the call maybe the tower
they're broadcasted from all of that is
being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing in real-time analysis of
billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution Apache
hbas hbas stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbas performs fast
processing of records using SQL queries
so you can mix your SQL and no SQL
queries and usually to say nosql queries
because of the way the query Works
applications of hbas one of them would
be in the medical industry hbas is used
for storing genome sequences storing
disease history of people of an area and
you can imagine how sparse that is as
far as both of those a genome sequence
might be only have pieces to it that
each person is unique or is unique to
different people and the same thing with
disease you really don't need a column
for every possible disease a person
could get you just want to know what
those diseases those people have had to
deal with in that area e-commerce hbas
is used for rest storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and Target advertisement for
Better Business insights sports hbas
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so we look at hbas we all
want to know what's a difference between
hbase versus
rdbms that is a relational database
management system hbas versus rdbms so
the hbas does not have a fixed schema
it's schemes defines only column
families and we'll show you what that
means later on an rdbms has a fixed
schema which describes the structure of
the tables and you can think of this as
you have a row and you have columns and
each column is a very specific structure
how much data can go in there and what
it does with the AG base it works well
with structured and semi-structured data
with the rdbms it works only well with
structured data with the AG base it can
have denormalized data it can contain
missing or null values with the rdbms it
can store only normalized data now you
can still store a null value in the
rdbms but it still takes up the same
space as if you're storing a regular
value in many cases and it also for the
h Bas is built for y tables it can be
scaled horizontally for instance if you
are doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your SQL
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the H base it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and I always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data I'm adding on roughly
$1,000 in commodity Computing with an
Enterprise machine uh we're looking at
about 10,000 at the lower end for each
terabyte of data and that includes all
your backup and redundancy so it's a big
difference it's like a tenth of the cost
to stored across the hbase it has
automatic failure support right ahead
log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbas provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a Java API for client access
provides easy to use Java API for
clients block cache and Bloom filters so
the hbas supports block hashing and
Bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbas storage hbas column
oriented storage and I told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key and this is really one of
the important references is each row has
to have its own key or your row ID and
then you have your column family and in
here you can see we have column family 1
column Family 2 column family 3 and you
have your column qualifiers so you can
have in column family one you can have
three columns in there and there might
not be any data in that so when you go
into column family one and do a query
for every column that contains a certain
thing that row might not have anything
in there and not be queried where in
column Family 2 maybe you have column
one filled out and column three filled
out and so on and so forth and then each
cell is connected to the row where the
data is actually stored let's take a
look at this at what looks like when you
fill the data in so in here we have a
row key with a row ID and we have our
employee ID 1 two 3 that's pretty
straightforward you probably would even
have that on an SQL server and then you
have your column family this is where it
starts really separating out your column
family you might have personal data and
under personal data you would have name
City age you might have a lot more than
just that you might have number of
children you might have degree all those
kinds of different things that go under
personal data and some of them might be
missing you might only have the name and
the age of an employee you might only
have the name the city and how many
children and not the age and so you can
see with the personal data you can now
collect a large variety of data and
stored in the H base very easily and
then maybe have a family of professional
data your designation your salary all
the stuff that the employee is doing for
you in that company let's dig a little
deeper into the hbas architecture and so
you can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the the
Apache hbas we have the Zookeeper which
is used for monitoring what's going on
and you have your hmaster this is the
hbas master assigns regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbas master then under the HM or
hbas Master you have your Reger server
serves data for read and write and the
region server which is all your
different computers you have in your
Hadoop cluster you'll have a region an
hlog you'll have a store memory store
and then you have your different files
for H file that are stored on there and
those are separated across the different
computers and that's all part of the
hdfs storage system so when we look at
the Architectural Components or regions
and we're looking down we're drilling
down a little bit h-based tables are
divided horizontally by row so you have
a key range into regions so each of
those IDs you might have IDs 1 to 20 21
to 50 or whatever they are regions are
assigned to the nodes in the cluster
called region servers a region contains
all rows in the table between the region
start key and the End Key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
git and the git sends it out it finds
out where that start if it's between
which start keys and end keys and then
it pulls the data from that different
region server and so the region sign
data definition language operation
create delete are handled by the hmaster
so the hmas is telling it what are we
doing with this data what's going out
there assigning and reassigning regions
for Recovery or load balancing and
monitoring all servers so that's also
part of it so you know if your IDs if
you have 500 IDs across three servers
you're not going to put 400 IDs on
server one and 100 on server two and
leaves Region Three and region four
empty you're going to split that up and
that's all handled by the hmas and you
can see here it monitors region servers
assigns regions to region servers
assigns regions to region servers and so
forth and so forth hbas has a
distributed environment where hmaster
alone is not sufficient to manage
everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with hmas so you
have an an active hmaster which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the Zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zookeeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active hmaster
fails it'll come to the rescue active
hmaster and region servers connect with
a session to zookeeper so you see your
active hm selection region server
session they're all looking at the
Zookeeper keeping that pulse an active
hm region server connects with a session
to the Zookeeper and you can see here
where we have ephemeral nodes for active
sessions via heartbeats to indicate that
the region servers are up and running so
let's take a look at uh hbas read or
write going on there's a special h-based
catalog table called The Meta table
which holds a location of the regions in
the cluster here's what happens the
first time a client reads or writes data
to hbase the client gets the region
server the host the meta table from
zookeeper and you can see right here the
client has a request for your region
server and goes hey zookeeper can you
handle this and the Zookeeper takes a
look at it and goes ah meta location is
stored in Zookeeper so it looks at his
metad data uh on there and then the
metadata table location is sent back to
the client the client will query The
Meta server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the medit table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're quering so we
get the region server for row key from
The Meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or get
Row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbas meta table special hbas
catalog table that maintains a list of
all the region servers in the hbas
storage system so you see here we have
the meta table we have a row key and a
value table key region region server so
the meta table is used to find the
region for the given table key and you
can see down here you know our meta
table comes in it's going to figure out
where it's going with the region server
and we look a little closer at the right
mechanism in hbas we have write a head
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for Recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts uh the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store M store
is a right cache that stores a new data
that not yet been written to disk there
is one M store per column family per
region and once we've done that we have
three act once the data is placed in MIM
store the client then receives the
acknowledgment when the MIM store
reaches the threshold it dumps or
commits the data into H file so you can
see right here we've taken our our it's
gone into the wall the wall then sorts
it into the different memory stores uh
and then the memory stores it says Hey
we've reached we're ready to dump that
into our H files and then it moves it
into the H files H files store the Roses
data as stored key value on disk so here
we've done a lot of theory let's dive in
and just take a look and see what some
of these commands look like and what
happens in our age base when we're
manipulating a nosql
[Music]
setup so if you're learning a new setup
it's always good to start with where is
this coming from it's open source by
Apache and you can go to hb. apache.org
and you'll see that it has a lot of
information you can actually download
the hbas separate from the Hadoop
although most people just install the
Hadoop because it's bundled with it and
if you go in here you'll find a
reference guide and so you can go
through the Apache reference guide and
there's a number of things to look at
but we're going to be going through
Apache hbase shell that's what we're
going to be working with and there's a
lot of other interfaces on the setup and
you can look up a lot of the different
commands on here so when we go into the
Apache hbas reference guide we can go
down to read hbas shell commands from a
command file you can see here where it
gives you different options of formats
for putting the data in and listing the
data certainly can also create files and
scripts to do this too but we're going
to look at the basics and we're going to
go through this on a basic uh hbas shell
and one last thing to look at is of
course if you continue down the setup
you can see here where they have more
detail as far as how to create and how
to get to your data on your hbase now I
will be working in a virtual box and
this is by Oracle you can download the
Oracle virtual box box you can put a
note in below for the YouTube as we did
have a previous session on setting up
virtual setup to run your Hadoop system
in there I'm using the cloud era quick
start installed in here there's hortens
you can also use the Amazon web service
there's a number of options for trying
this out in this case we have Cloudera
on the Oracle virtual box the virtual
box has Linux Centos installed on it and
then the Hop it has all the different
hop flavors including hbas and I bring
this up because my computer is a Windows
10 P the operating system of the virtual
box is Linux and we're looking at the
hbas data warehouse and so we have three
very different entities all running on
my computer and that can be confusing if
it's a first time in and working with
this kind of setup now you'll notice in
our uh Cloud Dera setup they actually
have some hbas monitoring so I can go
underneath here and click on hbas and
master and it'll tell me what's going on
with my region servers it'll tell me
what's going on with our backup tables
right now I don't have any user tables
cuz we haven't created any and this is
only a single node and a single hbas
store so you're not going to expect
anything too extensive in here since
this is for practice and education and
perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy cloud of course but when you talk
about a quick start or a single node
setup that's what it's really for so we
can go through all the different hbas
and you'll see all kinds of different
information with zookeeper if you saw it
flash by down here what version we're
working in so zookeeper is part of the
hbas setup where we want to go is we
want to open up a terminal window and in
Cloud Dera it happens to be up at the
top and when you click on here you'll
see your Cloud era terminal window open
and let me just expand this so we have a
nice full screen and then I'm also going
to zoom in that way you have a nice big
picture and you can see what I'm typing
and what's going out on and to open up
your hbas shell simply type hbas shell
to get in and hit enter and you'll see
it takes just a moment to load and we'll
be in our hbas shell for doing hbas
commands once we've gotten into our hbas
shell you'll see you'll have the hbas
prompt information ahead of it we can do
something simple like list this is going
to list whatever tables we have and it
so happens that there's a base table
that comes wish H Bas now we can go
ahead and create and I'm going to type
in gist create what's nice about this is
it's going to throw me kind of a uh it's
going to say hey there's no just
straight create but it does come up and
tell me all these different formats we
can use for create so we can create our
table and one of our family
you can add splits names versions all
kinds of things you can do with this but
let's just start with a very basic one
on here and let's go ahead and create
and we'll call it new table uh let's
just to call it new TBL for table new
table and then we also want to do let's
do knowledge so let's take a look at
this I'm creating a new table and it's
going to have a family of knowledge in
it and let me hit enter and it's going
to come up it's going to take it a
second to go ahead and create it now we
have our new table in here so if I go
list you'll now see table and new table
so you can now see that we have the new
table and of course the default table
that's set up in here and we can do
something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
TBL and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name I
have knowledge data block en coding none
Bloom filter row replication scope
version all the different information
you need new minimum version zero
forever deleted cells false block size
in memory and you can look this stuff up
on apache.org to really track it down
one of the things that's important to
note is versions so you have your
different versions of the data that's
stored and that's always important to
understand that we might talk about that
a little bit later on and then after we
describe it we can also do a status the
status says I have one active Master
going on that's our H base as a whole we
can do status summary I should do the
same thing as status so we got the same
thing coming up and now that we've
created let's go ahead and put something
in it so we're going to put new TBL and
then we want Row one you know what
before I even do this let's just type in
put and you can see when I type in put
it gives us like a lot of different
options of how it works and different
ways of formatting our data as it goes
in and all of them usually begin with
the new table new TBL then we have in
this case we'll call it Row one and then
we'll have knowledge if you remember we
created knowledge already and we'll do
knowledge Sports and then in knowledge
and sports we're going to set that equal
to Cricket so we're going to put underne
this uh our knowledge setup that we have
a thing called Sports in there and we'll
see what this looks like in just a
second let's go ahead and put in we'll
do a couple of these let's see let's do
another row one and this time set of
sports Let's Do Science you know this
person not only you know we have Row one
which is both knowledgeable in cricket
and also in chemistry so it's a chemist
who plays Cricket in row one and um
let's see if we have let's do another
row one just to keep it going and we'll
do science in this case let's do physics
not only in chemistry but also a
physicist I have quite a joy in physics
myself so here we go we have U Row one
there we go and then let's do uh row two
let's see what that looks like when we
start putting in row two and in row two
this person is has knowledge in
economics this is a master of business
and how maybe it's Global economics
maybe it's just for the business and how
it fits in with the country's economics
and we call it macroeconomics so I guess
it is for the whole country there so we
have knowledge economics macroeconomics
and then let's just do one more we'll
keep it as row two and this time our
Economist is also a musician so we'll
put music and they happen to have
knowledge and they enjoy oh let's do pop
music they're into the current pop music
going on so we've loaded our database
and you'll see we have two rows Row one
and row two in here and we can do is we
can list the contents of our database by
simply doing scan uh scan and then let's
just do scan scan by itself so you can
see how that looks you can always just
type in there and it tells you all the
different setups you can do with scan
and how it works in this case we want to
do scan new TBL and in our scan new TBL
we have Row one row one row two row two
and you'll see Row one has a column
called knowledge science time step value
crickets value physics so it has
information as when it was created when
the time stamp is Row one also has
knowledge Sports and a value of cricket
so we have Sports and Science and this
is interesting because if you remember
up here we also gave it originally we
told it to come in here and have
chemistry we had science chemistry and
science physics and we come down here I
don't see the chemistry why because
we've now replaced chemistry with
physics so the new value is physics on
here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new table
and when I hit enter in here you're
going to see it comes out true and then
we'll go ahead and disable it let's go
and disable new table make sure I have
our quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan when we do the scan new table I hit
enter you're going to see that we get an
error coming up so once it's disabled
you can't do anything with it until we
reenable it now before we enable the
table Let's do an alteration on it and
here's our new table and this should
look a little familiar cuz it's very
similar to create we'll call this test
info and we'll hit enter in there it'll
take just a moment for updating and then
we want to go ahead and enable it so
let's go ahead and enable our new table
so it's back up and running and then we
want to describe describe new table and
we come in here you'll now see we have
name knowledge and under there we have
our data encoding and all the
information under knowledge and then we
also have down below test info so now we
have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops I already
did that I guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at while we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do R1 and when we do
hspace R1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a timestamp value
physics and we have knowledge Sports and
it has a timestamp on it and value
Cricut and then let's see what happens
when we put into our new table and in
here we want Row one and if you can
guess from earlier cuz we did something
similar uh we're going to do knowledge
economics and then it's going to be
instead of uh I think it was what uh
macroeconomics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our get command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a Tim stamp value
market economics physics and Cricut and
this is because we have uh economics
science and Sports those are the three
different columns that we have and then
each one has different information in it
and so if you manage to go through all
these commands and look at Basics on
here you'll now have the ability to
create a very basic hbase setup nosql
setup based on your columns and your
rows and just for fun we'll go back to
the cloud Dera thanks guys I hope you
guys found this informative with this
we've come to the end of our detailed
look into the Hadoop ecosystem now we
have shti who will explain big data
analytics and some applications of Big
Data let us now understand why big data
analytics is required with an example so
all of you listen to music online isn't
it here we will take an example of
Spotify which is a Swedish audio
streaming platform and see how big data
analytics is used here Spotify has
nearly 96 plus million users and all
these users generate a tremendous amount
of data data like this songs which are
played repeatedly the numerous likes
shares and the user search history all
these data can be termed as Big Data
here with respect to Spotify have you
ever wondered what Spotify does with all
this big data well Spotify analyzes this
big data for suggesting songs to its
users I'm sure all of you might have
come across the recommendation list
which is made available to each one of
you by Spotify each one of you will have
a totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so Spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because Spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by Spotify now that we
have understood why big data analytics
is required let us move on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term Big Data many a times
but do you know what exactly Big Data
means well we will understand the term
Big Data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as I talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of Facebook Facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages Etc Big Data also contains data
of different formats like structured
data semi-structured data and
unstructured data data like your Excel
sheets all fall under structured data
this data has a definite format your
emails fall under semi-structured and
your pictures and videos all fall under
unstructured data all this data together
make up for Big Data it is very tough
have to store process and analyze big
data using rdbms if you have looked into
our previous videos you would know that
Hadoop is the solution to this Hadoop is
a framework that stores and processes
Big Data it stores big data using the
distributed storage system and it
processes big data using the parallel
processing method hence storing and
processing big data is no more a problem
using Hadoop big data in its raw form is
of no use to us we must try to derive
meaningful information from it in order
to benefit from this big data do you
know Amazon uses big data to monitor its
items that are in its fulfillment
centers across the globe how do you
think Amazon does this well it is done
by analyzing big data which is known as
big data analytics what is big data
analytics in simple terms big data
analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from Big Data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step I will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management BDO which is a
Philippine banking company uses big data
analytics for risk management risk
management is an important aspect for
any organization especially in the field
of banking risk management analysis
comprises a series of measures which are
employed to prevent any sort of
unauthorized activities identifying
fraudulent activities was a main concern
for BDO it was difficult for the bank to
identify the fraudster from a long list
of suspects BDO adopted big data
analytics which helped the bank to
narrow down the entire list of suspects
thus the organization was able to
identify the fraudster in a very short
time this is how big data analytics is
used in the field of banking for risk
management let us now see how big data
analytics is used for product
development and Innovations with an
example all of you are aware of
Rolls-Royce cars right do you also know
that the manufactur jet engines which
are used across the world what is more
interesting is that they use Big Data
analytics for developing and innovating
this engine a new product is always
developed by trial and error method big
data analytics is used here to analyze
if an engine design is good or bad it is
also used to analyze if there can be
more scope for improvement based on the
previous models and on the future
demands this way big data analytics is
used in designing a product which is of
higher quality using big data analytics
the company can can save a lot of time
if the team is struggling to arrive at
the right conclusion big data can be
used to zero in on the right data which
have to be studied and thus the time
spent on the product development is less
big data analytics helps in quicker and
better decision making in organizations
the process of selecting a course of
action from various other Alternatives
is known as decision making lot of
organizations take important decisions
based on the data data that they have
datadriven business decisions can make
or break a company hence it is important
to analyze all the possibilities
thoroughly and quickly before making
important decisions let us now try to
understand this with an use case
Starbucks uses big data analytics for
making important decisions they decide
the location of their new outlet using
big data analytics choosing the right
location is an important factor for any
organization the wrong location will not
be able to attract the required amount
of customers positioning of a new outlet
a few miles here or there can always
make a huge difference for an outlet
especially a one like Starbucks various
factors are involved in choosing the
right location for a new outlet for
example parking uracy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and and
thoroughly thus Starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
Delta and American Airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does everything they can in
order to provide good service and
experience to its customers Delta
Airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers Journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customer's
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the Airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose Delta for
for their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis Delta Airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
will have to see if the data that we
received is fit for analysis or not not
all the data that we receive will have
meaningful information some of it will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data is
now fit for analysis well it is not we
still have to figure out which data will
be compatible with the tool that we will
be using for analysis if we find data
which is incompatible we first extract
it and then transform it to a compatible
form depending on the tool that we use
in the next stage all the data with the
same Fields will be integrated this is
known as the data aggregation stage the
next stage which is the analysis stage
is a very important stage in the life
cycle of Big Data data analytics right
here in this step the entire process of
evaluating your data using various
analytical and statistical tools to
discover meaningful information is done
like we have discussed before the entire
process of deriving meaningful
information from data which is known as
analysis is done here in this stage the
result of the data analysis stage is
then graphically communicated using
tools like like tblo powerbi click view
this analysis result will then be made
available to different business
stakeholders for various decision making
this was the entire life cycle of big
data analytics we just saw how data is
analized from scratch now we will move
on to a very important topic that is the
different types of big data analytics
well we have four different types of big
data analytics as you see here these are
the types and below this are the
questions that each type tries to answer
we have descriptive analytics which asks
the question what has happened then we
have diagnostic analytics which asks why
did it happen Predictive Analytics
asking what will happen and prescriptive
analytics which questions by asking what
is the solution we will look into all
these four one by one with an use case
for each we will first start off with
descriptive analytics as mentioned ear
descriptive analytics asks the question
what has happened it can be defined as
the type that summarizes past data into
a form that can be understood by humans
in this type we will look into the past
data and arrive at various conclusions
for example an organization can review
its performance using descriptive
analytics that is it analyzes its past
data such as Revenue over the years and
arrives at a conclusion with the profit
by looking at this graph we can
understand if the company is running at
a profit or not thus descriptive
analytics helps us understand this
easily we can simply say that
descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like Facebook likes tweets
Etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the Dow Chemical company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly $4 million annually so we
now see here that descriptive analytics
not only helps us derive meaningful
information from the past data but it
can also help companies in cost
reduction if it is used wisely let us
now move on to our next type that is
diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data Discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it inet soft's
bi query tool is an example of
diagnostic analytics we can use Query
tool for Diagnostic analytics now that
you know why diagnostic analytics is
required and what diagnostic analytics
is I will run you through an example
which shows where diagnostic analytics
can be used all of us shop on e-commerce
sites right have you ever added items to
your cart but ended up not buying it yes
all of us might have done that at some
point an organization tries to
understand why its customers don't end
up buying their products although it has
been added to their cards and this
understanding is done with the help of
diagnostic analytics an e-commerce site
wonders why they have made few online
sales although they have had a very good
marketing strategy there could have been
various factors as to why this has
happened factors like the shipping fee
which was too high or the page that
didn't load correctly not enough payment
options available and so on all these
factors are analyzed using diagnostic
analytics and the company comes to a
conclusion as to why this has happened
thus we see here that the root cost is
identified so that in future the same
problem doesn't occur again let us now
move on to the third type that is
Predictive Analytics as the name
suggests Predictive Analytics makes
predictions of the Future IT analyzes
the current and historical facts to make
predictions about future it always asks
the question what will happen next
Predictive Analytics is used with the
help of artificial intelligence machine
learning data mining to analyze the data
it can be used for predicting customer
Trends market trends customer Behavior
Etc it solely works on probability it
always tries to understand what can
happen next with the help of all the
past and current information a company
like PayPal which has 260 plus million
accounts always has the need to ensure
that their online fraudulent and
unauthorized activities are brought down
to nil fear of constant fraudulent
activities have always been a major
concern for PayPal when a fraudulent
activity occurs people lose trust in the
company and this brings in a very bad
name for the brand it is inevitable that
fraudulent activities will happen in a
company like PayPal which is one of the
largest online payment processes in the
world but PayPal uses analytics wisely
here to prevent such fraudulent
activities and to minimize them it uses
Predictive Analytics to do so the
organization is able to analyze past
data which includes a customer's
historical payment data a customer's
Behavior Trend and then it builds an
algorithm which works on predicting what
is likely to happen next with respect to
their transaction with the use of big
data and algorithms the system can gauge
which of the transactions are valid and
which could be potentially a fraudulent
activity by doing so PayPal is always
ready with precautions that they have to
take to protect all their clients
against fraudulent transactions we will
now move on to our our last type that is
prescriptive analytics prescriptive
analytics as the name suggests always
prescribes a solution to a particular
problem the problem can be something
which is happening currently hence it
can be termed as the type that always
asks a question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and Predictive Analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and be prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit du you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seat selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flight fair is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days Seasons like Christmas and
school vacations also weekends the rates
will be much higher higher than weekday
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight Fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flight's Fair will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight's fair by
doing so the Airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of Big Data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are few of the tools that I will be
talking about today we have Hadoop
mongodb talend Kafka Cassandra spark and
storm we will look into each one of them
one by one we will first start off with
Hadoop when you speak of big data the
first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is Hadoop isn't it as I
mentioned earlier Apache Hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
Hadoop uses map reduce big and high for
analyzing this big data Hadoop is easily
one of the most famous Big Data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a crossplatform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb talend D provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in Big Data
integration talend Open studio is a free
open- source tool for processing data
data easily on a big data environment
Cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to Hadoop in its
feature of fall tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes kandra is preferred for real-time
processing spark is another tool that is
used for data processing this data
processing engine is develop to process
data way faster than Hadoop map ruce
this is done in a way because spark does
all the processing in the main memory of
the data nodes and thus it prevents
unnecessary input output overheads with
the disk whereas map reduce is disk
based and hence spark proves to be
faster than Hadoop map ruce storm is a
free big data computational system which
is done in real time it is one of the
easiest tools for Big Data analysis it
can be used with any programming
language this feature makes storm very
simple to use finally we will look into
another big data tool which is known as
Kafka Kafka is a distributed streaming
platform which was developed by LinkedIn
and later given to apach software
Foundation it is used to provide
realtime analytics result and it is also
used for fault tolerant storage these
were few of the big data analytics tools
the first Big Data application we will
look into is weather focused imagine
there is a sudden stop storm and you're
not even prepared that would be a
terrifying situation isn't it dealing
with any calamities such as hurricanes
storms floods would be very inconvenient
if we are caught off guard the solution
is to have a tool that predicts the
weather of the coming days well in
advance this tool needs to be accurate
and to make such a tool big data is used
so how does Big Data help here well it
allows us to gather all the information
required to predict the weather
information such as the climate change
details wind direction precipitation
previous weather reports and so on after
all this data is collected it becomes
easier for us to spot a trend and
identify what's going to happen next by
analyzing all of this big data a weather
prediction engine works on this analysis
it predicts the weather of every region
across the world for any given time by
using such a tool we can be well
prepared to face any climate change or
any natural Calamity let's take an
example of a land slide and try to
understand how big data is used to
tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the University of Melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur 2 weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce skyh High results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data Publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
Revenue Big Data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations Etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer's
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made Available to You by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
History your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing doing so the site is able to
retain and engage its customer for a
longer time next is customer churn
analysis in simple words customer churn
happens when a customer stops a
subscription with a service predicting
and preventing this is of Paramount
importance to any organization by
analyzing the behavioral patterns of
previously churned customers an
organization can identify which of their
current customers are likely to churn by
analyzing all of this data the
organization can then Implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of Starbucks big data is
effectively used by the Starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new Starbucks location the
system analyzes all the data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthc care
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available Big Data
medical researches are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence Personal Care is
very important Personal Care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history and individuals medical
history along with their body param
meters are analyzed and personal
attention is given to each of them as we
all know Medical Treatments are not very
pocket friendly every time a medical
treatment is taken the amount increases
this can be reduced if readmissions are
brought down analyzing all the data
precisely will deliver a long-term
efficient result which will in turn
prevent a patient readmission frequently
with globalization came an increase in
the ease for infe infectious diseases to
spread widely based on geography and
demographics Big Data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
American Healthcare Company United
Healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the Healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics Logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to re
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available Workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also Finds Its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation ation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of UPS as you know UPS is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute UPS
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routs in real time this is
how efficiently UPS leverages Big Data
next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism Market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak Seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resour
thoughts and hotels to analyze various
details regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further a customer always comes back if
they are offered good packages which are
more than just the basic ones looking
into a customer's past travel history
likes and preferences hotels can provide
its customers with personalized
experiences which will interest them
highly investing in an area which could
be the Hub of Tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
Homestay networks Airbnb and see how big
data is used by them Airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world world big
data is used by it to analyze the
different kinds of available properties
depending on the customer's preferences
the pricing the keywords previous
customers ratings and experiences Airbnb
filters out the best result Big Data
Works its magic yet again now we will
move on to our final sector which is the
government and law enforcement sector
maintaining Law and Order is of utmost
importance to any government it is a
huge task by itself self Big Data plays
an active role here and in addition to
this it also helps governments bring in
new policies and schemes for the welfare
of its citizens the police department is
able to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which break
makes the Law and Order of the region
governments are able to tackle
unemployment to a great extent by using
big data by analyzing the number of
students graduating every year to the
number of relevant job openings the
government can have an idea of the
unemployment rate in the country and
then take necessary measures to tackle
it our next factor is poverty in large
countries it is difficult to analyze
which area requires attention and
development big data analytics makes it
easier for governments to discover such
areas poverty gradually decreases once
these areas begin to develop governments
have to always be on the lookout for
better development a public survey
voices the opinion of a country's
citizens analyzing all the data
collected from such surveys can help
governments build better policies and
services which will benefit its citizens
let us now move on to our use case did
you know that the New York Police
Department uses big data analytics to
protect its citizens the department
prevents and identifies Crimes by
analyzing a huge amount of data which
includes fingerprints certain emails and
records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes thanks shy now
let me tell you how you can become a big
data engineer hi guys I'm R from Simply
learn and today I'm going to tell you
how you can become a big data engineer
now it should come as no surprise for
you guys to know that organizations
generate as well as use a whole lot of
data this vast volume of data is called
Big Data companies use big data to draw
meaningful insights and take business
decisions and Big Data Engineers are the
people who can make sense out of this
enormous amount of data now let's find
out who is a big data engineer a big
data engineer is a professional Who
develops maintains tests and evaluates
the company's Big Data infrastructure in
other words develop Big Data Solutions
based on a company's requirements they
maintain these solutions they test out
these Solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design Implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of ETL or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
effic efficiency of the system now to
ensure that all the business
requirements are met they need to build
a suitable data architecture they need
to be able to integrate several
programming languages and tools together
so that they can generate a structured
solution they need to build models that
reduce the overall complexity and
increase the efficiency of the whole
system by mining data from various
sources and finally they need to work
well with other teams ones that include
data Architects data analysts and data
scientists next up let's have a look at
the skills required to become become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
Big Data Solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages I can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for Big Data
engineering are python Java and C++ the
second skill that you require is to have
in-depth knowledge about dbms and SQL
you need to know how data is maintained
as well as managed in a database you
need to know how SQL can be used to
transform as well as perform actions on
a database and by extension know how to
write SQL queries for any relational
database Management Systems some of the
commonly used database Management
systems for Big Data engineering mySQL
rackle database and the Microsoft SQL
Server the third skill that you require
is to have experience working with ETL
and warehousing tools now you need to
know how to construct as well as use a
data warehouse so that you can perform
the ETL operation or the extract
transform and load operations now as a
big data engineer you'll be constantly
tasked with extracting unstructured data
from a number of different sources
transforming it into meaningful
information and loading it into other
data storages databases or data
warehouses now what this is is basically
aggregating unstructured data from
multiple sources analyzing it so that
you can take Better Business decisions
some of the tools used for this purpose
are Talent IBM data stage pentaho and
Informatica next up we have the fourth
skill that you require which is
knowledge about operating systems now
since most Big Data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as Hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like Linux and Unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by Big Data
engineers are Unix Linux and Solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with Hadoop based analytics
since Hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to Big Data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with Apache
Hadoop based Technologies Technologies
like hdfs Hadoop map produce Apache
edpas Hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with
realtime processing Frameworks like
Apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast water
volumes of data so for this data you
need an analytics engine like spark
which can be used for large scale
real-time data processing now spark can
process live streaming data from a
number of different sources like
Facebook Instagram Twitter and so on it
can also perform interactive analysis
and data integration and now we're at
our final skill requirement which is to
have experience with data mining and
modeling so as a data engineer you'll
have to examine massive pre-existing
data so that you can discover patterns
as well as new information information
with this you'll create predictive
models for your business so that you can
make better informed decisions some of
the tools used for this are R rapid
minor vea and N now let's talk about a
big data engineer salary as well as
other roles they can look forward to now
the average salary of a big data
engineer in the United States is
approximately $90,000 per year now this
ranges from $66,000 all the way to
$130,000 per anom in India the average
salary is around 7 lakh rupees and wages
from 4 lakhs to 13 lakhs per anom after
you've become a big data engineer some
of the job roles that you can look
forward to are that of a senior Big Data
engineer a business intelligence
architect and a data architect now let's
talk about certifications that a big
data engineer can opt for first off we
have the cloud CCP data engineer a cloud
certified professional data engineer
possesses the skills to develop reliable
and scalable data pipelines that result
in optimized data sets for a variety of
workloads it is one of the industry's
most most demanding performance-based
certification CCP evaluates and
recognizes the candidates Mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs $400 next we
have the IBM certified data architect
Big Data certification an IBM certified
Big Data architect understands the
complexity of data and can Design
Systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the Google Cloud
certified data engineer a Google
Certified data engineer enables
datadriven decision making by collecting
transforming and Publishing data they
should also be able to leverage deploy
and continuously train pre-existing
machine learning models the length of
the certification exam is 2 hours and
its registration fee is $200 now let's
have a look at how simply learn can help
you become a big data engineer simply
learn provides the Big Data architect
Masters program this includes a number
of different courses like big data
Hadoop and Spark developer Apache spark
in Scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and Hada
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per anim it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like CFA Apache spark Flume
edpas mongodb Hive Pig map produce Java
Scala and much more I hope this helps we
have now come to the final part of our
video aay will take you through 80 of
the most important interview questions
that just might appear in your big data
interview we will discuss on Hadoop
interview questions and we will learn on
different aspect aspects and be prepared
for Hado interviews so that you can move
into the Big Data Arena here we have
some list of questions and an
explanation of those so that you can be
well prepared for your Hadoop interviews
now let's look at some general Hadoop
questions so what are the different
vendor specific distributions of Hadoop
now all of you might be aware that
Hadoop or Apache Hadoop is the core
distribution of Hadoop and then you have
different vendors and the market which
have packaged the Apache Hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor specific distributions we have
Cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hotton works and now
you might be aware that clouder and
hotton works have merged so it has
become a bigger entity you have mapar
you have Microsoft asure IBM's
infosphere and Amazon on web services so
these are some popularly known vendor
specific distributions if you would want
to know more about the Hado
distributions you should basically look
into Google and you should check for
Hado different distributions wiki page
so if I type Hadoop different
distributions and then I check for the
Wiki page that will take me to the
distributions and Commercial support
page and this basically says that the
sole products that can be called a
release of Apache Hadoop come from
apache.org so that's your open source
community and then you have various
vendor specific distributions which
basically are running in one or the
other way Apache Hadoop but they have
packaged it as a solution like a
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of a dupe coming
back let's look at our next question so
what are the different Hadoop
configuration files now whether you're
talking about Apache Hadoop Cloud era
hoton Works map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important and existing in
every distribution of Hadoop so you have
Hadoop environment. sh wherein you will
have environment variables such as your
Java path what would be your process ID
path where will your logs get stored
what kind of metrics will be collected
and so on your core hyphen site file has
the hdfs path now this has many other
properties like enabling trash or
enabling High availability are
discussing or mentioning about your
zookeeper but this is one of the most
important file you have hdfs hyph site
file now this file will have other
information related to your Hardo
cluster such as your replication Factor
where will name node store its metadata
on disk if a data node is running where
would data node store it its data if a
secondary name node is running where
would that store a copy of name node
metadata and so on your maped hyphen
site file is a file which will have
properties related to your map reduce
processing you also have Masters and
slaves now these might be deprecated in
a vendor specific distribution and in
fact you would have a Yan hyphen site
file which is based on the Yan
processing framework which was
introduced Hado version 2 and this would
have all your resource allocation and
resource manager and node manager
related properties again if you would
want to look at default properties for
any one of these for example let's say
hdfs hyphen site file I could just go to
Google and type in one of the properties
for example I would say DFS do name node
do name do directory and as I know this
property belongs to hdfs hyen site file
and if you search for this it will take
you to the first link which says sdfs
default XML you can click on this and
this will show you all the properties
which can be given in your hdfs hyphen
site file it also shows you which
version you are looking at and you can
always change the version here so for
example if I would want to look at
2.6.5 I just need to change the version
and that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example I would say fs. default
fs and that's a property which is in
core hyphen site file and somewhere here
you would see core minus default.xml and
this will show you all the properties so
similarly you could search for
properties which are related to Yan
hyphen site file or maped hyphen site
file so I could say Yan do resource
manager and I could look at one of these
properties which will Direct ly take me
to Yan default XML and I can see all the
properties which can be given in Yan and
similarly you could say map ruce do job.
reduces and I know this property belongs
to map reduce hyphen site file and this
takes you to the default XML so these
are important config files and no matter
which distribution of adop you're
working on you should be knowing about
these config files whether you work as a
Hadoop admin or you work as a Hadoop
developer ER knowing these config
properties would be very important and
that would also showcase your internal
knowledge about the configs which drive
your Hadoop cluster let's look at the
next question so what are the three
modes in which Hadoop can run so you can
have Hadoop running in a standalone mode
now that's your default mode it would
basically use a local file system and a
single Java process so when you say
Standalone mode it is as you downloading
Hado related package on one single
machine but you would not have any
process running that would just be to
test Hadoop functionalities you could
have a pseudo distributed mode which
basically means it's a single node
Hadoop deployment now Hadoop as a
framework has many many services so it
has a lot of services and those Services
would be running irrespective of your
distribution and each service would then
have multiple processes so your pseudo
distributed mode is a mode of cluster
where you would have all the important
processes belonging to one or multiple
Services running on a single node if you
would want to work on a pseudo
distributed mode and using a cloud era
you can always go to Google and search
for Cloud era's Quick Start VM you can
download it by just saying Cloud era
quick start VM and you can search for
this and that will allow you to download
a quick VM follow the instructions and
you can have a single node Cloud era
cluster running on your virtual machines
for more information you can refer to
the YouTube tutorial where I have
explained about how to set up a quick VM
coming back you could have finally a
production setup or a fully distributed
mode which basically means that your
Hadoop framework and its components
would be spread across multiple machines
so you would have multiple services such
as hdfs Yan Flume scoop Kafka hbase Hive
Impala and for these Services there
would be one or multiple processes
distributed across multiple nodes so
this is normally what is used in
production environment so you could say
Standalone would be good for testing
pseudo distributed could be good for
testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs so when you say regular file
system you could be talking about a
Linux file system or you could be
talking about a windows-based operating
system so in regular file system we
would have data maintained in a single
system so the single system is where you
have all your files and directories so
it is having lowfall tolerance right so
if the machine crashes your data
recovery would be very difficult unless
and until you have a backup of that data
that also affects your processing so if
the machine crashes or if the machine
fails then your processing would be
blocked now the biggest challenge with
regular file system is the seek time the
time taken to read the data so you might
have one single machine with huge amount
of Diss and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least called tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for Hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in htfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple notes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication Factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of Auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination for multiple machines
however if you are working with huge
data which is getting stored it will
still be beneficial in comparison to
reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through Auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up now
let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs Fault
tolerant now as I just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is Fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 MB that's
the minimum since Hado version 2 so any
file which is up to 128 MB would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 MB then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored cross
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is called
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as I mentioned
earlier you would in a Hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs so for
your hdfs service you would have a name
node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across
Orting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about hdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs that data is split
into into blocks depending on its size
and the blocks are randomly distributed
across nodes with auto replication
feature these blocks are also Auto
replicated across multiple machines with
the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up your data nodes which are part of the
cluster and based on config files would
start sending their heartbeat to the
name note and this would be every 3
seconds what does name node do with that
name node will store this information in
its Ram so name node starts building a
metadata in its RAM and that metadata
has information of what are the data
nodes which are available in the
beginning now when a data writing
activity starts and the blocks are
distributed across data noes data nodes
every 10 seconds will also send a block
report to name node so name node is
again adding up this information in it
Ram or the metadata in Ram which earlier
had only data node information now name
node will also have information about
what are the files the files are split
in which blocks the blocks are stored on
which machines and what are the file
permissions now while name node is
maintaining this metadata in Ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk now that is what we see in the red
box which basically has information of
whatever information was to hdfs so to
summarize your name node has metadata in
Ram and metadata in disk your data nodes
are the machines where your blocks or
data is actually getting stored and then
there is a auto replication feature
which is always existing unless and
until you have disabled it and your read
and write activity is a parallel
activity however replication is a
sequential activity now this is what I
mentioned about about when you talk
about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and RAM
so when we talk about dis it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your FS image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata and
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on hdfs metadata in
Ram is dynamically built every time the
cluster comes up which basically means
that if your cluster is coming up name
node in the initial few seconds or few
minutes would be in a safe mode which
basically means it is busy registering
the information from data nodes so name
node is one of the most critical
processes if name node is down and if
all other processes are running you will
not be able to access the cluster name
noes metadata in disk is very important
for name node to come up and maintain
the cluster name node's metadata in Ram
is basically for all or satisfying all
your client requests now when we look at
data nodes as I mentioned data noes hold
the actual data blocks and they are
sending these block reports every 10
seconds so the metadata in name notes
Ram is constantly getting updated and
metadata in disk is also constantly
getting updated based on any kind of
right activity happening on the cluster
now data node which is storing the block
will also help in any kind of read
activity whenever a client requests so
whenever a client or an application or
an API would want to read the data it
would first talk to name node name node
would look into its metadata on RAM and
confirm to the client which machines
could be reached to get to that data
that's where your client would try to
read the data from sdfs which is
actually getting the data from data noes
and that's how your read write requests
are satisfied now what are the two types
of metadata in name node server holds as
I mentioned earlier metadata in disk
very important to remember edit log NFS
image metadata in Ram which is
information about your data nodes files
files being split into blocks blocks
residing on data nodes and file
permissions so I would share a very good
link on this and you can always look for
more detailed information about your
metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hoton Works however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back let's look at the next
question what is the difference between
Federation and high availability now
these are the features which were
introduced in Hado version 2 both of
these features are about horizontal
scalability of name node so prior to
version two the only possibility was
that you could have one single Master
which basically me means that your
cluster could become unavailable if name
node would crash so Hadoop version 2
introduced two new features Federation
and high availability however High
availability is a popular one so when
you talk about f itation it basically
means any number of name notes so there
is no limitation to the number of name
notes your name notes are in a Federated
cluster which basically means name nodes
still belong to the same cluster but
they are not coordinating with each
other so whenever a write request comes
in one of the name node picks up that
request and it guides that request for
the blocks to be written on data nodes
but for this your name node does not
have to coordinate with other name note
to find out if the block ID which was
being assigned was the same one as
assigned by other name note so all of
them belong to a Federated cluster they
are linked via a cluster ID so whenever
an application or an API is trying to
talk to Cluster it is always going via
an cluster ID and one of the name node
would pick up the read activity or write
activity or processing activity so all
the name notes are sharing a pool of
metadata in which each name node will
have its own dedicated pool and we can
remember that by a term called name
space or name service so this also
provides High fall tolerance suppose
your one name note goes down it will not
affect or make your cluster unavailable
you will still have your cluster
reachable because there are other name
nodes running and they are available now
when it comes to heartbeats all your
data notes are sending their heartbeats
to all the name name notes and all the
name notes are aware of all the data
noes when you talk about high
availability this is where you would
only have two name notes so you would
have an active and you would have a
standby now normally in any environment
you would see a high availability setup
with zookeeper so zookeeper is a
centralized coordination service so when
you talk about your active and stand by
name nodes election of a name node to be
made as active and taking care of a
automatic failover is done by your
zookeeper High availability can be set
up without zookeeper but that would mean
that a admin's intervention would be
required to make a name node as active
from standby or also to take care of
failover now at any point of time in
high availability a active name node
would be taking care of storing the
edits about whatever updates are
happening on sdfs and it is also writing
these edits gets to a shared location
standby name node is the one which is
constantly looking for these latest
updates and applying to its metadata
which is actually a copy of whatever
your active name node has so in this way
your standby name node is always in sync
with the active name node and if for any
reason active name node fails your
standby name node will take over and
become the active remember zookeeper
plays a very important role here it's a
centralized coordination service one
more thing to remember here is that in
your high availability secondary name
node will not be allowed so you would
have a active name node and then you
will have a standby name node which will
be configured on a separate machine and
both of these will be having access to a
shared location now that shared location
could be NFS or it could be a quorum of
journ noes so for more information refer
to the tutorial where I I have explained
about sdfs high availability and
Federation now let's look at some
logical question here so if you have a
input file of 350 MB which is obviously
bigger than 128 MB how many input splits
would be created by sdfs and what would
be the size of each input split so for
this you need to remember that by
default the minimum block size is 128 MP
now that's customizable if your
environment has more number of larger
files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 120 MB remember in Hadoop every
entity that is your directory on sdfs
file on sdfs and a file having multiple
blocks each of these are considered as
objects and for each object hadoop's
name nodes Ram 150 bytes is utilized so
if your block size is very small then
you would have more number of blocks
which would directly affect the name
noes Ram if you keep a block size very
high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on splits more number of splits
more the parallel processing so setting
of block size has to be done with
consideration about your parallelism
requirement and your name nodes Ram
which is available now coming to the
question if you have a file of 350 MB
that would be split into three blocks
and here two blocks would have 128 MB
data and the third block although the
block size would still be 128 it would
have only 94 MB of data so this would be
the split of this particular file now
let's understand about rack awareness
how does rack awareness work or why do
we even have racks so organizations
always would want to place their nodes
or machines in a systematic way there
can be different approaches you could
have a rack which would have machines
running only Master processes and the
intention would be that this particular
rack could have higher bandwidth more
cooling dedicated power supply top of
rack switch and so on the second
approach could be that you could have
one master process running on one
machine of every rack and then you could
have other slave processes running now
when you talk about your rack awareness
one thing to understand is that if your
machines are placed within racks and we
are aware that Ado follows Auto
replication the rule of replication in a
rack aware cluster would be that you
would never have all the replicas placed
on the same rack so if we look at this
if we have block a in blue color you
will never have all the three blue boxes
in the same rack even if they are on
different notes because that makes us
that makes it less fault tolerant so you
would have at least one copy of block
which would be stored on a different
rack on a different note now let's look
at this so basically here we are talking
about replicas being placed in such a
way now somebody could ask a question
can I have my block and its replicas
spread across three racks and yes you
can do that but then in order to make it
more redundant you are increasing your
bandwidth requirement so the better
approach would be two blocks on the same
rack on different machines and one copy
on a different track now let's proceed
how can you restart name node and all
demons in Hadoop so if you were working
on a Apache Hadoop cluster then you
could be doing a start and stop using
Hadoop demon scripts so there are these
Hadoop demon scripts which would be used
to start and stop your Hadoop and this
is when you talk about your Apache
Hadoop so let's look at one particular
file which I would like to show you more
information here and this talks about
your different clusters so let's look
into this and so let's look at the start
and stop and here I have a file let's
look at this one and this gives you
highlights so if you talk about Apache
Hadoop this is how the setup would be
done so you would have it download the
Hadoop tar file you would have to
untarget edit the config files you would
have to do formatting and then start
your cluster and here I have said using
scripts so this is in case of Apache
Hadoop you could be using a start all
script that internally triggers start
DFS and start Yan and these scripts
start DFS internally would run Hadoop
demon multiple times based on your
configs to start your different
processes then your start Yann would run
Yan demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in Apache Hadoop now in
case of cloud error or hoton Works which
is basically a vendor specific
distribution you would have say multiple
Services which would have one or
multiple demons running across the
machines let's take an example here that
you would have machine 1 Machine 2 and
machine 3 with your processes spread
across however in case of cloud era and
hotworks these are cluster Management
Solutions so you would never be involved
in running a script individually to
start and stop your processes in fact in
case of cloud era you would have a cloud
CM server running on one of the machines
and then Cloud CM agents running on
every machine if you talk about hoton
works you would have ambari server and
ambari agent running so your agents
which are running on every machine are
responsible to monitor the processes
send also their heartbeat to the master
that that is your server and your server
is the one or a service which basically
will give instructions to the agents so
in case of vendor specific distribution
your start and stop of processes is
automatically taken care by these
underlying services and these Services
internally are still running these
commands however only in Apache Hadoop
you have to manually follow these to
start and stop coming back we can look
into some command related questions so
which command will help you find the
status of blocks and file system health
so you can always go for a file system
check command now that can show you the
files for a particular hdfs path it can
show you the blocks and it can also give
you information on status such as
underreplicated blocks over replicated
blocks misrep blocks default replication
and so on so your fsck file system check
utility does not not repair if there is
any problem with the blocks but it can
give you information of blocks related
to the files on which machines they are
stored if they are replicated as per the
replication factor or if there is any
problem with any particular replica now
what would happen if you store too many
small files in a cluster and this
relates to the block information which I
gave some time back so remember Hadoop
is coded in Java so here every directory
every file and file iterator block is
considered as an object and for every
object within your Hadoop cluster name
noes Ram gets utilized so more number of
blocks you have more would be usage of
name noes RAM and if you're storing too
many small files it would not affect
your disk it would directly affect your
name noes Ram that's why in production
clusters admin guys or infrastructure
specialist will take care care that
everyone who is writing data to hdfs
follows a quota system so that you could
be controlled in the amount of data you
write plus the count of data and
individual rights on hdfs now how do you
copy data from local system onto sdfs so
you can use a put command or a copy from
local and then given your local path
which is your source and then your
destination which is your sdfs path
remember you can always do a copy from
local using a minus F option that's a
flag option and that also helps you in
writing the same file or a new file to
hdfs so with your minus F you have a
chance of overwriting or rewriting the
data which is existing on sdfs so copy
from local or minus put both of them do
the same thing and you can also pass an
argument when you're copying to control
your replication or other aspects of
your file now when do you use DFS admin
refresh noes or RM admin refresh noes so
as the command says this is basically to
do with refreshing the node information
so your refresh nodes is mainly used
when say a commissioning or
decommissioning of nodes is done so when
a node is added into the cluster or when
a node is removed from the cluster you
are actually
informing master that this particular
node would not be used for storage and
would not be used for processing now in
that case you would be once you are done
with the process of commissioning or
decommissioning you would be giving
these commands that is refresh nodes and
RM admin refresh noes so internally when
you talk about commissioning
decomissioning there are include and
exclude files which are updated and
these include and exclude files files
will have entry of machines which are
being added to the cluster or machines
which are being removed from the cluster
and while this is being done the cluster
is still running so you do not have to
restart your master process however you
can just use these refresh commands to
take care of your commissioning
decommissioning activities now is there
any way to change replication of files
on sdfs after they are already written
and the answer is of course yes so if
you would want to set a replication
Factor
at a cluster level and if you have admin
access then you could edit your sdfs
hyphen site file or you could say Hadoop
hyph site file and that would take care
of replication Factor being set at a
cluster level however if you would want
to change the replication after the data
has been written you could always use a
set rep command so set rep command is
basically to change the replication
after the data is written you could also
write the data with a different
replication and for that you could use a
minus D DFS do replication and give your
application Factor when you're writing
data to the cluster so in Hadoop you can
let your data be replicated as per the
property set in the config file you
could write the data with a different
replication you could change the
replication after the data is written so
all these options are available now who
takes care of replication consistency in
a Hado cluster and what do you mean by
under over replicated blocks now as I
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always an
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same note it would mean
that if your replication is three we
would need at least three data notes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three notes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was a
replication Factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication Factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
dis has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those Miss
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with a
replication of three one of the node
went down due to a network failure or
some other issue within few minutes name
node re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any note that depends on the load on a
particular Noe now we discussed about
Hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about map reduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in map reduce now we know that
when we talk about map reduce the data
which has to be processed might be
existing on multiple nodes so when you
would have your map reduce program
running it would basically read the data
from the underlying diss now this could
be a costly operation if every time the
data has to be read from disk so
distributed cash is a mechanism wherein
data set or data which is coming from
the dis can be cached and available for
all worker nodes now how will this
benefit so when a map reduce is running
instead of every time reading the data
from disk it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your map reduce processing so
distributed Cache can be set in your job
conf where you can specify
that a file should be picked up from
distributed cache now let's understand
about these roles so what is a aord
reader what is a combiner what is a
partitioner and what kind of roles do
they play in a map reduce processing
Paradigm or map reduce operation so
record reader communicates with the
input split and it basically converts
the data into key value Pairs and these
key value pairs are the ones which will
be worked upon by the mapper your
combiner is an optional phase it's like
mini reduce so combiner does not have
its own class it relies on the reducer
class basically your combiner would
receive the data from your map tasks
which which would have completed works
on it based on whatever reducer class
mentions and then passes its output to
the reducer face partitioner is
basically a a phase which decides how
many reduced tasks would be used
aggregate or summarize your data so
partitioner is a phase which would
decide based on the number of keys based
on the number of map tasks your
partitioner would decide if one or
multiple reduced tasks would be used to
take care of processing so either it
could be partitioner which decides on
how many reduced tasks would run or it
could be based on the properties which
we have set within the cluster which
will take care of the number of reduced
TS which would be used always remember
your partitioner decides how outputs
from combiner are sent to reducer and to
how many reducers it controls the
partitioning of keys of your
intermediate map outputs so map face
whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your partitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduced tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face why is map reduce slower in
processing so we know map reduce goes
for parallel processing we know we can
have multiple map tasks running on
multiple nodes at the same time we also
know that multiple reduced task could be
running now why does then map reduce
become a slower approach first of all
your map reduce is a batch oriented
operation Now map reduce
is very rigid and it strictly uses
mapping and reducing phases so no matter
what kind of processing you would want
to do you would have to still provide
the mapper function and the reducer
function to work on data not only this
whenever your map phase completes the
output of your map phase which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying Diss and
this data would then be suffer fed and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from hdfs makes map
reduce a slower approach the question is
for a map reduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created Now by default you cannot change
the number of map tasks because number
of map tasks depends on the input splits
however there are different ways in
which you you can either set a property
to have more number of map tasks which
can be used or you can customize your
code or make it use a different format
which can then control the number of map
tasks by default number of map tasks are
equal to the number of splits of file
you are processing so if you have a 1GB
of file that is split into eight blocks
of 128 MB there would be eight map tasks
running on the cluster these map tasks
are basically running your mapper
function if you have hardcoded
properties in your map red hyphen site
file to specify more number of map tasks
then you could control the number of map
tasks let's also talk about some data
types so when you prepare for Hadoop
when you want to get into Big Data field
you should start learning about
different data formats now there are
different data formats such as AO par
you have uh sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types in Hadoop these are
implementation of your writeable and
writeable comparable interfaces so for
every data type in Java you have a
equivalent in Hadoop so in in Java would
be in writable in Hadoop float would be
float writable long would be long
writable double writable Boolean
writable array writable map writable and
object writable so these are your
different data types that could be used
within your map reduce program and these
are implementation of writeable and
writeable comparable interfaces what is
speculative execution now imagine you
have a cluster which has huge number of
nodes and your data is spread across
multiple SL machines or multiple notes
now at a point of time due to a disk
degrade or network issues or machine
heating up or more load being on a
particular node there can be a situation
where your data node will execute task
in a slower manner now in this case if
speculative execution is turned on there
would be a shadow task or a another
similar task running running on some
other node for the same processing so
whichever task finishes first will be
accepted and the other task would be
killed so speculative execution could be
good if you are working in a intensive
workload kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or having
knowledge of what are the resources
available so if speculative execution as
a property is turned on then the task
which was running slow a copy of that
task or you can say a shadow task would
run on some other node and whichever
task completes first will be considered
this is what happens in your speculative
execution now how is identity m mapper
different from chain mapper now this is
where we are getting deeper into map
reduce Concepts so when you talk about
mapper identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper is
specified in map reduce driver class so
for every map reduce program you would
have a map class which is taking care of
your mapping phase which basically has a
mapper function and which would run one
or multiple map tasks right your program
your program would also have a reduce
class which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple noes now if a
mapper is not specified within your
driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduce class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old map reduce API in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to Second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the undermentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a map reduce
program obviously we need to have the
input location we need to have the
output location so input location is
where the files will be picked up from
and this would preferably on sdfs
directory output location is the path
where your job output would be written
by your map reduce program you also need
to specify input and output formats if
you don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
Driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters which you need
to consider for a map reduce program now
what is the difference or what do you
mean by map side join and reduce site
join map side join is basically when the
join is performed at the mapping level
or at the mapping phase or is performed
by the mapper so each input data which
is being worked upon has to be divided
into same number of partitions input to
each map is in the form of a structured
partition and is in sorted order so
mapsite join you can understand it in a
simpler way that if you compare it with
rdbms Concepts where you had two tables
which were being joined it will always
be advisable to give your bigger table
as the left side table or the first
table for your join condition and it
would be your smaller table on the left
side side and your bigger table on the
right side which basically means the
smaller table could be loaded in memory
and could be used for joining so mapsite
join is a similar kind of mechanism
where input data is divided into same
number of partitions when you talk about
reduced side join here the join is
performed by the reducer so it is easier
to implement than mapsite join as all
the sorting and shuffling will send the
values or send all the values having
identical keys to the same reducer so
you don't need to have your data set in
a structured form so look into your map
side join or reduce site join and other
joins just to understand how map reduce
Works however I would suggest not to
focus more on this because map reduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of map reduce based processing
has decreased overall or across the
industry now what is the role of out
output committer class in a map reduce
job so output committer as the name says
describes the commit of task output for
a map ruce job so we could have this as
mention or gachi Hado map ruce output
committer you could have a class which
extends your output committer class so
map reduce relies on this map reduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to set up the job initialization
cleaning up the job after the job
completion that means all the resources
which were being used by a particular
job setting up the task temporary output
checking whether a task needs a commit
committing the task output and
discarding the task out so this is a
very important class and can be used
within your map ruce job what is the
process of spilling in map ruce what
does that mean so spilling is basically
a process of copying the data from
memory buffer to disk when obviously the
buffer usage reaches a certain threshold
so if there is not enough memory in your
buffer in your memory then the content
which is stored in buffer or memory has
to be flushed out so by default a
background thread starts spilling the
content from memory to disk after 80% of
buffer size is filled now when is the
buffer being used so when your map
reduce processing is happening the data
from data is being read from the desk
loaded into the buffer and then some
processing happens same thing also
happens when you are writing data to the
cluster so you can imagine for a 100
megabyte size buffer the spilling will
start after the content of buffer
reaches 80 megabytes this is
customizable how can you set the mappers
and reducers for a map reduce job so
these are the properties so number of
mappers and reducers as I mentioned
earlier can be customized so by default
your number of map tasks depends on the
split and number number of reduced tasks
depends on the partitioning phase which
decides number of reduced tasks which
would be used depending on the keys
however we can set these properties
either in the config files or provide
them on the command line or also make
them part of our code and this can
control the number of map tasks or
reduced tasks which would be run for a
particular job let's look at one more
interesting question what happens when a
node running a map task fails before
sending the output to the reducer so
there was a node which was running a map
task and we know that there could be one
or multiple map tasks running on one or
multiple notes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other note so in
Hado version two Yan framework has a
temporary de called application master
so your application Master is taking
care of execution of your application
and if a particular task on a particular
node failed due to unavailability of
node it is the role of application
Master to have this task scheduled on
some other note now can we write the
output of map reduc in different formats
of course we can so Hadoop supports
various input and output formats so you
can write the output of map produce in
different formats so you could have the
default format that is text output
format wherein records are written as
line of text you could have sequence
file which is basically to write
sequence files or your binary format
files where your output files need to be
fed into another map reduce jobs you
could go for a map file output format to
write output as map files you could go
for a sequence file as a binary output
format so that's again a variant of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a nonhuman readable
format DV output format now this is
basically used when you would want to
write data to say relational databases
or say nosql databases such as hedge
base so this format also sends the
reduce output to a SQL table now let's
learn a little bit about yan yan which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did Yan bring in hadoo
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of map reduce version one so map
reduce version one had major issues when
it comes to scalability or availability
because sorry in Hadoop version one you
had only one master process for
processing layer and that is your job
tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was responsible for
resource tracking and job scheduling in
Yan you still have a processing Master
but that's called resource manager
instead of job tracker and now with Ado
version two you could even have resource
manager running in in high availability
mode you have node managers which would
be running on multiple machines and then
you have a temporary demon called
application master so in case of Hado
version two your resource manager or
Master is only handling the client
connections and taking care of tracking
the resources the jobs scheduling or
basically taking care of execution
across multiple nodes is controlled by
application Master till the app ation
completes so in Yan you can have
different kind of resource allocations
that could be done and there is a
concept of container so container is
basically a combination of RAM and CPU
course Yan can run different kind of
workloads so it is not just map reduce
kind of workload which can be run on
Hardo version 2 but you could have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have uh realtime processing
and huge processing applications could
run on a cluster based on Yan so when we
talk about scalability in case of your
Hadoop version 2 you can have a cluster
size of more than 10,000 nodes and can
run more than 100,000 concurrent tasks
and this is because for every
application which is launched you have
this temporary Deon called application
master so if I would have 10
applications running I would have 10 app
Masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadu version 2 is
fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per haduk version one and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by Yan so Dynamic allocation of
cluster resources taking care of
different workloads allocating resources
across multiple machines and using them
for execution all that is taken care by
Yan multi- tency which basically means
you could have multiple users or
multiple
teams you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does Yan
allocate resources to an application
with the help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an API which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
I mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
Schuler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources resource manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components so you have a
Schuler which allocates resources to
various running applications so
scheduler is not bothered about tracking
your resources or basically tracking
your applications so we can have
different kind of schedulers such as
fifo which is first in first out you
could have a fair scheduler or you could
have a capacity schuer and these
schedulers basically control how
resources are allocated to multiple
applications when they are running in
parallel so there is a q mechanism so
Schuler will resources based on
requirements of application but it is
not monitoring or tracking the status of
applications your applications manager
is the one which is accepting the job
submissions it is monitoring and
restarting the application Masters so
it's application manager which is
basically then launching a application
Master which is responsible for an
application so this is how it looks so
whenever a job submission happens we
already know that resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of RAM
and CPU cores some portion of resources
that is your RAM and CPU cores are
allocated to node manager now resource
manager is already aware of how much
resources are available across nodes so
whenever a client request comes in
resource manager will make a request to
node manager it will basically request
node manager to hold some resources for
processing node manager would basically
approve or disapprove this request of
holding resources and these resources
that is a combination of RAM and CPU
cores are nothing but containers we can
allocate containers of different sizes
within Yan hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demon called application
Master to take care of your execution so
your app Master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say
internally by applications manager will
run in one of the containers because
application Master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how Yan is basically taking care of your
allocation your application Master is
managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with Schuler and if
a particular node crashes it is the
responsibility of appm to go back to the
master which is resource manager and
negotiate for more resources so your
appm will never ever negotiate resources
with node manager directly it will
always talk to resource manager and
resource manager is the one which
negotiates the resources container as I
said is a collection of resources like
your RAM CPU Network bandwidth and your
container is allocated based on the
availability of resources on a
particular node so which of the
following has occupied the place of a
job tracker of map ruce so it is your
resource manager so resource manager is
the name of the master process in Ado
version 2 now if you would have to write
Yan commands to check the status of an
application we could just say Yan
application minus status and then the
application ID and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
Yan has a UI and you can even look at
your applications from the UI you can
even kill your applications from the UI
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
Yan based cluster yes we can that is
what hadu version to allows us to have
so you can have a high availability yarn
cluster where you have a active and
standby and the coordination is taken
care by your zookeeper at a particular
time there can only be one active
resource manager and if active resource
manager fails your standby resource
manager comes and becomes active however
zuker is playing a very important role
remember zuker is the one which is
coordinating the server State and it is
doing the election of active to standby
failover what are the different
schedulers available in Yan so you have
a feif for scheduler that is first in
first out and this is not a desirable
option because in this case a longer
running application might block all
other small running applications
Your Capacity scheduler is basically a
Schuler where dedicated cues are created
and they have fixed amount of resources
so you can have multiple applications
accessing the cluster at the same time
and they would be using their own cues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about Fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of resources
you can just have a percentage and you
could decide what kind of fairness is to
be followed which basically means that
if you were allocated 20 GB of memory
however the cluster has 100 GB and the
other team was assigned 80 GB of memory
then you have 20% access to the cluster
and other team has 80% however if the
other team does not come up or does not
use the cluster in a fair scheduler you
can go up to maximum of 100% of your
cluster to find out more information
about about your schedulers you could
either look in Hadoop definitive guide
or what you could do is you could just
go to Google and you could type for
example Yan
scheduler let's search for Yan Schuler
and then you can look in Hadoop
definitive guide and so this is your
Hadoop definitive guide and it
beautifully explains about your
different schedulers how do multiple
applications run and that could be in
your fif kind of scheduling it could be
in capacity scheduler or it could be in
a fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for Yan untangling and this is a
Blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource location happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about allocation and so on so
coming back we basically have these
schedulers what happens if a resource
manager fails while executing an
application in a high availability
cluster so in a high availability
cluster we know that we would have two
resource managers one being active one
being standby and zookeeper which is
keeping a track of the server States so
if a RM fails in case of high
availability the standby will be elected
as active and then basically your
resource manager or the standby would
become the active one and this one would
instruct the application Master to abort
in the beginning then your resource
manager recovers its running state so
there is something called as RM State
Store where all the applications which
are running their status is stored so
resource manager recovers it's running
state by looking at your state store by
taking advantage of container statuses
and then continues to take care of your
processing now in a cluster of 10 data
notes each having 16 GB and 10 cores
what would be total processing capacity
of the cluster take a minute to think 10
data nodes 16 GB Ram per node 10 course
so if you mention the answer as 160gb
RAM and 100 cores then you went wrong
now think of a cluster which has 10 data
nodes each having 16 GB RAM and 10
course remember on every node in a Hado
cluster you would have one or multiple
processes running those processes would
need RAM the machine itself which has a
Linux file system would have its own
processes so that would also be having
some RAM usage which basically means
that if you talk about 10 data noes you
should deduct at least 20 to 30% towards
the overheads towards the cloud database
Services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case I
could say that you could have 11 or 12
GB available on every machine for
processing and say six or seven cores
multiply that by 10 and that's your
processing capacity remember the same
thing applies to the dis usage also so
if somebody asks you in a 10 data node
cluster where each machine has 20 tabt
of diss what is my total storage
capacity available for S DFS so the
answer would not be 200 you have to
consider the overheads and this is
basically which gives you your
processing capacity now let's look at
one more question so what happens if
requested memory or CPU course Beyond or
goes beyond the size of container now as
I said you can have your configurations
which can say that in a particular data
node which has 100 GB Ram I could
allocate say 50 GB for the processing I
out of 100 cores I could say 50 cores
for processing so if you have 100 GB RAM
and 100 cores you could ideally allocate
100 for processing but that's not
ideally possible so if you have 100 GB
Ram you would go for 50 GB and if you
have 100 course you would go for 50
course now within this RAM and CPU
course you have the concept of
containers right so container is a
combination of RAM and CPU cores so you
could have a minimum size container and
maximum size container now at any point
of time if your application starts
demanding more memory or more CPU course
and this cannot fit into a container
allocation your application will fail
your application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of wean CPU course which is more than
the maximum container size so look into
this Yan tangling website which I
mentioned and look for the second blog
in those series which explains about
these allocations now here we will
discuss on hive Peg hbase and these
components of do which are being used in
the industry for various use cases let's
look at some questions here and let's
look how you should prepare for them so
first of all we will learn on Hive which
is a data warehousing package so the
question is what are the different
components of a hive architecture now
when we talk about Hive we already know
that Hive is a data warehousing package
which basically allows you to work on
structured data or data which can be
structurized so normally people are well
vered with querying or basically
processing the data using SQL queries a
lot of people come from database
backgrounds and they would find it
comfortable if they know structured
query language Hive is one of the data
warehousing package which resides within
a Hadoop ecosystem it uses hadoop's
distributed file system to store the
data and it uses rdbms usually to store
the metadata although metadata can be
stored locally also so what are the
different components of an Hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
Hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and dup we need odbc or jdbc connector
jar file and that connector jar file has
a driver class now this driver class is
mandatory to create a connection between
Hive and Hadoop so user interface
creates this interface using the driver
now we have meta store meta store stores
the metadata information so any object
which you create such as database table
indexes their metadata is stored in meta
store and usually this meta store is
stored in an rdbms so that multiple
users can connect to hi so your meta
store stores the metadata information
and sends that to the compiler for
execution of a query what does the
compiler do it generates the execution
plan it has a dag now dag stands for
direct cyclic graph so it has a dag of
stages where each stage is either a
metadata operation a map reduce job or
an operation on sdfs and finally we have
execution engine that acts as a bridge
between Hive and Hado to process the
query so execution engine communicates
bidirectionally with metast store to
perform operations like create or drop
tables so these are four important
components of hi architecture now what
is the difference between external table
and manage table in hi so we have
various kinds of table in Hive such as
external table manage table partition
table the major difference between your
managed and external table is in respect
to what happens to the data if the table
is dropped
usually whenever we create a table in
Hive it creates a manage table or we
could also call that as an internal
table now this manages the data and
moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
table or external table usually the data
can reside in hive's default Warehouse
directory or it could be residing in a
location chosen however when we talk
about manage table if one drop drops a
manage table not only the metadata
information is deleted but the table's
data is also deleted from hdfs if we
talk about external table it is created
with an external keyword explicitly and
if an external table is dropped nothing
happens to the data which resides in
sdfs so that's the main difference
between your managed and external table
what might be the use case if somebody
asks you there might be a migration kind
of activity or you you are interested in
creating lot of tables using your
queries so in that case you could dump
all the data on hdfs and then you could
create a table by pointing to a
particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs Also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition in Hive and why is
partitioning required in Hive if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each St T usually has one column
in context of rdbms which could be used
to partition the data and why do we do
that so that we can avoid scanning the
complete table for a query and restrict
the scan to set of data or to a
particular partition in Hive we can have
any number of partition keys so
partitioning provides granularity in hi
table it reduces the query latency by
scanning only relevant partition data
instead of whole data set we can
partition at various levels now if I
compare rdbms with Hive in case of rdbms
you could have one column which could be
used for partitioning and then you could
be squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms your partition column is
usually a part of the table definition
so for example if I have an employee
table I might have employee ID employee
name empy employee age and employee
salary as four columns and I would
decide to partition the table based on
salary column now why would I partition
it because I feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so I could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in Hive
it is a little different in hive you can
do partitioning and there is a concept
of static and dynamic partitioning but
in Hive the partition column is not part
of table definition so you might have an
employee table with employee ID name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on his DFS in that case when we query
the data we we can see the partition
column also showing up so we can
partition the transaction data for a
bank for example based on month like
Chan Feb Etc and any operation regarding
a particular month will then allow us to
query that particular folder that is
where partitioning is useful now why
does hi not store metadata information
in sdfs if somebody asks you so we know
that hive's data is stored in sdfs which
is Hadoop distributed file system
however the metadata is either stored
locally and that mode of high would be
called as embeded mode or you could have
hive's metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for Hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so Hive stores metadata
information in meta store using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access now if somebody asks what are the
components used in Hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation Optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query sub
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in Java
or Java programming language and then
basically these user defined functions
are added to the class path now you
would have a logical plan generation
which basically looks at your query and
then generates a logical plan or the
best execution path which would be
required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
Optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in hve so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using Hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which work when a query is
submitted so these are the components
now let's look a scenario based question
Suppose there are lot of small CSV files
which are present in a sdfs directory
and you want to create a single Hive
table from these files so data in these
files have Fields like registration
number name email address so if this is
what needs to be done what will be your
approach to solve it where will you
create a single Hive table for lots of
small files without degrading the
performance of the system so there can
be different approaches now we know that
there are lot of small CSV files which
are present in a directory so we know
that when we create a table in Hive we
can use a location parameter so I could
say create table give a table name give
the column and their data types I could
specify the D limits and finally I could
say location and then point it to a
directory on sdfs and this directory
might be the directory which has lot of
CSV files so in this case I will avoid
loading the data in the table because
table being Point table pointing to the
directory will directly pick up the data
from one or multiple files and we also
know that Hive does schema check on read
so it does not do a schema check on
write so in case there were one or two
files which did not follow the schema of
the table it would not prevent data
loading data would anyways be loaded
only when you query the data it might
show you null values if data which was
loaded does not follow the schema of the
table this is one approach what is the
other approach so let's look at that you
can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or a
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the D
limiters as it shows here that is row
format and Fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data in text file3
would be storing the data in sequence
file format so we say create table give
the specifications we say row format D
limited fields are terminated by comma
stored as sequence file then we can move
the data from test table into test
sequence file table so I could just say
insert overwrite my new table as select
star from other table remember in Hive
you cannot do insert update delete
however if the table is existing you can
do a insert overwrite from an existing
table into a new table so this could be
one approach where we could have lot of
CSV files or smaller files clued
together as one big sequence file and
then store it in the table now if
somebody asks you write a query to
insert a new column that is integer data
type into a Hi table and the requirement
might be that you would want to insert
this table at a position before an
existing column now that's possible by
doing an alter table giving your table
name and then specif specifying change
column giving you a new column with the
data type before an existing column this
is a simple way wherein you can insert a
new column into a hive table what are
the key differences between Hive and pig
now some of you might have heard Hive is
a data warehousing package and pig is
more of a scripting language both of
them are used for data analysis or Trend
detection hypothesis testing data
transformation and many other use cases
so if We compare Hive and P Hive uses a
declarative language called hiveql that
is Hive querying language similar to SQL
and it is for reporting or for data
analysis even for data transformation or
for your data extraction Pig uses a high
level procedural language called Pig
Latin for programming both of them
remember use map reduce processing
framework so when we run a query in Hive
to process the data or when when we
create and submit a p script both of
them trigger a map reduce job unless and
until we have set them to Local mode
Hive operates on the server side of the
cluster and basically works on structur
data or data which can be structurized
pig usually works or operates on the
client side of the cluster and allows
both structured unstructured or even I
could say semi-structured data Hive does
not support AO file format by default
however that can be done by using the
right serializer deserializer so we can
have Hive table related data stored in
AO format in sequence file format in par
format or even as a text file format
however when we are working on smarter
formats like AO or sequence file or par
we might have to use specific
serializers D serializes for AO this is
the package which allows us to use Avro
format Pig P supports AO format by
default hi was developed by Facebook and
it supports partitioning and pig was
developed by Yahoo and it does not
support partitioning so these are high
level differences there are lots and
lots of differences remember Hive is
more of a data warehousing package and
pig is more of a scripting language or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
Pig which is as I mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses map reduce
although we can even have pig run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about Pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is a patch big different
from map reduce now we all know that map
reduce is a programming model it is it's
quite rigid when it comes to processing
the data because you have to do the
mapping and reducing you have to write
huge code usually map Ru is written in
Java but now it can also be written in
Python it can be written in Scala and
other programming languages so if we
compare Pig with map ruce Pig obviously
is very concise it has less lines of
code when compared to map reduce now we
also know that pig script internally
will trigger a map reduce job however
user need not know about map reduce
programming model they can simply write
simple scripts in Pig and that will
automatically be converted into map
reduce however map ruce has more lines
of code pig is highlevel language which
can easily perform join operations or
other data processing operations map
reduce is a low-level language which
cannot perform job join operations
easily so we can do join using map
reduce however it's not really easy in
comparison to Pig now as I said on
execution every Pig operator is
converted internally into a map reduce
job so every P script which is run which
would be converted into map reduce job
now map reduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a map reduce
job or when it is triggered by pi script
Pig works with all versions of Hadoop
and when we talk about map reduce
program which is written in one Hadoop
version may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you're using what programming
language you have used and what version
of aoop you are working on so these are
the main differences between between
Apache Pig and map ruce what are the
different ways of executing Pig script
so you could create a script file store
it in pig or do text and then you could
execute it using the pig command you
could be bringing up the grunt shell
that is Pig's shell now that usually
starts with map reduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run Pig embedded as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your pig script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of Hive different components of pig even
different components which are involved
in Hadoop ecosystem so when we want to
learn about major components of pig
execution environment here are some so
you have pig scripts now that is written
in pig latin using built-in operators
and user defined functions and submit it
to the execution environment that's what
happens when you would want to process
the data using p now there is a parser
which does type checking and checks the
syntax of the script the output of parer
is a tag direct a cyclic graph so look
in Wikipedia for dag so dag is basically
a sequence of steps which run in One
Direction then you have an Optimizer now
this Optimizer performs optimization
using merge transform split Etc it aims
to reduce the amount of data in the
pipeline that's the whole purpose of
Optimizer you have a internal compiler
so pick compiler converts the optimized
code into a map reduce job and here user
need not know the map reduce programming
model or how it works or how it is
written they all need to know about
running the pick script which would be
internally converted into a map reduce
job and finally we have an execution
engine so map reduce jobs are submitted
to the execution engine to generate the
desired results so these are major
components of pig execution environment
now let's learn about different complex
data types in pig pig supports various
data types the main ones are Tuple bag
and map what is Tuple or Tuple as you
might have heard a tuple is an ordered
set of fields which can contain
different data types for each field so
in Array you would have multiple
elements but that would be of same types
list can also have different types your
Tuple is a collection which has
different fields and each field can be
of different type now we could have an
example as 1 comma 3 or 1 comma 3 comma
a string or a float element and all of
that form a tuple bag is a set of tuples
so that's represented by curly braces so
you could also imagine this like a
dictionary which has various different
collection elements what is a map map is
a set of key value pairs used to
represent data so when you work in Big
Data field you need to know about
different data types which are supported
by Pig which are supported by Hive which
are supported in other components of a
do so Tuple bag map array array buffer
you can think about list you can think
about dictionaries you can think about
map which is key value pair so these are
your different complex data types other
than the primitive data types such as
integer character string Boolean float
and so on now what are the various
diagnostic operators available in Apache
Pig so these are some of the operators
or options which you can give in a pig
script you can do a dump now dump
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either I could do a dump and see the
output on the screen or I can even do a
dump into and I I could store my output
in a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator in Pig and then
Pig also has different internal storage
like Json loader or pick storage which
can be used if you're working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or seen on the screen you also
have a describe operator now that is
used to view the schema of a relation so
you can load the data and then you can
view the schema of relation using
describe operator explain as we might
already know displays the physical
logical and map reduce execution plans
so normally in rdbms when we use xplain
we would like to see what happens behind
the scenes when a particular script or a
query runs so we could load the data
using load operator as in any other case
and if we would want to display The
Logical physical and map reduce use
execution plans we could use explain
operator there is also an illustrate
operator now that gives the stepbystep
execution of sequence of statements so
sometimes when we would want to analyze
our script to see how good or bad they
are or would that really serve our
purpose we could use illustrate and
again you can test that by loading the
data using load operator and you could
just use a illustrate operator to have a
look at the stepbystep execution of the
sequence of t statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in Apache
P now if somebody asks State the usage
of group order by and distinct keywords
in pig script so as I said pig is a
scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
VAR variable or you can give some other
name and you can say group relation Name
by age now say I have a file where I
have field various fields and one of the
field is a relation name so I could
group that by a different field order by
is used to display the contents of
relation in a sorted order whether
ascending or descending so I could
create a variable called relation 2 and
then I could say order relation name one
by ascending or descending order this
syn basically removes the duplicate
records and it is implemented only on
entire records not on individual records
so if you would like want to find out
the distinct values and relation name
field I could use distinct what are the
relational operators in pig so you have
various relational operators which help
data scientists or data analyst or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as co-group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a cartisan product of two or
more relations for each is basically to
do some iteration so if it will iterate
through tupal of a relation generating a
data transformation so for example if I
say variable a equals and then I load a
file in a and then I could create a
variable called B where I could say for
each a I would want to do something say
group join is to join two or more tables
in a relation limit is to limit the
number of output tuples or output
results split is to split the relation
into two or more relations Union is to
get a combination that's it will merge
the contents of two or more relations
and order is to get a sorted result so
these are some relational operators
which are extensively used in pig for
analysis what is the use of having
filters in Apache Pig now say for
example I have some data which has three
Fields ear product quantity and this is
my phone sales data so filter operator
could be used to select the required
values from a relation based on a
condition it also allows you to remove
unwanted records from data file so for
example filter the products where
quantity is greater than thousand so I
see that I have one row wherein or
multiple rows where the quantity is
greater than th000 such as 1500 1700
1200 so I could create a variable called
a I would load my file using pck storage
as I explained earlier pck storage is an
internal parameter which can be used to
specify the D limits now here my D
limiter is comma so I could say using
pick storage as and then I could specify
the data type for each field so ear
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then B
I could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than th000 so it's
very concise it's very simple and it
allows us to extract and process data in
a simpler way now Suppose there is a
file called test.txt having 150 records
in his DFS so this is a file which is
stored on his DFS and it has 150 records
where we can consider every record being
one line and if somebody asks you to
write a pick command to retrieve the
first 10 records of the file first we
will have to load the data so I could
create a variable called testore data
and I would say load my file using pick
storage specifying the D limiter as
comma as and then I could specify my
Fields whatever Fields our file have and
then I would want to get only 10 records
for which I could use the limit operator
so I could say limit on test data and
give me 10 records this is very simple
and we can extract 10 records from 150
records which are St stored in the file
on sdfs now we have learned on Pig we
have learned some questions on hive you
could always look more in books like
programming in Hive or programming in
Pig and look for some more examples and
try out these examples on a existing
Hadoop setup now let's learn on hbase
which is a no SQL database now hbase is
a four dimensional database in
comparison to your rdbms which usually
are two-dimensional so rdbms have rows
and columns but H base has four
coordinates it has row key which is
always unique column family which can be
any number column qualifiers which can
again be any number per column family
and then you have a version so these
four coordinates make hedge base a four
dimensional key value store or a column
family store which is unique for storing
huge amount of data and extra extracting
data from hbas there is a very good link
which I would suggest everyone can look
at if you would want to learn more on
hbase and you could just say hbase
mapper and this basically brings up a
documentation which is from map R but
then that's not specific to map R and
you can look at this link which will
give you a detailed explanation of hpas
how it works what are the Architectural
Components and how data is stored and
how it makes Edge BAS a very powerful
nosql database so let's learn on some of
the important or critical questions on
hbase which might be asked by the
interviewer in an interview when you're
applying for a big data admin or a
developer position role so what are the
key components of hbas now as I said
this is one of the favorite questions of
interviewers where they would want to
understand your knowledge on different
components for a particular Service
hbase as I said is a no SQL database and
that comes as a part of service with
Cloud era or hotton works and with
Apache Hadoop you could also set up hbas
as an independent package so what are
the key components of hbas hbase has a
region server now hbas follows the
similar kind of topology like Hado now
Hadoop has a master process that is name
node and slave processes such as data
nodes and secondary name node in the
same way hbase also has a master which
is H master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually collocated with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have 100 data nodes you would
have 100 region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbas tables that are divided
horizont onally into regions or you
could say group of rows is called
regions so in HED base you have two
aspects one is group of columns which is
called column family and one is group of
rows which is called regions now these
regions or these rows are grouped based
on the key values or I would say row
Keys which are always unique when you
store your data in hge base you would
have data in the form of rows and
columns so group of rows are called
regions or you could say these are
horizontal partitions of the table so a
region server manages these regions on
the Node where a data node is running a
region server can have up to 1,000
regions it runs on every node and
decides the size of region so region
server as I said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbas
data on the Node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
collocated with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of hbas as
I said you have H hm so you would always
have a connection coming in from a
client or an application what does
hmaster do it assigns regions it
monitors the region servers it assigns
regions to region servers for load
balancing and it cannot do that without
the help of Zookeeper so if we talk
about components of hbas there are three
main components you have zookeeper you
have hmaster and you have region server
region server being the slave process
your hm being the master process which
takes care of all your table operations
assigning regions to the region servers
taking care of read and write request
which come from client and for all of
this Edge Master will take in help help
of Zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service so whenever a
client wants to read or write or change
the schema or any other metadata
operations it will contact edgm edgm
internally will contact zookeeper so you
could have hbas setup also in high
availability mode where you could have a
active edgm and a backup Edge Master you
would have a zookeeper Corum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized C ination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as
three five and 7 because zookeeper works
on the concept of majority consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status for every server with
zookeeper is monitor ing zookeeper keeps
a session alive with that particular
server EDM would always check with
zookeeper which region servers are
available alive so that regions can be
assigned to the region server at one end
you have region server which are sending
their status to the Zookeeper indicating
if they are ready for any kind of read
or write operation and at other end H
Master is querying the Zookeeper to
check the status now zookeeper
internally manages a meta table now that
meta table will have information of
which regions are residing on which
region server and what rois those
regions contain so in case of a read
activity hmas will query zookeeper to
find out the region server which
contains that meta table once hedm gets
the information of meta table it can
look into the meta table to find out the
row keys and the corresponding region
servers which contain the regions for
those row Keys now if we would want to
understand row key and column families
in h base let's look at this and it
would be good if we could look this on
an Excel sheet so row key is always
unique it acts as a primary key for any
h-based table it allows logical grouping
of cells and makur that all cells with
the same row key are collocated on the
same server so as I said you have four
coordinates for hedge Bas you have a row
key which is always unique you have
column families which is nothing but
group of columns and when I say column
families one column family can have any
number of columns so when I talk about
hbase H base is four-dimensional and in
terms of hbase it is also called as a
column oriented database which basically
means that every Row in one column could
have a different data type now you have
a row key which uniquely identifies the
row you have column families which could
be one or many depending on how the
table has been defined and a column
family can have any number of columns or
I could say for every row within a
column family you could have different
number of columns so I could say for my
Row one I could just have two columns
such as name and City within the column
family for my row two I could have name
City age design ation salary for my
third row I could have thousand columns
and all that could belong to one column
family so this is a horizontally
scalable database so column family
consists of group of columns which is
defined during table creation and each
column family can have any number of
column qualifiers separated by a d
limiter now a combination of row key
column family column qualifier such as
name City age and the value within the
cell is makes the hge base a unique
four-dimensional database for more
information if you would want to learn
on hbase please refer this link which is
hbase mapper and this gives a complete
hbase architecture that is three
components of name node uh three
components that is name node region
servers and zookeeper how it works how H
hedm interacts with zookeeper what Zuki
but does in coordination how are the
components working together and how does
HB take care of read and write coming
back and continuing why do we need to
disable a table so there are different
table operations what you can do in
hedge Bas and one of them is disabling a
table now if you would want to check the
status of table you could check that by
is disabled and giving the table name or
is enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
Maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
or change it settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in hbas now
to interact with hbas one could either
use a graphical user interface such as
Hue or you could be using the command
line hbas shell or you could be using
base ATB API if you are working with
Java or say happy base if you're working
with python where you may want to open a
connection with hbas so that you can
work with hbas programmatically in that
case we have to create a configuration
object that is configuration my conf and
then create a configuration object and
then you can use different classes like
H table interface to work on a new table
you could use H column qu ifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbas admin API what does replication
mean in terms of hbas so hedge Bas as I
said Works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbas cluster
to other hbas cluster so this
replication feature in hbase provides a
mechanism to copy data between clusters
or sync the data between different
clusters this feature can be used as a
Disaster Recovery Solution that provides
High availability for hbas so if I have
hbase cluster one where I have one
master and multiple region servers
running in a Hadoop cluster I could use
the same Hadoop cluster to create a
hbase replica cluster or I could have a
totally different h-based replica
cluster where my intention is that if
things are changing in a particular
table in cluster one I would want them
to be replicated across different
cluster so I could alter the HB table
and set the replication scope to one now
a replication scope of zero indicates
that table is not replicated but if we
set the replication to one we basically
will have to set up a hbas cluster where
we can replicate hbas tables data from
cluster one to Cluster so these are the
commands which can be used to enable
replication and then replicate the data
of table across clusters can we Import
and Export in hbase of course we can it
is possible to to Import and Export
tables from one hbas cluster to other
hbas cluster or even within a cluster so
we can use the hbas export utility which
comes in this particular package give a
table name and then a Target location so
that will export the data of hbase table
into a directory on sdfs then I could
create a different table which would
follow some kind of same definition as
the table which was exported and then I
could use import to import the data from
the directory on hdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase Import
and Export you could look at hbas import
operations let's search for the link and
this is the link where you could learn
more about hedge base import export
utilities how you could do a bulk import
bulk export which internally uses map
produce and then you could do a Import
and Export into hbas tables moving for
further what do we mean by compaction in
hbas now we all know that hbas is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is return in hbase it is
first return to what we call as WR ahead
log and also to mem store which is right
cache now once the data is written in
wall and your mem store it is offloaded
to form an internal hbas format file
which is called H file and you usually
these edge files are very small in
nature so we also know that hdfs is good
when we talk about few number of larger
files in comparison to large number of
smaller files due to the limitation of
name noes memory compaction is process
of merging hbase files that is these
smaller H files into a single large file
this is done to reduce the amount of
memory required to store the files and
number of disk seeks needed so we could
have lot of hedge files which get
created when the data is written to hge
Bas and these smaller files can then be
compacted through a major or minor
compaction creating one big Edge file
which internally would then be return to
sdfs and sdfs format of blocks that is
the benefit of compaction there is also
a feature called Bloom filter so how
does Bloom filter work so Bloom filter
or hbase Bloom filter is a mechanism to
test whether a h file contains a
specific row or a row column cell Bloom
filter is named after its creator Burton
hward Bloom it is a data structure which
predicts whether a given element is a
member of a set of data it provides an
inmemory index structure that reduces
the disk reads and determines the
probability of finding a row in a
particular file this is one of very
useful features of hbase which allows
for faster access and avoids disk seeks
does hbas have any concept of namespace
so namespace is when you have similar
elements grouped together so Nam space
yes hbas supports Nam space so namespace
is a logical grouping of tables
analogous to a database in rdbms so you
can create hbas Nam space to the schema
of rdbms database so you could create a
namespace by saying create namespace and
giving it a name and then you could also
list the tables within a nam space you
could create tables within a specific
name space now this is usually done in
production environment where a cluster
might be multi-tenant cluster and there
might be different users of the same
nosql database in that case admin would
create specific name space and for
specific name space you would have
different directories on hdfs and users
of a particular business unit or a team
can work on their Edge Bas objects
within a specific name space this is a
question which is again very important
to understand about the rights or reads
so how does WR ahead log wall help when
a region server crashes now as I said
when a write happens it will happen into
mem store and wall that is your edit log
or write ahead log so whenever a write
happens it will happen in two places mem
store which is the right cache and wall
which is a edit log only when the data
is written in both these places and
based on the limitation of mem store the
data will be flushed to create an hbase
format file called H file these files
are then compacted and created into one
bigger file which will then be stored on
sdfs and sdfs data as we know is stored
in the form of blocks on the underlying
data noes so if a region server hosting
a mem store crashes now where is region
server running that would be collocated
with data node so if a data node crashes
or if a region server which was hosting
the mem store right cache crashes data
in memory the data that in memory which
was not persisted is lost now how does
hbas recover from this as I said your
data is return into wall and mem store
at the same time hbas recovers against
that by writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a right happens it
happens in M store and wall at the same
time hbas cluster keeps a wall to record
changes as they happen and that's why we
call it as also an edit log if hbas goes
down or the node that goes down the data
that was not flushed from M store to H
file can be recovered by replaying the
right ahead log and that's the benefit
of your edit log or write ahead log now
if we would have to write hbas command
to list the contents and update the
column families of a table I could just
do a scan and that would give me
complete data of a table if you are very
specific and if you would want to look
at a particular row then you could do a
get table name and then give the row key
however you could do a scan to get the
complete data of a particular table you
could also do a describe to see what are
the different column families and if you
would want to alter the table and add a
new column family it is very simple you
can just say say alter give the hbas
table name and then give you a new
column family name which will then be
added to the table what are catalog
tables in hbas so as I mentioned your
zookeeper knows the location of this
internal catalog table or what we call
as The Meta table now catalog tables in
hedge Bas have two tables one is hbas
meta table and one is hyphen root the
catalog table hbas meta exists as an
hbas table and is filtered out of hbase
shells list command so if I give a list
command on hbas it would list all the
tables which hbase contains but not the
meta table it's an internal table this
meta table keeps a list of all regions
in the system and location of hbas meta
stored in Zookeeper so if somebody wants
to find out or look for particular rows
they need to know the regions which
contain that data and those regions are
located on region server to get all this
information one has to look into this
meta table however we will not be
looking into meta table directly we
would just be giving a write or a read
operation internally your hbas master
queries The Zookeeper zookeeper has the
information of where the meta table
exists and that meta table which is
existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of The Meta table what is
hotspotting in hbase and how to avoid
hot spotting now this is a common
problem and always admin guys or guys
who are managing the infrastructure
would think about it so one of the main
idea is that edge Bas would be
leveraging the benefit of sdfs your all
read and write request should be
uniformly distributed across all of the
region and region servers otherwise
what's the benefit of having a
distributed cluster so you would have
your data stored across region servers
in the form of regions which are
horizontal partitions of the table and
whenever read and write requests happen
they should be uniformly distributed
across all the regions in the region
servers now hotspotting occurs when a
given region serviced by a region server
receives most or all of read and write
request which which is basically a
unbalanced way of read write operations
now hotspot can be avoided by designing
the row key in such a way that data
being written should go to multiple
regions across the cluster so you could
do techniques such as salting hashing
reversing the key and many other
techniques which are employed by users
of hbase we need to just make sure that
when the regions are distributed across
region servers they should should be
spread across region servers so that
your read and write request can be
satisfied from different region servers
in parallel rather than all read and
write request hitting the same region
server overloading the region server
which may also lead to the crashing of a
particular region server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which I specified in
during my discussion and that that gives
you a detailed explanation of how hbas
works you can also look into hbas
definitive guide by oilly or hbas in
action and these are really good books
to understand about Edge based internals
and how it works now that we have
learned on hive which is a data
warehousing package we have learned on
Pig which is a scripting or a scripting
language which allows you to do data
analysis and we have learned some
questions on a nosql database just noted
that there are more than 225 nosql
databases existing in market and if you
would want to learn and know about more
no SQL databases you can just go to
Google and type
nosql databases or and that will take
you to the link which is for no SQL
databases and this shows there are more
than
225 nosql databases existing in market
and these are for different use cases
you used by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which I would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data inje tools some are for
structur data some are for streaming
data some are for data governance some
are for data ingestion and
transformation
and so on so have a look at this link
which also gives you a comparison of
different data ingestion tools so here
let's learn about some questions on
scoop which is one of the data injection
tools mainly used for structured data or
you could say data which is coming in
from rdbms or data which is already
structured and you would want to ingest
that you would want to store that on
sdfs which could then be used for Hive
which could be used for any kind of
processing using map reduce or Hive or
pig or spark or any other processing
Frameworks or you would want to load
that data into say high verage Bas
Stables scoop is mainly for structured
data it is extensively used when
organizations are migrating from rdbms
to a big data platform and they would be
interested in ingesting the data that is
doing Import and Export of data from
rdbm M to sdfs or vice versa so let's
learn about some important questions on
scoop which you may be asked by an
interviewer when you apply for a big
data related position how is scoop
different from flum so this is a very
common question which is asked scoop
which is mainly for structured data so
scoop works with rdbms it also works
with no SQL databases to Import and
Export data so you can import data into
sdfs
you can import data into Data
warehousing packets such as Hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from Hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
Flume Flume is more of a data inje tool
which works with streaming data or
unstructured data so data which is
constantly getting generated for example
log files or metrics from server or some
chat messenger and so on so if you're
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbas you could be
using Flume there could be other tools
also like Kafka or storm or Chuka or
samza nii and so on scoop however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scoop is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is all already stored in
rdbms in terms of Flume it is completely
event driven that is as the messages or
as the events happen as the data is
getting generated you can have that data
ingested using Flume scoop works with
structured data sources and you have
various scoop connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as MySQL Oracle db2 Microsoft SQL
Server you have different connectors
which are available Flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms Flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
to many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of Flume you have components
such as your Source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scoop and Flo what are the different
file formats to import data using scoop
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scoop
when you talk about scoop you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when I want to import data
from an rdbms I could get that data in
sdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so I could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to Output
files with d limitter between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scoop so to learn more about your
scoop and different arguments which are
available you can click on scoop.
apache.org you can look into the
documentation and I would suggest
choosing one of the versions and looking
into the user guide and here you can
search for arguments and look for
specific control arguments which show
how you can import data using scoop so
here we have common arguments and then
you also have import control arguments
wherein we have different options like
getting data as AO as sequence file as
text file or Park file these are
different formats you can also get data
in default compression scheme that is
gzip or you can specify compression codc
and then you can specify What
compression mechanism you would want to
use when you're importing your data
using Schoop when it comes to default
format for Flume we could say sequence
file which is a binary format that
stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as Java classes and scoop
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scoop you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as I mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
AO par sequence file that is binary
format or machine readable format and
then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if I look in uh the content and here
I could search for a scoop based file
where I have listed down some examples
so if I would want to use different
compression schemes here are some
examples have a look at these so I'm
doing a scoop import I'm also giving an
argument so that scoop which also
triggers a map reduce job or I would say
map only job so when you run a scoop
import it triggers a map only job no
reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line map R.F framework.
name name so that you could run your map
only job in a local mode to save time or
that would interact with Yan and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
username and password give the table
name give a Target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
I could say minus Z to get data in a
compressed format that is gz or I could
be specifying compression codc and then
I could specify What compression codc I
would want to use say Snappy bzip lz4
default I could also run a query by
giving a scoop import and when I'm
specifying a query I if you notice I've
not given any table name because that
would be included in the query I can get
my data as a sequence file format which
is a binary format which will create a
huge file so we could also have
compression enabled and then I could say
the output of my map job should use a
compression at record level for my data
coming in sequence file so sequence file
or a binary format supports compression
at record level or at Block Level I
could get my data in a AO file where
data has embedded schema within the file
or a park file also so these are
different ways in which you can set up
different compression schemes or you can
even get data in different formats and
you could be doing a simple scoop import
for these looking further what is the
importance of eval tool in scoop so
there is something called as eval tool
so scoop eval tool allows users to
execute user defined queries against
respective database servers and preview
the result in the console so either I
could be running a straightaway query to
import the data into my hdfs or I could
just use scoop eval connect to my
external rdbms specify my username and
password and then I could be giving in a
query to see what would be the result of
the query which we intend to import now
let's learn about how scoop imports and
exports data between rdbms and sdfs with
its architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scoop import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scoop lib folder so
scoop import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks now that depends
on your scoop command you could be
specifying that you would want to do a
import only in one task or in multiple
tasks these multiple map tasks will then
run on a section of data from rdbms and
then store it in sdfs so at high level
we could say scoop will introspect
database to get gather the metadata it
divides the input data set into splits
and this division of data into splits
mainly happens on primary key column of
the table now if somebody might ask what
if my table in rdbms does not have a
primary key column then when you're
doing a scoop import either you will
have to import it using one mapper task
by specifying hyphen hyphen m equals 1
or you would have to say split by
parameter to specify a numeric column
from rdbms and that's how you can import
the data let me just show you a quick
example on this so I could just look in
again into the scoop command file and
here we could be looking at an example
so if you see this one here we are
specifying minus - M = 1 which basically
means I would want to import the data
using one map task now in this case
whether the table has a primary key
column or does not have a primary key
column will not matter but if I say a
minus- ms6 where I'm specifying multiple
map tasks to be imported then this will
look for a primary key column in the
table which you importing now if the
table does not have a primary key column
then I could be specifying a split by
and then specify the column so that the
data could be split into multiple chunks
and multiple map tasks would take it now
if the second scenario is your table
does not have a primary key column and
it does not have a numeric column on
which you could do a split Buy in that
case and if you would want to use
multiple mappers you could still say
split Buy on a textual column but you
will have to add this property so that
it allows splitting the data which is
non-numeric all of these options are
given in the scoop apache.org link going
further house scoop imports and exports
data between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so as I said it submits the
map only job to the cluster and then it
basically does a import or export so if
we are exporting the data from sdfs in
that case again there would be a map
only job it would look at multiple
splits of the data which is existing
which your map only job would process
through one or multiple map task and
then export it to to rdbms suppose you
have a database test DB in MySQL we if
somebody asked you to write a command to
connect this database and import tables
to scoop so here is a quick example as I
showed you in the command file so you
could say scoop import this is what we
would want to do you connect using jdbc
now this will only work if the jdbc
connector already exists within your
scoop lib directory admin has to set up
that so you can connect to your rdbms
you can point to the database so here
our database name is testore DB I could
give username and then either I could
give password on the command line or
just say capital P so that I would be
prompted for the password and then I
could give the table name which I would
want to import I could also be
specifying minus minus M and specify how
many map tasks do I want to use for this
import as I showed in previous screen
how to export a table back to rdbms now
for this we need the data in a directory
on hdfs so for example there is a
department stable in retail database
which is already imported into scoop and
you need to export this table back to
rdbms so this is the content of the
table now create a new Department table
in rdbms so I could create a table
specifying the column names whether that
supports null or know if that has a
primary key column which is always
recommended and then I can do a scoop
export I can connect to the rdbms
specifying my username and password
specify the table into which you want to
export the data and then you give export
directory pointing to a directory on
hdfs which contains the data this is how
you can export data into table seeing
example on this so I could again look
into my file and and here I have an
example of import this is where you are
importing data directly into hi and you
have scoop import where you are
importing data directly into hbase table
and you can then query your hbas table
to look at the data you could also do a
export by running your map only job in a
local mode connecting to the rdbms
specifying your username specifying the
table where you would want export and
the directory on stfs where you have
kept the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further what
is the role of jdbc driver in scoop
setup so as I said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odvc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard Java API which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class and this driver class
enables the connection between your
rdbms and your Hado structure each
database vendor is responsible for
writing their own implementation that
will allow communication with the
corresponding database and we need to
download the drivers which allow our
scoop to connect to external rdbms so
your jdbc driver alone is not enough to
connect to scoop we also need connectors
to interact with different database so a
connector is a plugable piece that is
used to fetch metadata and allows scoop
to overcome the differences in SQL
dialects so this is how connection can
be established so normally your admins
would when they are setting up scoop and
Hadoop they would download say MySQL
jdbc connector and this is how they
would go to the MySQL connectors if you
are connecting to mySQL similarly for
your other rdbms you could be say going
in here you could be looking for or a
previous version depending you could be
going for platform independent and then
you could be downloading the connector
jar file now if you untar this jar file
you would see a MySQL connector jar and
if we look in
com. MySQL do
jdbc com. MySQL jdbc driver so this is
the package which is within the
connector jar file and this this has the
driver class which allows the connection
of your scoop with your rdbms so these
things will have to be done by your
admin so that you can have your scoop
connecting to an external rdbms now how
do you update the columns that are
already exported so if I do a export and
I put my data in rdbms can I really
update the columns that are already
exported yes I can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
Remains the Same the only thing I will
have to specify now is the table name
your Fields terminated by if you have a
specific D limiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in
rdbms what is cod genin so scoop
commands translate into your map reduce
job or map app only job so Cod gen is
basically a tool in scoop that generates
data access objects Dao Java classes
that encapsulate and interpret imported
records so if I do a scoop code gen
connect to an rdbms using my username
and give a table this will generate a
Java code for employee table in the test
database so this code gen can be useful
for us to understand what data we have
in this particular table finally can
scope be used to convert data in
different formats I think I already
answered that right if no which tools
can be used for this purpose so scope
can be used to convert data in different
formats and that depends on the
different arguments which you use when
you do a import such as AO file PAR file
binary format with record or Block Level
compression so if you're interested in
knowing more on different data form mats
then I think I can suggest a link for
that and we can say doop uh
formats I think it is TE Magie AO par
Let's see we can find either the Link
tech Maggie yeah this is a very good
link which specifies or talks about
different data formats which you should
know such as your text file format
different compression schemes how is
data organization what are the common
formats what do you have in text file
structured binary sequence files with
compression without compression what is
record level what is Block Level what is
a AO data file what is a SQL what is a
par data file or a columnar format and
other formats like orc RC and so on so
please have a look at this link I hope
this will be helpful in your interviews
with that we've reached the end of this
complete Hardo tutorial for beginners I
hope you enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from Simply
[Music]
learn